HEARING ON THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
TODAY OUR FOCUS IS
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES IN THE
COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. I HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
INSTRUCTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. I
WILL CURRENTLY SKIP- THE PART
FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM AND
FOCUS ON THE PANELISTS AS ALL
PANELISTS WHO ARE ON THE AGENDA
OR APPEARING REMOTELY USING
ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. THERE WILL
BE NO VOTE IN THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE. THE
PHONE NUMBER TECHCONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND ALSO
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET
BUT THE NUMBER IS TOLL FREE.
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO.
IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. ALL
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE TAKING
ON THE ON ALL ISSUES ON THE
AGENDA INCLUDING THE NON
PRESENTATION ITEMS ISSUES THREE
AND FOUR AT THE END OF THE
HEARING UPON CONCLUSION OF
ISSUED TO. I'M GONNA OPEN.
TODAY'S OPENING REMARKS IF I
CAN IN SPANISH AND THEN TO BE
INTENTIONAL IN DOING IT-
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S- IMPORTANT
FOR US TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE ALL
DON'T COME FROM THE SAME PLACE.
LATELINE THURMAN THE CALIFORNIA
THE PHOENIX AT THE LOS LAS
PERSONAS CON THIS COPY SEE THAT
IS THAT THIS OUT- YOU'LL TEN IN
LOS MEANS MOST THAT
INTRINSICALLY GODLESS QUE OTRAS
PERSONAS. AL MISMO TIEMPO NO
TOLD US LAS PERSONAS CON THIS
GOT BC THAT IS BEING IN THE
ARMY'S MULU LOUD AUTONOMA MEANS
MOST OPPORTUNITY. THAT IS OLD
RECORDS TRUCKS- MOBILE THEM
MOST GEARED UP ALONG. FOR US TO
GO TO A EAGLE DIE. ON THE Y. IT
A SCHOOL RUN HE THEY LINGUAE.
L. MODEL THEY PROMOTE TAUGHT US
ASSEMBLY BLEND COMMUNE SUCK.
BETTER WAS TO FREEZE HIM. THE
FROM AN ACTIVE K. HAS TO FIND
THAT ALL PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES HAVE
THE SAME LEGAL RIGHTS AS OTHER
PEOPLE. AND YET AT THE SAME
TIME NOT ALL PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES COME
FROM THE SAME PLACE AND HAVE
THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES AND
RESOURCES. HOW CAN WE CONTINUE
TO ADVOCATE FOR EQUALITY WHEN
THERE ARE CULTURAL AND LANGUAGE
BARRIERS. THE PROMOTE TOTEM
MODEL IS A GOOD START BUT IS
THAT ENOUGH. THAT THEME OF IS
THAT ENOUGH IS IMPORTANT FOR US
TO ADDRESS AS WE ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
FRAMING COMMENTS TODAY INSIST
THAT WE HAVE A PUBLIC FACING
THE DASHBOARD ON VACCINE ACCESS
SPECIFICALLY FOR DISABILITY
COMMUNITY. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
TODAY MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
FLEXIBILITY AS CODIFIED IN
EXTENDED BEYOND THE MONTH TO
MONTH THAT CURRENTLY IS
HAPPENING. AND I'D LIKE US TO
ADDRESS DIRECTLY THE SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE. THAT TREATS POLICIES
THAT ARE FUNDAMENTALLY.
FUNDAMENTALLY ON GOING AND
NATURE AS IF THEY ARE
TEMPORARY. I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART FOR US TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CORRECT DURING
THIS HEARING WANTED TO START
TODAY BY FRAMING THOSE COMMENTS
SO THAT WE COULD HEAR THAT. THE
WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN OUR
FIRST PANEL. FOR THE PANELISTS
WHO WILL BE PRESENTING YOUR
ORDER OF THE TO ME YOU WILL
PRESENT IN THE ORDER THAT YOUR
NAME APPEAR IN THE AGENDA. AND
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
THE INFORMATION THAT IS
REQUESTED IN THE AGENDA. FOR
THIS FIRST PANELIST WE HAVE
EIGHT PRESENTERS AND WE WILL
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES DIRECTOR
NANCY PARCHMENT. WE WILL HOLD
ALL MEMBERS QUESTIONS UNTIL
AFTER ALL OF THE PANELISTS HAVE
CONCLUDED. AND WITH THAT CAN WE
PLEASE BEGAN WITH ISSUE ONE.
THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA AND-
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
ALSO WANT TO- EXPRESSED
GRATITUDE TO- STAFF FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE AGENDA THAT IS-
FRAMING OUR CONVERSATIONS
TODAY. I'M AS NOTED I HAD- A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO RESPOND TO- SO WITH-
STARTING ON ON THE FIRST COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS I DO WANT TO.
ESTABLISH A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
FRAMEWORK AND STAGE FOR WHERE
WE ARE IN ON THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE IN PASSED AWAY. TO
KOBE WHILE MR SEVEN CASH WHO IS
OUR CHIEF DATA ANALYTICS AND
STRATEGY- DEPUTY THAT IS GOING
TO FOCUS ON ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND IN THE NEXT SET
OF QUESTIONS- AS OF FEBRUARY
NINTH WE HAD- 1-300-040-0403
INDIVIDUALS SERVED BY REGIONAL
CENTERS WHO TESTED POSITIVE FOR
CARPET. AND SADLY WE HAD FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE TESTED POSITIVE HAVE
PASSED AWAY. 69% OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WERE POSITIVE WERE
REPORTED ON OR AFTER. DECEMBER
FIRST 59% OF THOSE WHO HAVE
PASSED WERE REPORTED ON OR
AFTER DECEMBER FIRST SO YOU CAN
SEE THE RECENT SURGE REALLY HAD
A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. YOU ARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE-
THROUGH THE REGIONAL CENTERS
THE SAFETY OF OUR CONSUMERS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS PROVIDERS OR
STAFF REGIONAL CENTERS AND YOUR
DDS DOWN IN THE PRIMARY FOCUS.
AND I WILL SAY THAT IN YOUR
REPORT OBJECTIVE ARE CONSUMER
OR THOSE WHO SUPPORT THEM- IS
DEEPLY SADDENED AND IT HURTS-
AND WE ALWAYS SEND OUR DEEPEST
CONSOLE IS TO. TO THOSE WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR LOVED ONES BUT
IT'S BEEN VERY IMPORTANT
INFORMATIVE FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE DAILY TRACKING OF THOSE
WHO- WHO ARE POSITIVE WHO WERE
IN THE HOSPITAL AND THOSE WHO
HAVE PASSED SO WE CAN MAKE THE
BEST DECISIONS AND HAVE IT. IN
OUR ACTION AND REACTION- ON TO
THIS VERY SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. GOING BACK TO MARCH IN
BEGINNING WITH A STAY AT HOME
ORDERS- MY FOCUS FOR A RESPONSE
I'M TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY HAS BEEN VERY FOCUSED
ON SAFETY FOR CONSUMERS
PROVIDERS AND STAFF. AND THIS
HAS BEEN ACHIEVED THROUGH
FOCUSING ON FLEXIBILITY
COMMUNICATION TO AND FROM OUR
COMMUNITY SUPPORT TO OUR
PROVIDERS THEIR STAFF AND THEN
ALSO ON DATA SAID NOTED. UNDER
NUMBER OF DIRECTION- DIRECTIVES
THAT WERE ISSUED TO BE
RESPONSIVE AND TO BE ABLE TO
PLAY A ROLE IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE ACHIEVE THESE KIND OF CORE
TENETS AND OUR RESPONSE. THERE
ARE TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
DIRECTIVES THAT WERE ISSUED
UNDER TWO DIFFERENT- ORTIZ. THE
FIRST BEING UNDER THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER. WHICH PROVIDES ME AS A
DIRECTOR ON THE ABILITY TO
ISSUE THESE DIRECTIVES IN
THIRTY DAY INCREMENTS. AND THE
SECOND IS UNDER AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY AUTHORITY WHICH IS IN A
PROVISION IN THE LAW THAT GIVES
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. THE
ABILITY TO ISSUE DIRECTIVES TO
PROTECT THE CONSUMERS- RIGHT.
HEALTH SAFETY OR WELFARE. THAT
HELP INCREASE- RUBBISH DOES NOT
HAVE A THIRTY- TIME TO. I WAS
MARCH TWO DDO IS ISSUE APPROX
FORTY DIFFERENT. GUIDANCE IN
FOR. LETTER PRIMARILY WE HAVE-
ON THE OF A- IN WHICH WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE
ACHIEVING US I HAD NO TO IT.
ADDITIONALLY EQUITY AND
SERVICES AND INTERVENTIONS YOU
ARE COMMUNITIES YOUR GREATER
STRESS ONLY BY HEALTH BUT ALSO
BASED ON ETHNICITY OR BASED ON
GEOGRAPHIC OR ECONOMIC- STATUS
IN IN NEEDING TO ACCESS
RESOURCES TO KEEP THEM SAFE.
I'VE BEEN ASKING- TALK ABOUT
STATE DIRECTIVES THAT HAVE
BEEN- ESTABLISHED IN BORN
THROUGH THE AUTHORITY PROVIDED
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER BUT I'M
ALSO STATE AND ALSO THOSE-
DIRECTIVES AS I NOTED UNDER THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY MAY ALSO BE
PART OF THE DISCUSSION. THAT WE
MAY HAVE- WE TAKE A LOOK AT
THOSE- ORDERS THAT WE HAVE ALSO
HEARD FROM OUR STAKEHOLDERS
PRIORITIES BECAUSE WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS WE'VE HAD STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT ASK. WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT'S NOT WORKING WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT YOU WOULD MAKE PER
RECOMMENDATION IF WE NEEDED TO
PAY RENT AND DO THINGS-DIFFERENTLY. STAKEHOLDERS AND
SHARED WITH US THERE'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF THE PRIORITIES AND
THE DIRECTIVES THAT THEY HAVE
FOUND TO BE VERY HELPFUL.
PARTICIPATE DIRECTED SERVICES
WHILE IT HASN'T BEEN UTILIZED
AS MUCH AS WE WOULD LIKE AND WE
HAD TO DO ADDITIONAL TRAINING
AND OUTREACH IN THIS AREA. BUT
THERE HAS BEEN A REQUEST TO BE
ABLE TO EXTEND THOSE THREE
SERVICE CALLS THAT WE ADDED
UNDER DISCOUNT ON THAT. SERVICE
CODES ARE FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING- SERVICES SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT AND PERSONAL
ASSISTANCE WE ALSO HEARD THAT
REMOTE SERVICES POST FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTERS DOING OUTREACH
AS SERVICE COORDINATION BEING
ABLE TO DO AND TAKE. AN
ELIGIBILITY I'M REMOTELY AND
ALSO FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS
PARTICULARLY AND EARLY
INTERVENTION- BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES REMOTELY HAS
ALSO BEEN AN AREA IN WHICH- OUR
COMMUNITY HAS EXPRESSED STRONG.
DESIRE TO BE ABLE TO EXTEND
THAT ON A LONGER TERM BASIS.
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS NONE I'M
INTEREST IN AND UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE IMPACT BECAUSE ALL
TALKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
DECLINE IN OUR EARLY START-
CASELOAD- BUT IN ADDITION WE
ARE ALSO VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT WARM HANDOFF FROM EARLY
START GOING TO EDUCATION. AT
THE AGE OF THREE SO ONE OF THE
DIRECTORS ALSO HAD- IDENTIFIED
REGIONAL CENTERS TO EXPAND
SERVICES AND TELL AN INDIVIDUAL
THAT CHILD HAS BEEN ABLE TO
HAVE- SERVICES IDENTIFIED
THROUGH EDUCATION BEFORE THEY-
WOULD GET ON EITHER HAVE. THE
INDIVIDUAL- NO LONGER L.
ELIGIBLE REGIONAL CENTER SIR.
OR IF THEY ARE L. L. FOR GOING.
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE ALSO IT AND
ABOUT THE THIRTY RENEWAL
PROCESS AND THE TIME LIMIT-
EARLY ON YOU KNOW WE CERTAINLY
HAS AN APARTMENT HAD SOME
STRUGGLES AND BEING ABLE TO BE
TIMELY AND BE ABLE TO PUSH
THOSE OUT- AND THERE IS SOME
UNCERTAINTY FROM OUR COMMUNITY
WE CERTAINLY HAVE. TAKEN THAT
VERY SERIOUSLY WE'VE ADJUSTED
OUR PROCESS AND ARE ABLE TO-
HAVE APPROVALS FOR THOSE
DIRECTIVES TO BE OUT TIMELY SO
THERE'S- NOT A QUESTION WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING FROM
MONTH TO MONTH- ADDITIONALLY IT
IS REALLY OUR INTENT TO
CONTINUE THE EXTENSION OF ANY
NEEDED DIRECTIVE TO ENSURE THE
STATE AND- SAY SERVICES- AND
SUPPORTS TO INDIVIDUALS TO KEEP
THEM- SAFE AND RECEIVING THOSE
SERVICES DURING THIS TIME.
TODAY WE'VE ONLY ENDED FOR
THOSE DIRECTIVES- AND I DO WANT
TO MAKE NOTES THAT TIME BASED
ON THE FEEDBACK THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM OUR STAKEHOLDERS-
THAT WE ACTUALLY ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH REGULATIONS- WE
ARE WORKING ON A DRAFT RIGHT
NOW FOR PARTICIPANT DIRECTED TO
EXTEND IT TO THOSE THREE
DIFFERENT SERVICES. AND AGAIN
THAT'S INDEPENDENT LIVING
SKILLS- IT IS SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT AND PERSONAL
ASSISTANCE WE ANTICIPATE BEING
ABLE TO HAVE A DRAFT OF THOSE
REGULATIONS POSTED- BY EARLY OR
MID SPRING- IT DEFINITELY A
REMOTE SERVER- WE- CURRENTLY.
EXPLORING UNDER OUR AUTHORITY
WITH THE FEDERAL WAIVER ON
BECAUSE WE DO BELIEVE THAT WE
MAY HAVE SOME- OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN OUR EXISTING WAIVER TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE REMOTE
SERVICES FOR WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ON THIS. SO WE CAN
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT IS-
CURRENTLY IN OUR THIRTY WORK WE
NEED TO START EXPLORING WHAT
ARE THE OPPORTUNITIES EITHER
THROUGH WAIVER- AND EXTENDING-
THE- VARIOUS WAYS OF BEING ABLE
TO REACH FAMILIES AND
CONSUMERS. NOT ONLY IN AN
EMERGENCY BUT EVEN TO
ACCOMMODATE SOME UNIQUE
SCHEDULE SOMETIMES FAMILY SPACE
AND JUST A DAILY LIFE. SO AGAIN
OUR DIRECTIVES- CENTERED
AROUND- SAFETY REMOTE OPTIONS
WE ALSO HAD VERY SPECIFIC%
FLEXIBILITIES TO SUPPORT
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE WERE BEING RESPONSIVE
TO SOME OF THOSE UNIQUE AND
CHALLENGES- SUPPORTER LIVING
PROVIDERS HAD EXPRESSED-
CERTAINLY EARLY ON DEFINITELY
MADE WAY OF SAYING IT'S BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
SUPPORT THEIR STAFF AND TO BE
ABLE TO BE RESPONSIBLE. SO ONE
OF OUR MORE RECENT- DIRECTIVES
WAS TO ALLOW FOR AND ESTABLISH
A TWENTY FOR HOUR RATE FOR OUR
SUPPORTED LIVING PROVIDER SO
THEY COULD HAVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY. ADDITIONALLY FOR
FAMILIES AND CONSUMERS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
WE HEARD FROM OUR FAMILIES THAT
WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO HAVE MORE
THAN ONE PERSON IN. THAT THEY
REALLY NEEDED TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY ON THE RATE TO
SUPPORT OVER TIME- THIS IS
PARTICULARLY A VOICE THAT CAME
FROM OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITY THAT
SAID. YOU KNOW WE REALLY DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING OUR LOVED ONES ARE
FAMILY MEMBERS YOU WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE SUPPORTED-
THEIR CONCERNS AND THAT WAS ONE
OF THE ADDITIONAL RESPECT YOUR
ACTIVES THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. FLEXIBILITY TO
REGIONAL CENTERS WE ARE-
RECOGNIZING THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
WORKING. VERY HARD SAME AS THAT
FAMILIES AND SAME WITH THE-
SERVICE PROVIDERS- SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAD THE
OF. DUE TO THE FACT TO DO
GALLERY. I WAS ASKED TO ALSO
ADDRESS AND HER AID. AND UPDATE
ON THIS MOST RECENT AND
APPROACH ON VACCINE STRATEGIES.
AND VERY SPECIFICALLY TO THE
REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMER
POPULATION AND THEN- ALSO TO
IDENTIFY ANY CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE VACCINE ACCESS OR- OUR
POPULATION AND I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND PROVIDE SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION TO YOU- AND NOW.
I'M CALIFORNIA'S VACCINE PLAN
WAS ISSUED IN DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY- AS A PHASE ONE AA- FOR
VACCINE PRIORITY- THERE TO KIND
OF MAIN AREAS RESIDENTS OF LONG
TERM CARE AND THAT HEALTH CARE
WORKERS- WE AS A DEPARTMENT- WE
HAD HEARD FROM OUR COMMUNITY
YOU KNOW REALLY WANTING SOME
CLARITY AS TO. WHO IS DEFINED
AS A- RESIDENT AND LONG TERM
CARE AND THEN WHO ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD QUALIFY
AS HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND SO WE
ISSUED WE WORK WITH CDPH- AND
REALLY LOOKED OUT HOW CAN WE
FURTHER DEFINED NOT- SO IT
WOULD BE- AVAILABLE TO. THOSE
WHO ARE SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS
NOT ONLY THOSE WHO HAVE HIT
SOME PARTS- BUT ALSO FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO ARE UNPAID YOU KNOW
BUT THEY PROVIDE GIVEN
PROVIDING SUPPORTS YOU- THEIR
LOVED ONE WHETHER IT'S A SON
DAUGHTER BROTHER SISTER. I'M AT
HOME BECAUSE THEY'VE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE THE OTHER SUPPORT-
WE WERE ABLE TO ISSUE- CLARITY
ON THIS. I'M IN JAN- AND SO
THAT'S FAIRLY. THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO GET THE ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATION AS TO- THOSE
SETTING TYPES AS WELL AS MAKING
SURE THAT- WHAT VENDORS AND
WENT UNPAID SUPPORT- WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR HEALTH CARE.
THERE WAS SOME CONFUSION AT
LOCAL LEVELS I'M PARTICULARLY
AND A COUPLE OF COUNTIES- WE'RE
NOT ACCEPTING LETTERS FROM
FAMILY MEMBERS THIS WAS VERY
CONCERNING TO US- AND CERTAINLY
WANTED TO SEE WHAT WAS THE
REMEDY TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THAT. WE ARE ABLE TO WORK WITH
CDPH THEY THEN ISSUED A
CLARIFYING FAQ- THAT WAS ABLE
TO- ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AND WE
DID RECEIVE- ALMOST THAT SAME
DAY-FAMILIES- PROVIDING US
FEEDBACK SAYING THAT THAT.
ADDED SOME CLARITY AND WE WERE
ABLE TO- SEE SOME SUCCESS WITH
THAT FURTHER CLARIFICATION.
PHASE ONE B. END OF SIXTY FIVE
AND OLDER- THIS DOES TOUCH SOME
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE-
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOP THE
DISABILITIES- WE RIGHT NOW HAVE
A TEN THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMERS WHO ARE SIXTY FIVE
AND OLDER- NOW PART OF. THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE IN LONG
TERM CARE WERE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
VACCINE- IN THE FIRST- FACED IN
THE FIRST PRIORITY GROUP- 44%
OF THEM HOWEVER LIVE IN THEIR
OWN HOME- OR WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS AND SO THOSE ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE HAVE-
PROVIDED A DIRECTED TO REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT THEY MUST. GO OUT
AND MAKE- FOCUS CONVERSATIONS
AND- OUTREACH TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE INSURANCE
THAT THEY KNOW HOW TO. REGISTER
HOW TO ESTABLISH A CONNECTION
TO THE VACCINE AND MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S A WAY FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO GET THE VACCINE AND
THEY ARE- AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
I'M ADDITIONALLY- FOR THE
PRIORITIES AS WE HAVE HEARD- AS
OF FRIDAY- THAT WE HAVE THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE HIGH RISK-
CERTAINLY OUR POPULATION WITH
DEVELOP DISABILITIES HAD FITS
INTO THESE CATEGORIES AND I'LL
JUST REVIEW THAT FOR THOSE WHO.
MAY NOT HAVE THAT INFORMATION
THAT HOWEVER IS EFFECTIVE ON
MARCH FIFTEENTH. SO INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE SIXTEEN TO SIXTY FOUR
WHO ARE DEEMED TO BE- BY THEIR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER TO BE AT A
VERY HIGH RISK- FOR MORBIDITY
OR MORTALITY- AND FROM KOBE
NINETEEN AS A DIRECT RESULT OF
ONE. ONE OR MORE A VERY
SPECIFIC SEVERE HEALTH
CONDITIONS INCLUDED IN THOSE
HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DOWN SYNDROME.
IT IS ALSO- THERE'S- THEY JUST
SAW- CLARITY IS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO. AS A RESULT OF
A DEVELOPMENTAL OR OTHER SEVERE
HIGH RISK DISABILITY- THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS LIKELY TO DEVELOP
SEVERE LIFE THREATENING ILLNESS
OR DEATH FROM CALL THE NINETEEN
INSPECTION OR REQUIRING FOR THE
NINETEEN WILL LIMIT THE-
INDIVIDUAL'S ABILITY TO RECEIVE
ONGOING CARE AND SERVICES VITAL
TO THEIR WELL BEING AND
SURVIVAL- OR PROVIDING ADEQUATE
AND TIMELY- KOBE CARE WILL
PARTICULARLY. BE CHALLENGING AS
A RESULT OF THE INDIVIDUAL'S
DISABILITY- I'M THE DIRECTIVE
THAT- DDS SENT OUT ON FRIDAY
INSTRUCTING THE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO DO THE OUTREACH FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER- IN
ADDITION WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON AND ANOTHER
DIRECTOR- THAT IS GOING TO
OUTLINED CLARITY. ON HOW
REGIONAL CENTERS WILL BE ASKED-
AND AGAIN BOTH OF THESE
DIRECTORS ARE ASKED TO HAVE OUR
COMMUNICATION TOGETHER AS
PARTNERS- WE ALL HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING INFORMATION.
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO CONNECT
WITH THEIR HEALTH PROVIDERS TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS- TO THE
VACCINES WHEN THEY'RE
AVAILABLE- THIS IS NOT A
SURPRISE- FOR ME TO SHARE THAT
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE IS THE
AVAILABILITY AND- OF THE NUMBER
OF. VACCINES THERE IS A LIMITED
SUPPLY- AND THERE'S ALSO
DIFFERENT IS A DIFFERENT-
SUPPLY IS BETWEEN COUNTY SOME
COUNTIES- ARE FURTHER ALONG IN
THE PRIORITY LIST THAN OTHER
COUNTIES- AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE ALSO HAVING
THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TRACKING.
THE AVAILABILITY SO WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE OUT
QUICKLY I'M TO GET THOSE- AND
BAXEEN. SO IT DOES ALL- KIND OF
CONCERN- THAT WE DO HAVE THAT
REMAIN WHILE WE NOW KNOW WHO
AND WE KNOW. WHEN WE NEED TO
KNOW WE NEED TO REALLY DEFINE
KIND OF THAT ACCESS IN THAT
HOUSE- SO THIS REALLY WELL THE
PLANS OF THE THINGS THE STEPS
THAT WE'RE DOING TO GO FORWARD
REALLY DO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE CONCERNS. LIKE I
SAID THE AVAILABILITY OF A
VACCINES IS A CONCERN WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
IDENTIFYING THOSE CONSUMERS
RIGHT AWAY THAT HAVE THE
GREATEST REST BASED ON THEIR
HEALTH CONDITIONS SO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE HIGHLY
COMPLEX MEDICAL NEEDS- ANY
INDIVIDUAL THAT IS. AND A RISK
AREA AS FAR AS EVEN BEING ABLE
TO GET ACCESS TO- A SITE OR WHO
IS UNABLE TO GO TO A SITE- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME
VERY REMOTE AREAS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAD VERY LIMITED INTERNET
ACCESS. I'M SO WE WANT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO WORK WITH-
CARE PROVIDERS AND OTHERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
OUTREACH EVERY SINGLE PERSON.
THAT WE DON'T LEAVE ANYBODY
BEHIND- IN THE DIRECTIVE WE'VE
ASKED THE REGIONAL CENTERS TO
MAKE THESE CONTACTS WE KNOW
THAT THEIR COORDINATORS VERY
TIRED. EVEN ALSO WORKING VERY
HARD ALONG WITH THE PROVIDERS
AND FAMILY MEMBERS WHAT WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO PUSH THE GAS
PEDAL- SO WE'VE ASKED THE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO THINK
THROUGH THEIR STAFFING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY USE ALL THEIR
STAFF THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
TO DO THIS I REACH. AND THEN
ALSO PARTNER WITH THEIR SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
REACH SO WE CAN HAVE TIMELY AND
EFFECTIVE OUTREACH TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES THAT I JUST
IDENTIFIED- ON THE ADDITIONAL
AREA THAT I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT BUSINESS INFORMATION. WE
ARE STILL HEARING FROM SOME
ABOUT THE FEAR. OF HAVING THE
VACCINE I JUST HEARD YESTERDAY
SOMEBODY WAS AFRAID TO- TAKE
THE VACCINE BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO CHANGE
THEIR DNA. AND SO WE NEED TO
GET THE INFORMATION OUT WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
USING THOSE THAT ARE TRUSTED TO
BE ABLE TO SHARE THE
INFORMATION. WE ARE VERY.
FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
OUR TO HE BASED ORGANISED. THAT
PARTNERED WITH US THESE REALLY
IMPORTANT OUR- TO COMMUTE SAID
CALL. AND TO OUR UNDER CAN. AND
SO WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE INFORMATION
THAT IS ACCURATE SO PEOPLE CAN
MAKE THE- BEST DECISION AN
INFORMED DECISION WITH THE
RIGHT INFORMATION. I AM SO
THESE ARE THE AREAS IN WHICH
WE'VE BEEN- FOCUSED ON AND THEN
I CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO PRIORITIZE IT- I DO WANT TO
JUST MAKE NOTE THAT WHILE WE
HAD REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMERS
THAT ARE OFTEN COMMUNITY WE
ALSO HAVE REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMERS THAT ARE IN OUR STATE
OPERATED SERVICES. SO WE DO
OPERATE- PRIMARILY TO STATE
OPERATED FACILITIES- WHICH IS
VERY BUTTE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
AND THEN ALSO CANYON SPRINGS
BUT WE ALSO HAVE VERY CUTE.
CRISIS HOMES- BUT I DO WANT TO
JUST MAKE NOTE THAT AS OF
FEBRUARY TWELFTH WE HAVE 65% OF
OUR RESIDENTS HAVE RECEIVED THE
VACCINE. AND WE HAVE 42% OF OUR
STAFF WHO RECEIVED IT. NOW
WE'VE ONLY HAD TWO. BIG
BASICALLY TWO SERIES OF THE
VACCINE- CLINICS. AND WE ARE
FINDING THAT GOING TO THE THIRD
CLINIC IS WHEN WE'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO BRING IN MORE WHO
WERE- AMBER CONTINUE TO DO OUR
REACH TO OUR STAFF. AND YOU
ARE- RESIDENTS THAT TO HAVE
THEM PARTICIPATE- I'M SURE
BATES USED TO DO SO. I ALSO
ASKED TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT HAS DDS ASK REGIONAL
CENTERS TO PROVIDE IMPENDING
PUBLIC RELATED PLANS BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A DIRECTIVE THAT
ASKED REGIONAL CENTERS
INSTRUCTED THEM TO PROVIDE A
PLAN. FOR VACCINE AND
PROTESTING AND SO WE PROVIDED
THIRTY DAYS FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO GET TO US. ON THE NEWS ON
FRIDAY IS ACTUALLY CHANGING
THAT- KIND OF DIRECTED LIKELY
NOT MUCH WE STILL EXPECT THAT
OUT OF REACH BUT I DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE DOING IT
UNDER THE LANDS THAT WE HAD
INDIVIDUALS THAT. ARE GOING TO
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE VACCINE ON
MARCH FIFTEENTH. SO WE'RE GONNA
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE FOCUSING
ON A PLAN THAT DOES
COMMUNICATION IDENTIFIES THOSE
CLINICS THAT THAT ARE AVAILABLE
IDENTIFY WAYS TO BE ABLE TO GET
ACCESS. WHETHER IT'S
COORDINATING WITH RENTAL
TRANSPORTATION PROVIDERS TO GET
INDIVIDUALS TO A CLINIC. OR
WORKING WHEN WE IDENTIFY
MOBILE- OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THINGS TO GO TO INDIVIDUAL
HOMES BUT WE NEED TO KNOW NOW
WHO THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE. THAT
ARE GOING TO NEED THAT
ACCOMMODATION- I. HAVE ALSO
BEEN ASKED TO. BRIEFLY OUTLINE
IN THE STATE- RESPONSE
REGARDING THE EDS POPULATION IN
ANY MAJOR CHANGES THAT ARE
GOING GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PARTICULARLY WANTED TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS ON THE THIRTY SIX
POINT SEVEN MILLION INVESTMENT
THAT OUTLINED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- FOR BUDGET YEAR I'M SO
FOR BUDGET YEAR TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY. FIVE POINT ONE MILLION
TOTAL PLAN OF WHICH IS A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE POINT TWO
MILLION AS GENERAL FUND IS- IN
THE BUDGET YEAR IS RELATED TO
CALL THAT RESPONSE- WE VERY
SPECIFICALLY HAVE- AN ESTIMATE
OF TWO HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION TOTAL FUNDS
AND OF WHICH IS A HUNDRED FORTY
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION.
REGIONAL CENTER PURCHASE A
SERVICE SO THIS IS THE START OF
PURCHASE A SERVICE THAT GOES TO
CONSUMERS AND FAMILIES- TO
SUPPORT THEIR NEEDS DURING THIS
TIME- I'M OF THAT FIFTY SIX
POINT ONE MILLION IS RELATED TO
REST BUT MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE RESPITE RESOURCES INTO
FAMILY HOMES KNOWING THAT
THEY'RE STILL FAMILIES THAT
HAVE CHILDREN AT HOME THEY'RE
FACING NOT ONLY JUST- BE ISSUE
SAID ARE NEEDED TO SUPPORT A
CHILD WHO HASN'T ABOUT THE
DISABILITY BUT THERE MAY BE AN
HOME LEARNING THERE MAY BE
OTHER FACTORS THAT ARE. ARE
REALLY ADDING STRESS TO YOU ON
THAT SITUATION- WE HAVE
COMMUNITY HERE FACILITIES AND
SUPPORT SERVICES- THAT IS
ELEVEN POINT TWO MILLION WE DID
SEE A DECREASE AND
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES SO ON
THE QUESTION RELATED TO WHAT
ARE THE AREAS IN WHICH WE ARE
SEEING KIND OF THOSE IMPACTS-
WE DID SEE A DECREASE IN
CLAIMING BY SOME OF OUR SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND THERE'S A
SPECIFIC QUESTION ASKING US.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE IMPACT
YOU- THOSE PROVIDERS ENOUGH AND
WHEN WE GET TO THAT PORTION OF
THE AGENDA WHICH I THINK IS A
LITTLE BIT LATER- ALL MAKE SURE
THAT WE ADDRESS THAT-
ADDITIONALLY THAT THERE IS A
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT FACTORS ARE
INFLUENCING CASELOAD
PROJECTIONS I'M THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT POINT- WE
START EARLY ON A VERY QUICK.
DECLINE IN OUR EARLY START AND-
FOR. SERVICES BUT PRIMARILY-
EARLY START. DECLINE AND- THIS
MEANS THAT KIDS WHO ARE AT RISK.
MAY NOT BE GETTING THE SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED SO WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED WAYS TO BE ABLE TO
DO IMMEDIATE OUR REACH WE
CONNECTED WITH ALL OF OUR EARLY
START CONTACTS AND HAD. VERY
FOCUSED CONVERSATIONS AND-
WORKING WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTERS- WE ALSO DEVELOP
GROCERS WE REALLY DID-
SIGNIFICANT OUTREACH WE ARE
SEEING AN INCREASE IN THOSE
INTAKES BUT WE- WE ARE STILL-
SOMEWHAT BEHIND SO VERY
SPECIFICALLY AND HOW THAT AND-
INFLUENCES THE ESTIMATE THAT WE
HAVE FOR BUDGET YEAR WITH
CASELOAD AND REGIONAL CENTER
OPERATIONS- IS. IS RELATED TO
WHAT I WANT TO SHARE RIGHT NOW.
SO IN CURRENT YEAR SO- THIS
YEAR CASELOAD WAS UPDATED TO BE
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND EIGHT NINETEEN WHICH
IS AND I NOT DECREASE OF WHAT
WE HAD ESTIMATED. EIGHT
THOUSAND FIVE THIRTY FOUR OF
WHICH FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN
THIRTY FIVE IS RELATED. ISSUE
OUR ESTIMATE AN EARLY START. SO
WE TAKE A AT OUR BYYEAR. WE
ARE WE ARE ESTIMATING HIGH IN
THE SENSE OF WHAT OUR
TRADITIONAL ART TREND OF YEAR
OVER YEAR GROWTH WITH CASELOAD.
WE ARE HIGHER THAN WHAT WE'VE
BEEN TRAINING TRAINING OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS- SO WE DO
HAVE PROJECTED A CASELOAD OF
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX.
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE WHICH IS INCREASE OF JUST
SLIGHTLY ABOVE TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS. ON AND
WELL. WE WOULD THINK THAT
FUNDING WOULD I'M ACTUALLY NOT
BE WHICH WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
WOULD BE ADJUSTED DOWN IN
RESPONSE TO AN ADJUSTMENT TO
CASELOAD- BUT WE DIDN'T DO THAT
BECAUSE WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT
REALLY- A PRIORITY TO RECOVERY
IN THIS AREA. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
RECOVERY DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS THAT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE THE RESOURCES. TO
DO THOSE AND TAKES SO IF WE
WERE TO PARALLEL THE REDUCTION
BASED ON THE CASE LOAD. YES
WOULD THAT CHANGE REALLY THE
REGIONAL CENTERS OPERATIONS-
AND WANTED TO CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE AND NOT DELAY IN
TAKING AND BRINGING KIDS. IN
WAS IMPORTANT AND A PRIORITY TO
US- SO THAT WAS THE END OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE LISTED-
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR PARCHMAN.
NEXT WE HAVE PETE CERVENKA.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANKS THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TO YOU TODAY. I'D LIKE ALSO TO
THANK YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER
INCLUDING SEVERAL CHARTS AND IT
JAMMED- THAT IT WILL BE USEFUL
REFERENCES ARE FOR TODAY'S
DISCUSSION. OF COURSE ANY
CONVERSATION ABOUT DATA
INVOLVES A FEW CABBIE OUT SO I.
LIKE TO START WITH JUST A FEW
OF THOSE. ARE I HAVE BEEN
ASKING THE AGENDA TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT TRANS. WELL
TRAINS ARE COUNCIL CASES AND
DEATHS AND THEY CREATE
TRAMLINES OVER TIME- BUT I WANT
TO CALL OUT TO THE AN IMPORTANT
FACTOR NOT CAPTURED BY THE
TREND WOULD BE- DISCUSSION OF A
RATE OF. CASES EMBRACE OF DEATH
IN THE POPULATION AND- AS YOU
NOTED IN YOUR INTRODUCTORY
REMARKS ON OUR OUR POPULATION
HAS SEEN A HIGHER RATE THAN THE
GENERAL POPULATION OF BOTH.
CASES AND DEATHS ON THEIR END
AS WELL EXPLAINED IN A MINUTE
WELL WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT OUR
OUR DATA IS UNDER REPORTED
AFTER REASONS- THAT THAT WILL
COVER. OF COURSE. ALL ALL OF
THAT- IT WAS ADDRESSED TO BUY
THEIR BAR MINISTRY ABOUT THAT
WAS PRIOR. OF OUR POPULAR FOR
VACCINATION I GET GIVEN THE
FACTORS THAT I JUST DESCRIBED.
WELL THERE ARE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND OR SO
CONSUMERS ARE IN OUR POPULATION
JUST OVER ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
OF THEM RECEIVE DIRECT CARE FOR
THE STATE- WELL THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IN ADDITION
TO THOSE THAT WE DIRECTLY
CALIFORNIA'S HAVE DIRECT ACCESS
TO DATA FOR. ABOUT 85% OF OUR
POPULATION LIVES IN FAMILY
HOMES ANOTHER 15% OR SO LIVE IN
LICENSE RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
ALL THIS IS IMPORTANT TO KEEP
IN MIND BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY FOR
THOSE WE CARE DIRECTLY FOR WE
DIRECTLY HAVE ACCESS TO DATA
ABOUT THEM. BUT IT'S ONLY THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE. WELL AS YOU
DAHLE RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO REPORT
BOTH CASES HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
DEATHS AND WERE THEREFORE
CONFIDENT OF THAT DATA. BUT
AGAIN ONLY ABOUT 15% OF OUR
TOTAL POPULATION IS IN SUCH A
FACILITY- FOR FAMILIES. WELL
THE LAW ONLY REQUIRES THE
REPORTING OF THE GAS. AND
THERE'S OFTEN AN UNDERSTANDABLE
I DELAY IN REPORTING OF THAT
BASS AS FAMILIES GO THROUGH THE
GRIEVING PROCESS. SO FOR
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR CLIENTS.
OR CONSUMERS IN OUR COMMUNITY-
WE OFTEN- RELY ONLY ON WHAT WE
ARE. ABOUT REGIONAL CENTERS NOW
OR THE SERVICE PROVIDERS NOW OR
WHAT A FAMILY VOLUNTARILY
REPORTS TO US- THAT'S NOT AN
EXCUSE AND I'M NOT SUGGESTING
THAT WE MANDATE A CHANGE OR NOT
BUT I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
IT'S AN IMPORTANT LIMITATION ON
THE DEVICE. THE DATA AVAILABLE
TO US. AS A RESULT OF COURSE-
WE THINK THAT. WE HAVE SOME
UNDER REPORTING IN OUR DATA
FROM THE FAMILY HOMES AND IT'S
A LARGE A CHUNK OF OUR
CASELOAD. ALTHOUGH THAT UNDER
REPORTING IS GENERALLY WHAT WE
WOULD THINK OF THIS CONSISTENT
OVER. TIME THEY CAN'T BE
MEASURE- BUT IT IS THERE FOR
ADEQUATE STORAGE TRY IN OUR- IT
DOES OR THERE ARE. IT APPEAR
THAT THE RATE OF OUR ARE
HOSPITAL. MAYBE LOWER THE THEY
OUT ARE AND I WAS IN AND FACTOR
AS WELL IN THE PRIORITIZATION
DISCUSSION FOR VACCINATION. ON
ADDITIONALLY AND I'LL TALK MORE
A LITTLE BIT LATER ON IN
SUBSEQUENT QUESTIONS WELL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO FLYING TO THAT- IN
ADDITION TO OUR FAMILY IS NOT
BEING REQUIRED TO REPORT CASES
AND HOSPITALIZATION THERE'S NO
MANDATE ACROSS OUR POPULATION
TO REPORT VACCINATIONS EITHER
AND SO THAT WHEN YOU COMPOUND
THAT THERE'S AN INTERPLAY WHICH
ALSO CONSUMER CONSENT TO
VACCINATION ITSELF INTO THE
DATA SHARING ASSOCIATED WITH IT
WELL AND THE VARIOUS ACCESS
POINTS THAT PEOPLE DO HAVE TO
VACCINATION. WELL AND THE TIME
WIDE POTENTIALLY IN THAT
INFORMATION ALL OF THOSE THINGS
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE COMPANY
OUR ABILITY TO HAVE
COMPREHENSIVE DATA ABOUT WHO'S
BEEN VACCINATED WELL WHERE
THEY'VE BEEN VACCINATED SIDE OF.
FACTS AND SO FORTH. I'M HOWEVER.
WE DO THINK THAT IN THE DATA
THAT WE HAVE THE TRACKING OF
TRENDS REALLY ALLOWS US. TO
HAVE SOME INSIGHTS INTO WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND. AUTHOR
FOR EXAMPLE THE VAST MAJORITY
IN IN THE PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
OF NEW CALVET CASES ARE NOW
BEING IDENTIFIED IN IN
COMMUNITY I'M SORRY IN THE
COMMUNITY AND FAMILY SETTINGS.
RATHER THAN IN LICENSE
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES WHERE
VACCINES WERE FIRST MADE
AVAILABLE THIS GIVES US SOME
ASSURANCE THAT VACCINATION IN
FACT HAS BEEN REALLY SUCCESSFUL
IN THOSE LICENSE RESIDENTIAL
ASSEMBLY SO THAT'S GOOD NEWS.
IT'S ALL STOP THEIR WITH CABBIE
OUTS AND ACTUALLY GET TO THE
TREND ANALYSIS WELL AS DIRECTOR
OF ARGUMENT NOTED OR
TRANSFERRED CASES
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATH
ALMOST EXACTLY MIRROR THE
OVERALL STATEWIDE TRENDS THERE
TOO CHARTS IN PARTICULAR IN
YOUR AGENDA WHICH PROVIDE
USEFUL ILLUSTRATIONS OF THOSE
CHAT- TRANS. THIRTEEN ARE PAVE
SEVEN. OF YOUR AGENDA THERE
THERE'S A CHART WELL THAT GOES
ARE FAIRLY FAR BACK IN TIME
TOWARD THE BEGINNING OF THE
CALL PERIOD- WHEN WE OVERLAY
THE STATEWIDE CASE TREND ON
THIS CHART THERE ESSENTIALLY
MIRRORS OF EACH OTHER THERE WAS
A TWO MONTH BOBBLE. BEGINNING
IN LATE JUNE IN THE SUMMER. AND
WE SUCCESSFULLY TOGETHER BUILT
BAD DOCTOR AND THEN YOU SEE THE
STEEP RISE BEGINNING WITH THE
THANKSGIVING HOLIDAY THAT'S NOW
BEGINNING TO COME BACK TO HOME.
REGARDING GAS THERE'S A GRAPH
AT THE TOP OF PAGE EIGHT OF
YOUR AGENDA THE DISPLAYS CHECK
TRANSFER BOTH HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND DEATHS AND IT'S LARGELY
FOLLOW THE SAME. TREND LINES
BUT- WE'RE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
WITH LOWER OF SIX. LOWER NOW.
WE WERE ASKED TO COMMENT ABOUT
DEVIATIONS- AND AS I'VE SAID
YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE'RE
GENERALLY MIRRORING THE TREND
THAT THERE ISN'T- LIVE CHECK TO
MONSTER IT TO CALL OUT IN TERMS
OF THE DEVIATION AGAIN I WILL
FLAG THAT THERE THE RATE OF
BOTH CASES AND ASK FOR OUR
POPULATION IS ABOUT THREE TIMES
THE OVERALL RATE OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION I'M NOT OF COURSE
ISN'T REVEALED IN THE TRYING TO
BUT IT'S WORTH. KEEPING IN MIND.
ON YOU KNOW OTHERWISE YOU KNOW
THINGS THAT WE SEE OUTCOMES
HAVE BEEN WORSE IN LICENSE
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES THEY'VE
BEEN WORSE FOR OLDER PEOPLE
THAN FOR OTHERS AND OBVIOUSLY
WORSE FOR PEOPLE WITH MORE
COMPLICATED UNDERLYING MEDICAL
CONDITIONS- I DO WANT TO FLAG
ON. AND SHOULD THE CHART ON
PAGE EIGHT TRILLION CONTAINS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON- IT'S
RIGHT BELOW THE GRAPH THAT I
WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT ONE YOU
WILL SEE- THAT THE- COVERED
CASES OF GENERALLY ON A
DEMOGRAPHIC BASIS. WHILE ON AN
ETHNIC BASIS I'VE BEEN
PROPORTIONAL. OUR OVERALL
POPULATION THE EXCEPTION FOR
THAT IS FOR WHITE CONSUMERS
WERE FOR CODED CASES THEY'VE
BEEN ABOUT 40% OF TOTAL CASES
BUT ONLY 30% OF OUR POPULATION.
WELL THIS IS- ALSO BECAUSE THEY
WERE DESPERATE WHITE OR
CONSUMERS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY REPRESENTED
IN RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES
WITH THE INCIDENCE OF COLOR
THAT HAS BEEN ARE HIGHER. AND
FOR THE SAME REASON DEATHS OF
WHITE CONSUMERS ARE 51% OF
TOTAL GAS FOR THAT SAME REASON.
ON. CHARTS ON PAGE NINE INTENT
OF YOUR AGENDA- FURTHER
ILLUSTRATES THAT- THE INCIDENCE
OF THESE THINGS AND RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES HAVE HAVE BEEN
HIGHER AS WELL- AGAIN AS I
MENTIONED AND DIRECTOR
CHRISTMAS WELL AS WE SAW
VACCINATION PROGRESS IN LICENSE
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES WE SEE
THAT MOST OF THE NEW CASES THAT
REPRESENT US NOW IN THE DATA
ARE IN FACT IN FAMILY SETTINGS-
IN FACT. IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY ON JUST THE OTHER DAY
THE DAILY REPORT THAT WE HAD
ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO NEW
CASES ONLY FOUR OF THEM WERE
UNLICENSED RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES. ALSO THAT THAT'S A
GOOD DATA POINT. MOM. DIRECTOR
MARGIN ALSO TALKED ABOUT-
DURING THE RECENT UPDATE TO THE
STATE'S VACCINATION
PRIORITIZATION AND- EXPANSION
OF ELIGIBILITY BEGINNING MARCH
FIFTEENTH ONE THIS IS A
RECOGNITION BOTH OF THE OUR
LIMITED SUPPLY OF THE VACCINE
BUT ALSO- THE HIGHER RISK
ASSOCIATED WITH CODE INFRACTION
FOR OUR POPULATION ALSO
REVEALED THAT IS A POSITIVE
CHANGE BETWEEN NOW AND MARCH WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITIES. AND
ADVOCATES WELL THERE WERE
REALLY CONDUCTING WITH THEM A
ROBUST ROBUST PLANNING PROCESS
TO ESTABLISH A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF FOR WHERE WHEN
AND HOW REMAINING POPULATION
CAN. ACCESS THE BOXING.
DIRECTOR BARGED ALSO TO ABOUT
THE EXTENT OUT AFTER THAT SO.
HAVE BEEN ASKED DO AND WE GIVE
THEM A HEADS UP WE WILL ASK
THEM TO DO FOR OTHER CONSUMERS
AS WELL IN THE INTERVENING TIME
PERIOD. ON SO WE THINK I CAUGHT
A COMBINATION OF THE PLANNING
TIME IN THOSE OUTREACH EFFORTS
IN THE ASSISTANCE IS BEING
OFFERED. WELL WILL GO A LONG
WAY TO ACHIEVING OUR SHARED
GOAL OF SAVING LIVES AND
PROTECTING HOUSE. WE'VE BEEN
ASKED TO TALK ABOUT HOW THE
STATE WILL MONITOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION TO A PERSON SERVED
ON PROVIDER POPULATIONS. AND
WHETHER THIS DATA WILL BE
AVAILABLE AND WHAT FORMATS.
EXCUSE ME THE SHORT ANSWER IS
YES WE ARE MONITORING THIS DATA
AS YOU SAW ON THE TABLES THAT
WE ALREADY COVERED IN THE
AGENDA WE TRACK TOBIN IMPACTS
BY AGE BY ETHNICITY BY GENDER
BY RESIDENTS TYPE IN AT THE
REGIONAL CENTER LEVEL OF DETAIL
THE SAME INFORMATION SUBJECT
THOUGH TO THE RECORDING CABBIE
OUTS THAT I PREVIOUSLY
DESCRIBED IS ALSO AVAILABLE FOR
VACCINATIONS. THROUGH OUR CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM- AND SO WHILE
WE DON'T YET HAVE ROBUST
INFORMATION- WE WILL BE
COLLECTING IN THE IN THE SAME
FORMAT AND MAKING IT AVAILABLE-
LET ME SEE HERE WHAT ELSE CAN I
COULD COVER- I DON'T WANT TO BE
REDUNDANT OF PRIOR REMARKS SO
APOLOGIES AS I SKIED JUMP AHEAD
JUST A LITTLE BIT. ON YEAH HEY
AND THEN WE'VE BEEN ASKED AS
WELL TO TALK ABOUT THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN THE DDS
POPULATION ON THE IHS US
CASELOAD. WELL THE LAST TIME WE
DID ACROSS PROGRAM ANALYSIS UP
BETWEEN THESE TWO PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS WAS FOR THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALENDAR YEAR. ON
GIVEN MY LONG ASSOCIATION WITH
THE IRISH OF SAAS. PROGRAM
BEFORE JOINING- THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES- I
AND WE CLARIFIED WITH IT
WITHOUT DEPARTMENT AS WELL-
WITH DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. WHAT WE CAN TELL YOU
THAT ROUGHLY NINETY THOUSAND OF
OUR THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND CONSUMERS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WERE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE I. ENGINE SIZE PROGRAMS
WELL THAT'S APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY PERCENT. AND IT'S BEEN
GROWING JUST SLIGHTLY- AFTER
THAT TIME EACH YEAR AND IT'S
LARGELY REFLECTIVE OF THE FACT
THAT ONE OF THE GROWING
COMPONENTS WITHIN THE IHS ASK
IS SLOWED. IS IT IS A NUMBER OF
YOUNGER CHILDREN WITH AUTISM
INCREASINGLY UTILIZING IHS US
SERVICES. ALSO WE THINK- THAT
TREND IS PROBABLY CONTINUING ON
BUT WE HAVEN'T DONE ANY EXACT
MATCH THE ON THE- TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CAP YOUR CALENDAR
CALENDAR YEAR. DATA AFTER THAT.
WELL WE'VE ASKED TO AS WELL- IT
WHETHER WE KNOW HOW ARE POPULAR
IN. WITH OTHER PRIORITIZE GROUP
SUCH AS THOSE FIVE AND OLDER.
AND WHAT REMAINING NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS HAVE YET TO BE
VACCINATED. WELL BECAUSE OF THE
DATA LIMITATIONS THAT I JUST
DESCRIBED IT IT'S HARD TO KNOW
EXACTLY HOW MANY OF THOSE
CONSUMER OF OUR CONSUMERS ARE
REMAIN YET TO BE VACCINATED.
WELL BUT THAT IS PART OF THE
REASON THAT WE DIRECTED
REGIONAL CENTERS TO MAKE
CONTACT WITH ELIGIBLE
CONSUMERS. ON THERE ARE JUST
OVER TEN THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMERS WHO
ARE AGE SIXTY FIVE AND OVER.
THAT'S ABOUT 3% OF OUR TOTAL
DDS POPULATION AND THOSE
CONSUMERS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
VACCINATION NOW- I'M JUST JUST
OVER- IF YOU. ARE JUST JUST
OVER FIFTY SIX HUNDRED OF THEM-
RESIDE IN A LICENSE RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY ON THOSE- INTERMEDIATE
CARE FACILITIES COMMUNITY CARE
FACILITIES OR OTHER SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES SO BY NOW
THAT THOSE OLDER CONSUMERS
SHOULD ABOUT ACCESS TO THE
VACCINE. IF THEY CONSENTED TO
BE VACCINATED. ARM AND BASED ON
WHAT WE SEE AGAIN AND UR TREND
LINE WE THINK VACCINATION
EFFORTS IN THOSE FACILITY.
TYPES OF. AND THEN RELEASING IN
BRINGING- DAY OF CO THAT THOSE
FACILITIES I WOULD THAT A PER.
ANOTHER THIRTY THOUSAND
REGIONAL CONCERN CONSUMERS
YOUNGER THAN SIXTY FIVE ARE
ALSO A RESIDING IN THESE
LICENSE RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
AND SHOULD ALSO HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED SO THAT'S REALLY A
CLOSER AGAIN BACK TO THE 15% OF
OUR CONSUMERS. ARE THERE ARE.
OWNED AND ON AS WE DISCUSSED-
THE REMAINDER OF OUR CONSUMERS
I SHOULD HAVE OR WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTER ASSISTANCE.
TENSION OF BONDS SOON WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO VACCINATION. SO YOU
KNOW WE THINK WE'VE MADE GOOD
PROGRESS AND THERE'S ADDITIONAL
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS ABOUT. TO
COMMENT ON A AND WE'RE DOING A
LOT OF PLANNING IN THE RUN UP
TO THE BEGINNING OF THEIR
ELIGIBILITY ON MARCH FIFTEENTH.
ALSO THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
I THINK I'VE ADDRESSED THE
QUESTIONS ARE REQUESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND THAT SHE WOULD
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WE HAVE STEVEN PAVLOV
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BYE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS- STEVEN POSSIBLE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
FINANCE WAS ASKED TO RESPOND TO
YOUR TO QUESTION- THE FIRST
BEING WHICH GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENTS FOR DDS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AS FINANCING
DENTAL FIRES SPECIFICALLY
COGNEX NINETEEN OR EQUITY
RELATED. SO THE DIRECTORS
ALREADY PROVIDED A DETAILED
ACCOUNTING OF THE CLOVER
NINETEEN RELATED INVESTMENTS
I'LL JUST REITERATE THAT. TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL FUND OR A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE POINT TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND WAS
INVESTOR FOR CONTINUED RESPONSE
TO COVER NINETEEN. THAT BRINGS
DOWN IN THE FOLLOWING MANNER
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT POINT
THREE MILLION TOTAL FUND OR A
HUNDRED FORTY SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
REGIONAL CENTER PURCHASE OF
SERVICE UTILIZATION. AND THEN
THIRTY SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR STATE OPERATED
FACILITIES SEARCH CAPACITY. ON
THE EQUITY SIDE AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION TOTAL FINE OR A
THREE POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL
FUND FOR COMMUNITY NAVIGATORS
HOW CAN WE JUST LIKE TO NOTE
THIS IS IN ADDITION TO THE
EXISTING LIVING MILLION GENERAL
FUND. THAT'S PROVIDED ON ON
GOING BASIS FOR DISPARITIES
FUNDING PROVIDED TO REGIONAL
CENTRES- THE COMMUNITY
NAVIGATOR PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW
DDS CONTRACTOR FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS TO IMPLEMENT A
NAVIGATOR MODEL STATEWIDE. THE
PURPOSE OF WHICH WOULD BE TO
INCREASE SERVICE AUTHORIZATION
AND EQUALIZATION AND DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES. WITH THE AIM OF
FURTHERING HEALTH EQUITY OF
THAT THE GOVERNMENTAL SERVICES
SYSTEM. THAT WOULD LIMIT COMES.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WE HAVE
SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR AMBULANCE
MEMBERS SEND YOU PICK FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
WAS ASKED TO COMMENT ON FOUR
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS THE FIRST
IS TO SHARE INSIGHTS AND
PERSPECTIVES ON TRADE OFFS OF
PRIORITIZING VACCINE FOR THE
GDS OUR POPULATION. I WON'T
SPEND LONG ON THIS SINCE- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOW EXPANDED
TO- THE VACCINATION TO THE DDS
OUR POPULATION- FOR MANY OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE D. S. OUR
POPULATION BEGINNING MARCH
FIFTEENTH. I THINK THE
QUESTIONS NOW THE QUESTION NOW
WOULD REALLY BE HOW- HOW HOW
THIS WILL BE HOW THIS NEW
POLICY WLL BE IMPLEMENTED.
STRICTER ARJUNAN- ALREADY
PROVIDED A NUMBER OF-
CONSIDERATIONS AND CONCERNS
THERE- I WOULD JUST ADD A
COUPLE- WHICH INCLUDE. BUT HOW
WILL INFORMED CONSENT BE
MANAGED AMONG THIS POPULATION
AND WILL THE PEOPLE
ADMINISTERING THE VACCINE BE
SKILLED AT WORKING WITH
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. I'M MOVING TO THE
SECOND QUESTION HOW DOES
CALIFORNIA COMPARE TO OTHER
STATES REGARDING THE VACCINE
PRIORITIZATION FOR THE DDS
SERVE POPULATION. I'M GOING TO
PUT- FRAME THIS IN TERMS OF KEY
ISSUES THAT STATES HAVE HAD TO
CONSIDER SO THE FIRST QUESTION
WOULD BE- WIN WIN HAS A STATE
DECIDED TO EXPAND THEIR
PRIORITY LIST TO INCLUDE HIGH
RISK MEDICAL CONDITIONS. THE
CDC RECOMMENDS INCLUDING THIS
LIST IN PHASE ONE AND SEE A
VACCINE- PRIORITIZATION BUT
CALIFORNIA AND JUST OVER
TWENTY- STATES HAVE MOVED TO
THIS GROUP UP TO AN EARLIER
PHASE- BUT THE NEXT KEY
QUESTION IS SORT OF WHAT IS
INCLUDED IN THAT LIST OF HIGH
RISK MEDICAL CONDITIONS SO THE
CDC'S LIST- OF HIGH RISK
CONDITIONS INCLUDES DOWN
SYNDROME AS STRICTER BRIDGMAN
HAD MENTIONED- BUT IT DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDE OTHER
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS IS REALLY A LIVING LIST OF
CONDITIONS AND IT'S DEVELOPED
BASED ON AVAILABLE RESEARCH SO
IF A CONDITION IS NOT IN THAT
LIST IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE
IS A HIGH RISK OF SERIOUS
ILLNESS FROM FROM CODED BUT-
SIMPLY THAT THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF RESEARCH ON. THAT PARTICULAR
CONDITION IN THE COPA CONTEXT
SO ONCE THE STATE HAS EXPANDED
ITS PRIORITIZATION TO- INCLUDE
PEOPLE WITH HIGH RISK MEDICAL
CONDITIONS THE QUESTION
BECOMES. DO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND-
WHO IS ELIGIBLE IS THE LIST-
VERY GOOD OR IS THE LIST I'M
SPECIFIC SO CALIFORNIA REALLY
USED ON THE CDC'S LATEST-
ALMOST ALL OF THE CONDITIONS IN
THE CDC'S LIST BUT ALSO
EXPANDED- THE LIST TO INCLUDE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. AND
IMPORTANTLY IT ALSO ALLOWS SOME
DISCRETION BY HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS- TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION ABOUT WHETHER I'M
AN INDIVIDUAL HAS A CONDITION
THAT CAN LEAD TO SERIOUS
ILLNESS FROM KOBE. I WE NOTE
THAT ABOUT FIVE OTHER STATES
FIVE OR SIX OTHER STATES HAVE-
EXPANDED THEIR LIST OF
CONDITIONS TO SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. INCLUDING
DELAWARE NEW YORK- ABOUT SEVEN
STATES ALSO ALLOW SOME
DISCRETION BY HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS INCLUDING TEXAS
MONTANA NEW HAMPSHIRE. THE
THIRD CONSIDERATION WOULD BE
HOW ARE STATES IMPLEMENTING THE
POLICY AND THAT'S REALLY- SORT
OF THE PHASE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ACT. SO ONE OF THE KEY
QUESTIONS IS MUST MUST
INDIVIDUALS PROVIDE EVIDENCE OF
THEIR CONDITION OR IS THE STATE
GOING TO RELY ON SELF
ATTESTATION- MOST STATES HAVE
NOT INCLUDING CALIFORNIA HAVE
NOT REALLY SAID HOW THIS IS
GOING TO WORK. ON IT AND WE
KNOW RIGHT NOW THAT SEVERAL
STATES ARE RELYING ON SELF
ATTESTATION. WESLEY ARE I WOULD
JUST MENTION- STATES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MAKE SPECIAL EFFORTS
TO ACCOMMODATE THE POPULATION I
JUST PROVIDE ONE EXAMPLE- THE
STATE OF OREGON- NOT ONLY
INCLUDED DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IN ITS PHASE ONE
AS SO REALLY IN ITS FIRST-
FIRST PHASE A VACCINE-
ADMINISTRATION BUT IT ALSO. HAS
DONE SOME INTERESTING THINGS
LIKE CREATING A MOBILE DRIVE
THROUGH AT THE PORTLAND-
AIRPORT THAT ACCOMMODATES-
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. THE
QUESTION WE WERE ASKED TO
RESPOND TO IT CONCERNS OR
OBSERVATIONS ON OTHER FISCAL
POLICY DYNAMICS IN CO BID FOR
WHICH WE WANT TO SUBCOMMITTEE
TO BE AWARE. I'M I'M JUST GOING
TO NAME A FEW EXAMPLES HERE- IN
THE FIRST IS THAT THE PANDEMIC
HAS REALLY HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED
FOR BETTER DATA SYSTEMS IN THE-
IN THE DDS SYSTEM. THIS IS
REALLY BEEN A LONG STANDING L.
A. RECOMMENDATION- BUT THE
PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT SOME OF
THESE ISSUES- TO THE FOR
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT THE
SYSTEM IS HAVING TO RELY ON
SORT OF A MAKE SHIFT- PROVIDER
REPORTING SORT OF SYSTEM THNH
TO ENSURE THAT BILLING WILL
HAPPEN- IT'S ALSO. SOMEWHAT
HARD TO RUN- SORT OF REAL TIME
ANALYTICS ON THE CAPACITY OF
THE PROVIDER NETWORK OR ON ON
WHAT- INDIVIDUALS. THE
INDIVIDUAL SERVED ARE IN NEED
OF- BUT ALSO MENTION IT BUT
THEY- BARGE MEN HAVE ALREADY
DISCUSSED- ENROLLMENT BUT THAT
HAS BOTH FISCAL AND POLICY
IMPLICATIONS. I'LL TALK ABOUT
THE FISCAL IMPLICATIONS IN A
MOMENT BUT POLICY WISE- THE
DIRECTOR NOTED SOME OF THE
EFFORTS THEY'VE MADE TO
MITIGATE. THE EFFECTS OF
DECLINING- ENROLLMENT IN THE
SYSTEM. AND BUT WE WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THIS IS THE SIXTH
SENSE HAS BEEN SOMEWHAT LIMITED
AND- THIS CAN. THIS RAISES SOME
CONCERNS IN THE SENSE THAT-
DON'T WAIT OR TO SERVICES FOR
DOING THAT REALLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS IN PARTICULAR. CAN
HAVE ADVERSE EFFECTS- ON LATER
LIFE OUTCOMES AND AS WELL ON US
OVERALL. COST TO THE STATE-
FINALLY- JUST KNOW THAT ANOTHER
QUESTION SORT OF BROUGHT INTO
RELIEF BY THE PANDEMIC IS
WHETHER OR NOT- INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ARE STILL RECEIVING THE ROUTINE
MEDICAL DENTAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH CARE- THAT THEY OFTEN
REALLY NEED. AND HOW WILL
DEFERRED CARE- WE NEED TO MAYBE
M. PROVIDE PROBLEMS- IN THE IN
THE RECOVERY PHASE OF THE
PANDEMIC. FINALLY THE LAST
QUESTION WE'RE ASKED TO COMMENT
ON HIS OBSERVATIONS ON CASELOAD
AND BUDGETED EXPENDITURES SO
THESE ARE THE FISCAL POLICY
ADVOCATES AND CERTAIN FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS THAT I MENTIONED
BEFORE SO WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT- V. AS DIRECTOR BARTMAN
NOTED THERE HAVE BEEN SOME.
ISSUES WITH AN ENROLLMENT-
SINCE THE START OF THE PANDEMIC-
PARTICULARLY IN EARLY START
ENROLLMENT ACTUALLY DECLINED
MONTH OVER MONTH- THE D. THE
DDS- ASSUMPTIONS FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR ARE VERY OPTIMISTIC THEY
ASSUME FOR EXAMPLE OVER 20%
GROWTH. IN THE EARLY START
PROGRAM AND WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THAT DOUBLE- THE ANNUAL
GROWTH OF ANY YEAR OVER THE
PAST TWO DECADES ACTUALLY- SO
IF THIS GROWTH DOESN'T COME TO
PASS COSTS COULD BE OVERSTATED
IN THE DDS BUDGET BY AS MUCH AS
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OR
MORE GENERAL FUND. OUR OFFICE
DOESN'T RECOMMEND DOWNWARD
REVISION TO THE DDS BUDGET AT
THIS TIME- WE WILL KNOW MORE
ABOUT ACTUAL- CASELOAD OF
ENROLLMENT AT THE MAY REVISION
AND WILL ALSO KNOW MORE FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT.
POSSIBLE REVISED ASSUMPTIONS AT
THAT TIME AND WE CAN ADVISE THE
LEGISLATURE THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISS BENNET
NEXT WE HAVE LISA KLEIN BOB
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
REGIONAL CENTER OF THE EAST
BACK. THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME'S
LISA KLEIN ABOUT. AND I
REPRESENT THE REGIONAL CENTER
OF THE EAST BAY WHERE ALAMEDA
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY- THE
QUESTIONS I WAS ASKED OR WHAT
ARE THE LESSONS LEARNED SO FAR.
INCLUDED FOR YOUR REGIONAL
CENTER CLIENTS AND FAMILIES. I
WANT TO SAY THAT IN MANY WAYS
THIS EXPERIENCE OF THE PANDEMIC
HAS BROUGHT US BACK TO OUR
ROOTS AS REALLY COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS WE'VE HAD TO.
LEARN THAT. THE IMPACTS OF
REALLY DEFERRED FOR PEOPLE
DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY LIVE
THEIR FAMILY SOCIOECONOMIC IN
LANGUAGE STATUS. THEIR
DISABILITY AND THEIR OWN
MEDICAL NEEDS ARE RESPONSES
HAVE HAD TO BE TAILORED TO
ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS. THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WE
EXPERIENCE TESTING POSITIVE FOR
COVERT NINETEEN. AS WELL AS
THOSE WHO HAVE DIED HAVE BEEN
PEOPLE LIVING IN CONGREGATE
SETTINGS AND THOSE CASES WE
BELIEVE HAVE ORIGINATED WITH
STAFF WHO WORK MULTIPLE JOBS.
IN MULTIPLE FACILITIES DUE TO
ECONOMIC NECESSITY THIS HAS
AGAIN RAISED THE ISSUE OF THE
IMPACT OF THE LACK OF LIVABLE
WAGES ESPECIALLY IN HIGH COST
REGIONS SUCH AS OURS. I'M
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES HAVE ALSO
MEANT TO BROADCLOTH OF INCOME
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
AND WE'VE LEARNED THAT WE HAVE
TO GO BACK TO OUR ROOTS OF
HELPING PEOPLE TO ACCESS ALL OF
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE IN THE
COMMUNITY INCLUDING FREE LUNCH
PROGRAMS FOOD BANKS AND OTHER.
ASSISTANCE DURING THE PANDEMIC
OR HELPING HAND FUND WHICH
TAKES VOLUNTARY DONATIONS FROM
FELT OTHER PEOPLE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND FAMILIES WAS
CRITICAL TO MEET THE NEEDS. FOR
FOOD AND SHELTER WHEN FAMILIES
HAD NO OTHER SOURCES OF FUNDS I
THINK WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT. REALLY BACK TO THE-
NEED FOR COLLABORATION ACROSS
OUR COUNTIES. FAMILY RESOURCE.
CENTERS PROVIDERS AND OTHER
IMMUNITY BASED. ARE FOR TO
REACH PEOPLE OUR RELATIONSHIPS
WITH LOCAL COUNTIES WELL NOT
PERFECT HAVE WEST LEAD TO
TESTING WHEN THERE ARE.
OUTBREAKS LINKING US TO
ADDITIONAL PP AND ADDITIONAL
WE'VE ADDITION WE'VE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR LOCAL
STATE COUNCIL AND- SHARED IN
THE DISTRIBUTION. OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. WE'VE
ALSO LEARNED THAT THERE ARE
SOME SERVICES THAT MAY BE DONE
EVEN BETTER REMOTELY AND LET-
LARGE LARGER AMOUNTS OF
SATISFACTION AMONG FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUAL SERVICE ONE OF OUR-
FAMILY CONFERENCES CONGRESO
FAMILIAR ARC WHICH HAS TAKEN
PLACE IN PERSON FOR MANY YEARS.
MIGRATED ONLINE VERSIONS AND
THAT HAS BEEN REALLY SUCCESSFUL
AND FAMILIES ARE REPORTING A
GREAT DEAL OF SATISFACTION WITH
THAT. ON THE NEXT QUESTION IS
WHAT ARE THE MAJOR CHALLENGES
AND DIFFICULTIES AT THIS MOMENT
I THINK VACCINATIONS. AND WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH BOTH OF OUR COUNTIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE INDIVIDUALS
WE SERVE THEIR FAMILIES ARE
GOING TO BE GETTING VACCINES AS
SOON AS IT'S POSSIBLE FOR THEM
AND WE'RE REALLY REALLY GLAD.
THAT THE PRIORITIZATION FOR
COMMUNITY CAME LAST WEEK
HOWEVER WE AS EVERYONE HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
PRIORITIZATION DOESN'T MEAN
AVAILABILITY AND MANAGING THAT
GAP INTO A VACCINE IS READILY
AVAILABLE IS GOING TO BE A
CHALLENGE- WE HAVE TO HELP
PEOPLE ACCESS VACCINATION SITES
WE WILL BE WORKING VERY HARD TO
RUN LIST OF OUR MOST. NEEDY
CONSUMERS IN TERMS OF THEIR
CONDITIONS FOR GETTING
VACCINATED BY MARCH FIFTEENTH
WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL
PROVIDERS- ARE COUNTIES- LAST
TWO WEEKS AGO WE HAD A CLINIC
IN COLLABORATION. WITH CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY FOR SIXTY FIVE AND
ABOVE- CONSUME. AND THAT IN ONE
OF OUR US. PROVIDERS WHO WAS
VACCINE PROVIDER ADMINISTERING
THE VACCINATION- BUT WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND- DIRECTOR
BERTRAND DID MENTION THERE IS A
LOT OF VACCINE HESITANCY AND I
THINK WE HAVE TO DO BOTH-
KNOWLEDGE THAT AND WORK ON WHAT
THE ORIGINS OF THAT OUR AND
RECOGNIZE. THAT THERE ARE REAL
EXPERIENCES THAT HAVE LED TO
THAT HISTORICALLY AMONG
CERTAIN- GROUPS OF INDIVIDUALS.
ON REGIONAL CENTERS WANT TO
SUPPORT THE EMERGENCE FROM THE
PANDEMICS ONE OF OUR MAJOR
DIFFICULTIES MOVING FORWARD IS
WE DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE CASE
MANAGERS- TO- REALLY SUPPORT
OUR CONSUMERS AND MEET OUR
CASELOAD RATIOS. THIS HAS BEEN.
AN ONGOING ISSUE AND WE REPORT
ON THIS EVERY YEAR THE NEXT
YEAR IS GOING TO BRING- PEOPLE
WANTING CHANGES AND A- DEMAND
FOR SERVICES AS PEOPLE BEGAN TO
SEE THE FUTURE AND NOT FEEL AS
UNCERTAIN AS THEY HAVE THIS
YEAR. AND THEY WILL WANT REAL
SUPPORT FROM CASE MANAGEMENT IN
MAKING THESE CHANGES THE OTHER-
IMPACT AND DIFFICULTY RIGHT NOW
IS THAT WE'VE BEEN REALLY
IMPACTED BY ALTERNATIVE SERVICE
DELIVERY AND THE WAVE THERE ARE
ANTIQUATED I'M FISCAL SYSTEM.
DOESN'T ALLOW FOR SEAMLESS
TRANSITIONS FROM ONE WAY OF
BILLING TO ANOTHER AND IS
REALLY COMPLEX AND HARD FOR
BOTH- SERVICE PROVIDERS AND OUR
STAFF. AND SO AS WE MOVE
FORWARD ON THE NEXT QUESTION
WAS HOW CAN THE STATE WORK TO
SUPPORT REGIONAL CENTERS. AND
THE DDS POPULATION IN THE
COMING MONTHS I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE KEEPING ON THE
RADAR THE TRANSITION TO BLUE
SHIELD. AT CONTRACT FOR THAT
AND MAKING SURE THAT THAT
DOESN'T IT OUR POP. OF FIVE.
BECAUSE BEEN DEVELOPING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COUNTIES WHO
AT THIS POINT I'M NOT SURE OF
WHAT THEY ARE VACCINE
ALLOCATION IS GOING TO BE WITH
THE NEW SYSTEM AND I JUST WANT
TO KEEP OUR EYES FOCUSED ON
THAT- AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO
MARCH. FIFTEENTH THE OTHER
THING IS CONTINUATION OF THE
FLEXIBILITY- DURING THE
PANDEMIC WILL BE IMPORTANT ON
BOTH IN OUR ABILITY TO. PRETTY
QUICKLY RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES
WITH HEALTH AND SAFETY- REQUEST
FROM PROVIDERS AND WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE NEXT YEAR IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE WILL THERE
BE CONTINUING OUTBREAKS WE ALSO
WANT FLEXIBILITIES IN TERMS OF
REMOTE ACCESS OPTIONS. WHEN
THIS IS PREFERRED BY
INDIVIDUALS AND AGAIN THE
SUPPORT FOR MORE CASE
MANAGEMENT COMBAT POSITIONS AT
A COMPETITIVE RATE SO WE CAN
PROVIDESERVICES AS THEY SHOULD
BE PROVIDED. AND JUST IN IN
CLOSING ON THIS- MY PENSION AND
CONCERNS AS WE EMERGE FROM THE
PANDEMIC. IS I WANT TO BE SURE
WE TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP
THE THING SOMEPLACE. THAT
WORKED AND TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
ASK PEOPLE WHAT THEY WANT
MOVING FORWARD WE CAN'T ASSUME
AND I DON'T THINK ANYONE WANTS
TO ASSUME THAT EVERYTHING IS
GOING TO REFER BACK TO FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY. IF THAT'S REMOTE
ACCESS IN FACT ACCESS TO TELE
THERAPY ONGOING- WE MAY HAVE WE
MAY CONTINUE THAT AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
ALL OF THE COLLABORATIONS WITH
COUNTIES AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. SO THAT THE
PEOPLE SERVED OR SEEN AS PART.
OF EVERY COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN NOW WE HAVE CARLOS.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER. THANK
YOU DOCTOR ONLINE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD I
AM CARLOS FLORES EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF. THE SAN DIEGO
REGIONAL CENTER WE SERVE SAN
DIEGO AND IMPERIAL COUNTY I'M
HERE MY RESPONSES TO THE
COMMITTEE'S QUESTIONS. LESSONS
LEARNED SO FAR IN CODE FOR OUR
REGIONAL SERVICE LINES AND
CLIENTS AND FAMILIES ARE THE
NEED FOR CONTINUOUS CONTACT
WITH CLIENTS AND FAMILIES AND
THE ENTIRE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES NETWORK. I WILL
LEARN HOW TO TRANSITION STAFF
TO WORK REMOTELY STAFF LEARNED
MUCH ABOUT USING TECHNOLOGY TO
SPEAK CONNECTED WITH CLIENTS
AND FAMILIES. WILL LEARN HOW TO
MOBILIZE FOR THE DISTRIBUTION
OF PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT PPE SINCE MID MARCH
WE HAVE COLLABORATED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
OUR SERVICE PROVIDER COMMUNITY.
TO DISTRIBUTE MORE THAN FIVE
POINT TWO MILLION ARTICLES OF
PPP TO CLIENTS FAMILY MEMBERS
AND. SERVICE PROVIDERS STAFF.
WE'LL HOW TO MOBILE IT COVERTLY
TEN NOW. WE ARE. WITH SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO CREATE FOURTEEN
TESTING SITES OR CLIENTS FAMILY
MEMBERS SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
STAFF AND REGIONAL CENTER
STAFF. MOBILE TESTING IS ALSO
AVAILABLE IN TRAVEL TO SITE IS
NOT POSSIBLE. NO COST NO CHARGE
FOR TESTING OF THE TESTING TASK
FORCE OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY MADE THIS
EFFORT POSSIBLE FOR WHICH WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL. LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE NEED FOR EXPANDING
TECHNOLOGY IN REMOTE RURAL
AREAS AND FOR CLIENTS AND
FAMILIES THAT ARE JUST A
FINANCIALLY DISADVANTAGED. THE
MAJOR CHALLENGES AND
DIFFICULTIES AT THIS MOMENT R.
AS HAS BEEN SAID. OBTAINING
VACCINATIONS OF THE
DIFFICULTIES ARE BECAUSE OF
INSUFFICIENT NOTICES GAINES
IMPERIAL AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES. SAN DIEGO COUNTY
IMPAIR IMPERIAL COUNTIES. CAL
FIRE CBS IN WALL GREEN AND
WALKING PHARMACIES HAVE BEEN
OUTSTANDING IN THEIR
PREPARATION AND THE
COMMUNICATION. OF WHICH
OFFICIALS- QUANTITIES OF
VACCINES OTHER CHALLENGES
SHOULD. AND HOPEFULLY WILL
QUICKLY DISSIPATE. I CHALLENGE
CREAMS SYSTEMS FOR REAL SIR
PRIOR FOR TO AND ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES- WAS A RECENT
CHALLENGE AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT
OF WORK. GOOD NINETEEN BURNED
OUT AND RELAX IN OUR GUARDS
CHALLENGE AFTER THE
THANKSGIVING CHRISTMAS AND NEW
YEAR'S DAY HOLIDAYS HAS BEEN
SET THE RATE OF COMMON
INFECTIONS EXPLODED ON OUR
CLIENTS AND OUR SERVICE
PROVIDERS STAFF. THE STATE CAN
WORK TO SUPPORT REGIONAL
CENTERS AND IF YOU JUST
POPLATION IN THE COMING MONTHS
BY. CONTINUING THE TREMENDOUS
SUPPORT AND THAT WE HAVE
RECEIVED ACROSS THE STATE ARE
BEGINNING- FROM THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC FROM OUR
PARTNERS IN SACRAMENTO. BY
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH OUR
SYSTEM EXAMINING THE NEED TO
PAY LIVING WAGES TO THE DIRECT
CARE STAFF OF SERVICE PROVIDERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH OUR SYSTEM X. IN
EXAMINING THE NEED TO REDUCE
THE CASELOAD RATIOS IN REGIONAL
CENTRES ACROSS CALIFORNIA. MY
AND CONCERNS ONCE WE EMERGE
FROM THE PANDEMIC ARE. THE
CALIFORNIA'S IT HAS A CLEAR
PLAN AS WE PREPARE TO RETURN TO
PROVIDING SERVICES IN PERSON.
I'M VISUAL SYSTEM THAT TAKES
INTO CONSIDERATION THE LESSONS
LEARNED AND EXAMINES WAYS TO
MAKE OUR SYSTEM MORE FLEXIBLE
AND LESS COMPLICATED FOR THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE AND THEIR
FAMILIES. I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE POSSIBLE REGRESSION AND
PEOPLE SKILLS AND BEHAVIORS
BECAUSE OF THE LENGTH. OF THE
PANDEMIC. I ENVISIONED WE
RESUME DISCUSSING THE RATE
STUDY COMPLETED BY BROWN'S
ASSOCIATES AND WE REFORM AND
UNTANGLE OUR RATE SYSTEM AND
ADEQUATELY REIMBURSED SERVICE
PROVIDERS. I ENVISION A SYSTEM
THAT EFFECTIVELY UTILIZES
TECHNOLOGY. ESPECIALLY
ESPECIALLY IN A RURAL HARD TO
REACH AREAS AND FOR CLIENTS AND
FAMILIES WHO LACK THE WHO LACK
THE TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE OF
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. AND FINALLY
I ENVISION A SYSTEM. IS SYSTEM
WIDE CAMPAIGN TO RESTORE THE
REFERRALS AND NUMBER OF INFANTS
AND TODDLERS SERVES NEARLY
START PROGRAM. MMHM IN CLOSING.
I THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IN ALL CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS IN CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE STAFF FOR THE
TREMENDOUS SUPPORT THAT YOU
PROVIDE FOR PERSONS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS. THANK YOU SIR NEXT WE
HAVE ELIZABETH GOMEZ DIRECTOR
OF THE INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON. I THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY HERE TODAY MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH GOMEZ AND I HAVE TWO
SONS ONE OF WHICH HAS DOWN
SYNDROME BOTH OF MY CHILDREN
HAVE RECEIVED SERVICES FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTER. I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE. AN
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES
OUTREACH AND ASSISTANCE TO
UNDERSERVED LATINO FAMILIES
SERVED BY REGIONAL CENTERS.
THROUGH THE DEVIOUS DISPARITY
GRANT PROGRAM WE HELP FAMILIES
NAGRIK NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM WE
WORK HAND IN HAND TO BREAK DOWN
BARRIERS ON A PEER TO PEER
BASIS. TO OUR COMMUNITY AND
FIGURE OUT THE ORDERS. WE HAVE
THE COMMUNITY TRUST BECAUSE WE
ARE THE COMMUNITY. WE ARE ALSO
VERY THANKFUL FOR SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HELPED US LIKE
OUR DIRECTOR NANCY BARGE MEN
AND OTHER DEVIOUS STAFF ALSO
WANT TO THANK OTHER COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ALSO HELPED
US AND CONTRIBUTE- WITH HER
WORK. THIS YEAR OUR FAMILY'S
HARDSHIPS ARE AT A WHOLE
DIFFERENT LEVEL. CORBETT HAS
MAGNIFIED THE DISPARITIES MANY
OF OUR FAMILIES CAN FIND MONEY
TO PAY FOR FOOD AND RENT AND
CAN ACCESS EDUCATION BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF TECHNOLOGY AND
SUPPORTS. IN TO MANY OF US HAVE
GOTTEN COBIT THE DATA SHOWS HOW
VULNERABLE WE ARE. THIS YEAR
OUR FAMILY'S HARDSHIPS ARE A
WHOLE DIFFERENT LEVEL. THEY ARE
MAGNIFIED BY ALL THE ISSUES
THAT WE ARE ALL WORKING WITH
AND I WANT TO SHARE A FEW
SUGGESTIONS FROM THE WORK THAT
WE HAVE BEEN DOING WITH A
LATINO FAMILIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THE DIRECTIVES WORK.
ONLY IF IMPLEMENTED PROPERLY
THE DIRECTORS THAT DDS ISSUED
SHOULD BE HELPFUL FOR OUR
FAMILIES. BUT THERE IS
SOMETIMES A WALL WE HIT AT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS SOME REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE TOLD US. THAT THE
DIRECTOR SORRY ARE NOT
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY ARE
SOMETIMES JUST SUGGESTIONS.
THEY DON'T APPLY TO EVERYONE WE
ARE SEEING A DISCONNECT BETWEEN
HOW THIS MEASURES WERE MEANT TO
HELP FAMILIES BUT IN MANY CASES
THEY DO NOT. IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO HAVE A CLEAR
DIRECTIVE THAT IS NOT LEFT UP
TO THE TWENTY ONE DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATIONS. THE COMMUNITY
VOICE MUST BE HEARD. THE MOST
OUR COMMUNITY SHOULD BE
CONSULTED AT ALL LEVELS FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION. PARTNERS
CAN PLAY A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IF
YOU TAKE OUR CONCERNS SERIOUSLY
AND IF YOU DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT. CALDERON HUMILITY WORKS
THIS IS THEM ALL OFTEN LACKS A
SENSE OF COMPASSION FOR
FAMILIES THEY MUST GO THROUGH
UNREALISTIC TO OBTAIN THE MUCH
NEEDED SERVICES. THEY FEEL
HUMILIATED FOR HAVING TO BEG
FOR EXTRA HOURS OF SUPPORT.
WHEN THEY ARE DENIED OUR
FAMILIES WHO PRIMARILY SPEAK
SPANISH ARE TOLD THAT THEY
SHOULD GO FOR A FAIR HEARING.
BUT THERE IS NOTHING FAIR ABOUT
THE HEARINGS WHEN OUR FAMILIES
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS OR
THE LAW IN THE REGIONAL CENTERS
BRING LAWYERS AND EXPERIENCED
STAFF. THERE ARE BRIGHT SPOTS
BUT EVERYONE COULD DO A BETTER
JOB OF VALIDATING EMBRACING AND
SUPPORTING OUR COMMUNITY. COBIT
REQUIRES A SENSE OF URGENCY.
AND IT SADDENS ME WHEN A FAMILY
MEMBER TURN SO THE REGIONAL
CENTERS WHEN THEY GET COLD IT
AND THERE IS NO SENSE OF
URGENCY THERE IS NO PROTOCOL.
REGIONAL CENTER SOMETIMES WAIT
WEEKS BEFORE PROVIDING AN
ANSWER TO A REQUEST FOR HELP.
WE HEAR THAT SOME FAMILIES. ONE
EVEN REPORT THAT SOMEONE HAS
TESTED POSITIVE BECAUSE THEY
THEY CAN'T RISK LOSING SERVICES
FOR THEIR CHILDREN. FAMILIES
ARE TRULY SCARE. JUST A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO WE WERE ASSISTING
A FAMILY WHO WAS DENIED
ADDITIONAL RESPITE HOURS THE
MOM WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF A HIGH
RISK PREGNANCY AND HAD TWO
OTHER CHILDREN WITH AUTISM. SHE
HAD TO GO TO A FAIR HEARING
OVER THE PHONE TO MAKE THAT.
EVEN WORSE BARRIER IT WAS SO
STRESSFUL IN THE MEANING FOR
HER THAT A FEW HOURS LATER SHE
WENT INTO LABOR AND SHE
DELIVERED HER BABY PREMATURELY
THE BABY STILL IN THE NICK YOU.
NO ONE WANTS TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY PARENTS ARE
RUNNING IN A MAYES THAT NEVER
ENDS THEY ASKED FOR HELP FROM
THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND THEY
POINT THEM TOWARDS THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM. THE SCHOOL SENT PARENTS
BACK TO THE REGIONAL CENTERS
AND NO ONE GETS ANY HELP.
VACCINES HAVE BEEN ANOTHER
ISSUE OF DISPARITY. MANY
LATINOS WERE AFRAID OF THE
VACCINEAT THE BEGINNING. EVEN
WHEN THEY WERE ELIGIBLE TO GET
IT. WE HAVE BEEN EDUCATING
OURSELVES AND NOW THAT THEY
SOME OF THEM WANT TO TAKE THE
VACCINE. BUT SOME HAVE TO ASK
FOR A LETTER FROM THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND EVEN THAT SOMETIMES
HAS BEEN A FIGHT. MANY LATINO
PARENTS HAVE BEEN TURNED DOWN.
OUR FAMILIES. ARE THE FRONTLINE
WORKERS NOW. THEY ARE THE
TEACHERS THE AIDS THE PURPOSE.
EVERYTHING ELSE FOR THEIR KIDS
WITH MINIMAL HELP. THEY ARE THE
TRUE HEROES AND THEY SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO BEG FOR EVERYTHING. I'M
HERE TO ASK FOR HELP. AND
INCOMPLETE I'LL SAY THAT THE
ICC CAN FIGURE OUT THE ORDER. I
HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH
SOME OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS
AND WE'RE HERE TO SERVE. POOR
THEIR WORK IN HOURS WE BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN COLLABORATE
TOGETHER AND THAT WE CAN MAKE A
CHANGE FOR OUR COMMUNITY. ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO THANK DEPARTMENT
FOR ALL THE WORK AND THEIR- AND
ALL THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
PROVIDE TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE ICC.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
COMMONS FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
YOUR ADVOCACY. NEXT WE HAVE A
ON CARUTHERS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AMERICAN BROTHERS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE COUNCIL
ON DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
STATE BODY WITH INDEPENDENT
AUTHORITY TO INFORM AND
ADVOCATEFOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITY VACCINE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE I'M WITH THE
TWO QUESTIONS ABOUT ASPEN
RESPOND TO ABOUT TO START WITH
THE SECOND FIRST- AND THAT'S
THE I. D. PERSPECTIVE REALLY
HAS BEEN PRESENT THROUGHOUT
VARIOUS FORMS. FIVE OF THE
SEVENTY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BACKS IF IS YOUR
COMMITTEE ARE DISABILITY
ADVOCATES AND- I WE'VE ISSUED
JOINT LETTERS TOGETHER ARE
THOSE LETTERS WHICH CIRCULATED
THROUGH FOR COMMITTEE SIGN ON
THAT'S RESULTED IN A TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY ORGANIZATIONS.
JOINING INTO THESE EFFORTS ON
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS ARE REACHED
OUT TO THEIR MEMBERS SO THAT
THEY CAN BE HEARD AND WE THINK
THAT'S RESULTED IN THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE CONTACTING THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- INDIVIDUALS
SHARE THEIR STORIES- IN THAT
WITH THE PRESS. SO IN SOME
THERE THERE WERE MANY FORMS
THERE ARE MANY AVENUES NOR MANY
VOICES WITH ONE MESSAGE
PRIORITIZE PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. AND
OTHER DISABILITIES NOW. AND
LAST WEEK BECAUSE PERFECT
RESPONDED WITH. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR. FOR OUT. MY WHAT
PURPOSE IS GRAY. ISN'T REALLY
THIS. IS A WIN. WELL WE WANT TO
BE EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY THERE
ARE REASONS TO HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE MARCH FIFTEENTH.
ABOUT THAT TIME LINE DOES NOT
TAKE AWAY FROM THIS BEING THE
MOST FORWARD THINKING INCLUSIVE
CRITERIA I'VE SEEN- THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY I THINK YOU SAW IN
YOUR PRODUCT ROCKY HARLING
WHETHER STATES ARE DOING IT.
AND WHAT CALIFORNIA DID WAS
KIND OF TOOK THE BEST FROM
OTHER STATES WERE DOING AND IT
TOGETHER INTO ONE PROPOSAL.
EVEN WITNESSED PRAISE THERE ARE
CRITICAL ELEMENTS WE STILL NEED
TO WORK FOR I TO COME TO MIND
WHO AND HOW- THE CRITERIA IS A
LIST OF CONDITIONS AND
EXPERIENCES AND I THINK THIS
ALLOWS THE STATE AN
OPPORTUNITY. THE MEDICAL SYSTEM
DOES NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR
INDIVIDUAL DETERMINATION OF
EACH REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMER
OF EACH PERSON TO DEVELOP IN
THE SOMEBODY EACH PERSON WHO
FITS THIS CRITERIA. SO THERE'S
A SOLUTION FOR THAT. THE STATE
CAN EMPLOY THE DEATH. BY STATE.
ALL REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMERS
MEET THE DEFINITION. OF
CRITERIA COPE WITH LIFE
THREATENING YES WE KNOW THAT TO
BE TRUE SECOND CRITERIA
CORPORATE LIMITS. ORIGINAL
CENTERS CONSUMERS ABILITY GET
REGULAR KERR ABSOLUTELY THREE
CRITERIA PROVIDING KOBE CARE
WILL BE CHALLENGING BECAUSE A
PERSON'S DISABILITY. ABSOLUTELY
SO THE STATE CAN ISSUE THIS
REGIONAL CONSUMERS REGIONAL
CENTER CONSUMERS CAN ALSO ISSUE
THIS FOR. OUR DETERMINATION FOR
ALL AGES AS RECIPIENTS- THROUGH
DSS AND ALL SEA BASS
PARTICIPANTS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND- EACH
PERSON IN THESE PROGRAMS HERE'S
WHAT'S KEY YOU HAVE RECEIVED AN
INDIVIDUAL REVIEW. ALL RIGHTY
TO DETERMINE THE BETTER
DISABILITY IS SEVERE ENOUGH TO
QUALIFY FOR THE STATE SERVICES.
SO ANOTHER ISSUE A SEVERITY IS
NOT NEEDED. ALSO IT'S HARD TO
MANAGING WHAT REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMER WOULD NOT MEET THESE
CONDITIONS AND- MAKE ME
REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN LIVING IN
ISOLATION FOR A YEAR FOR A-
YEAR. HOW COOL WOULD WITH
THREATEN THEIR LIVES AND IMPACT
OR SERVICES. THANK YOU LET'S
BECOME MASTERS DETAILING AND
REALLY GREAT STORIES. THAT WHAT
PEOPLE ARE LIVING WITH. SO THE
STATE STILL NEEDS TO WORK OUT
WHO ENSURING PERFECT DAHLE READ
CENTER. SITES RESEARCH AND
ABOUT TO SPEND. IT'S EFFECTIVE
TO. APPROACH THAT LEVERAGES THE
REVIEW OF SEVERITY IT'S ALREADY
BEEN COMPLETED. BY MY ESTIMATE
IS THAT THIS WOULD BE ABOUT
300-724-0000 ADULTS WHO ARE
UNDER SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD SO
MANAGEABLE NUMBER. MOVING FROM
WHO TO HOW ADVOCATES OF ALSO
GAUGING HOW TO GET THE VACCINE
TO CONSUMERS. AND EARLY DRAFT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH SAID PEOPLE DISABILITY
SHOULD NOT GET VACCINATED MAX
MASS SITES. THANKFULLY THIS IS
DROPPED AWAY PEOPLE WITH ID
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO OBTAIN THE
VACCINE AT WHATEVER LOCATION
MEETS THEIR NEEDS. THAT COULD
BE A MASS LOCATION COULD BE
WITH HER HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
COULD BE AT A PHARMACY WHATEVER
IS AVAILABLE TO ANYONE ELSE.
SHOULD REMAIN AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE WITH IDT. ADDITIONALLY
OUR COMMUNITY HAS A RICH
NETWORK TO PROVIDE COMMUNITY
ACCESS POINTS. AS I SAY WE'RE
SCRAPPY- GIVE IT SOMETHING AND
WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT WORK SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE STATE COUNCIL WE
HAVE SEVENTY STAFF THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WERE ABLE TO
DISTRIBUTE. A HUNDRED AND FIVE.
POINT FIVE MILLION PIECES OF PP
OVER THE LAST YEAR- THANK YOU
TO THE- TO LISA AND OTHERS TO
COMMENT ABOUT THAT PARTNERSHIP
AND WE JUST DID IT IS TAPPING
INTO. BY THE SOUTH AFRICAN
NETWORKS THE FAMILY ADVOCATE
NETWORKS THE PROVIDERS THE
REGIONAL CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- IT'S REALLY A MIX OF
FORMAL AND INFORMAL NETWORKS.
IT'S ENGAGED AND IT'S READY TO
ACTIVATE A VACCINES SO I THINK
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE
IS TO HAVE THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR. USE OUR NETWORKS
TO INCREASE COMMUNITY YOU CAN
REACH ACCESS POINTS I WILL
PROVIDE LOCATION STAFF
PAPERWORK THEY PROVIDE MET BACK
SEEMS A MEDICAL STAFF. THERE'S
A LOT OF ADVANTAGES TO THIS
APPROACH INCLUDING PROVIDING
VACCINES AND MILLER SETTINGS-
THIS INCREASES TRUST IT REDUCES
VACCINE HESITANCY MAY ACTUALLY
USE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES OF
PEOPLE JUST DON'T LIKE SHOTS.
IT ALSO PROVIDES THE SERVICES
TYPICALLY PROVIDED IN A VARIETY
OF LANGUAGES WITH CULTURAL
AWARENESS SO. THAT MAYBE BRIDGE
THERE TO- ALSO ON HOW WE NEED
TO HAVE BEEN SALUTE- IDEAS
COULD BE DONE BY LEVERAGE PEDRO.
CENTER TRANSFER. PROVIDERS TO
GET PEOPLE TO COMMUNITY VACCINE
EVENTS- ALSO CREDIBLY WE COULD
GET THE SERVICES TO
VACCINATORS. USE THE SERVICES
TO GET BACK CENTERS TO PEOPLE
WE'RE TRULY HOMEBOUND. ALSO
PART OF HOUSE WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS EQUITY. I THINK
COMMUNITY IN RIDGEWOOD PART OF
THIS FOR THE REASONS ALREADY
MENTIONED BUT ANOTHER WAY IS TO
CREATE A PRIORITY ACCESS CODE
FOR MASS SITES AND SET ASIDE
APPOINTMENTS- FOR BY PARK AND
OTHERS WHO ARE UNDERSERVED.
LASTLY THE VACCINE SHOULD
REMAIN VOLUNTARY SO PEOPLE CAN
MAKE DECISIONS THAT ARE PASSED
FROM CONDITIONS AND THEIR OWN
HOUSE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING BETWEEN NOW AND MARCH
FIFTEENTH TO MAKE THIS A
SUCCESSFUL CAN BE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. WITH THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAS TO
SEE IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAIR OF ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESSES TO TWO OF
THE REGIONAL CENTER DIRECTORS
LISA AND- AND CARLOS. IS THAT.
WHERE HAVE THE HEALTH PLAN'S
BEEN DANI'S SOCIAIS WHERE THEY
HAVE THIS DATA. A BASE OF WHO
IS- OF THE ID POPULATION WE'RE
ARE THEY IN CONJUNCTION OF
HELPING OF BRING THE POPULATION
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE BEING PROTECTED HAVE
YOU HAD ANY OPPORTUNITIES. FROM
ANY OF THE HMO AND PPO SHOWS
THAT THAT ARE OUT THERE TO.
CREATE A WILLINGNESS TO BE ABLE
TO HELP THIS POPULATION. I CAN
START ON THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER- WE HAVE NOT WORKED
WITH HEALTH PLANS ON THIS
BECAUSE UP UNTIL THIS POINT THE
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION HAS
FOCUSED ON BOTH THE FEDERAL
PARTNERSHIP FOR PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN. LICENSE RESIDENTIAL CARE
AND IT HAS BEEN THROUGH THE
COUNTY SO VERY FEW INDIVIDUAL
PROVIDERS UP UNTIL THIS POINT
WOULD BE THROUGH THE HEALTH
PLANS HAVE HAD ACCESS TO
VACCINES I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
WILL CHANGE IN THE FUTURE BUT
THAT'S BEEN. OUR EXPERIENCE UP
UNTIL THIS POINT AND ACTUALLY
SOME OF EVEN THE TRACKING ON
THE VACCINE HASN'T APPEARED TO
BE CENTRALIZED TO THE HEALTH
PLANS AS OF YET SO THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER FRAZIER
THIS IS CARLOS FLORES DIRECTOR
RESIGNING REGIONAL CENTER WE-
WE HAVEN'T HAD. ANY PLANNING.
WITH OUR MANAGER OUR MEDICARE
ON MANAGED CARE PLANS-
REGARDING VACCINATIONS BUT WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF KAISER KAISER
IS PROVIDING VACCINATIONS
WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT THOUGH IS
JUST SENSE OF THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN. IS WE'VE HAD- CLOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH ALL OF THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO ENSURE
THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC PEOPLE
GET THEIR OTHER MEDICAL
ATTENTION THAT THEY NEED TO
ROUTINE CARE AND EMERGENCIES
AND- OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
NECESSARY. SO THEY'VE BEEN
REALLY GOOD ABOUT PARTICIPATING
IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE WANT ABOUT
MOST BUILDINGS- RECEIVE THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED THAT IS NOT
COVERED RELATED. AND WHAT. IS
COVERED RELATED THEY'VE BEEN
EQUALLY. WITH REGARDS TO HOUSE
A EXCEL CENTER. THAT'S YOUR SIR
YEAH THANK YOU SO THIS WOULDN'T
QUESTION I LIKE TO DRAW ON
DIRECTOR BARGAIN. SO WHEN YOU
MENTION THE ADDITIONAL RESPITE
CARE OF FLEXIBILITY AND WHATNOT
WHAT OTHER PROVISIONS ARE BEING
MADE FOR SOMEONE KIND OF A PARA
PROFESSIONAL. WHO WITH THE
CHILD OR ADULT HAS BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES DUE TO THE CONSTRAINTS
OF CO GOOD FOR WEEKS THEY NEED
ONE ON ONE ON A LARGER BASIS.
FAMILIES ABLE TO BE ABLE TO
CARE FOR THE INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE
OF THE ADDITIONAL STRESSES-
THEY'VE BEEN BROUGHT THEIR
WHOLE LIFE IS CHANGED HELLO AND
YOU KNOW THE UNIQUENESS OF
CONSISTENCY AND A LOT OF THE-
THE OF THE POPULATION IS
NECESSARY. HOW ARE WE
ADDRESSING THROUGH ON THIS CALL
THAT FUNDING THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THOSE
ADDITIONAL NAMES THROUGH
BEHAVIORAL OR DUAL DIAGNOSIS.
COMPONENTS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER YOU'RE
BRINGING UP A- AN ISSUE OF
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE THAT I
HAVE- HEARD FROM FAMILIES AND-
IT WAS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
FIRST AREAS IN WHICH WE
IDENTIFIED. A CONCERN AS TO HOW
OUR FAMILIES NOW THAT ARE
HAVING AT HOME LEARNING THEIR
HAVING TO SUPPORT- THEIR CHILD
TO HAVE REALLY EXTENSIVE NEEDS
AND NEEDING SUPPORT BUT THEN.
WE WERE HEARING THAT THERE ARE-
SERVICE PROVIDERS-
UNDERSTANDABLY- THAT WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO GO AND PROVIDE IN
PERSON SUPPORT AND
INTERVENTION- BOTH FOR THE
SAFETY OF THE FAMILY AND FOR
THE SAFETY OF THE- IT COULD BE
THE ABA PROVIDER COULD BE THE
SUPPORT PERSON THAT'S GIVING
RELIEF THAT CAN BE YOU KNOW A
NUMBER OF SUPPORT GOING INTO
THE HALL. OUR FAMILIES HAVE
FACED A HORRIFIC YEAR THERE'S
JUST NO THERE'S NOTHING THAT
THAT I CAN SAY THAT IS MANY OF
THE RELEASED THE FLEXIBILITIES
THAT WE ALL PUT IN THERE IS
THAT WE HAVE FAMILIES THAT HAVE
REALLY STRUGGLED AND BEING ABLE
TO KIND OF NAVIGATE HOW TO FACE
A PARTICULAR CHALLENGE
SITUATIONS THAT SAD. LIKE YOU
HAD NOTED RESPITE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT REST THAT WAS
ACCEPTABLE AND AVAILABLE- MANY
OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS- HAD
IMMEDIATELY STARTED INCREASING
ROUTES THAT ARE LOOKING AT
PERSONAL ASSISTANCE- SO FAMILY
MEMBERS- COULD USE MAYBE
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED TO SUPPORT
WITHIN THEIR OWN FAMILY UNIT-
ADDITIONALLY WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT SOME OF THE MORE RECENT
DIRECTIVES RELATED TO VACCINES
AND DEFINITIONS. REALLY THE
REASON WHY I WANTED TO BE ABLE
TO GET CLARITY AS YOU THOSE
DEFINITIONS FOR WHO IS A
HEALTHCARE WORKER WAS BECAUSE
THE THESE ARE THE FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT ARE SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUALS IN THE HALL. YOU
KNOW A CHILD WITH HIGHLY
COMPLEX NEEDS AND SO WANTED TO
PROVIDE WHAT EVER REALLY
KNOWING IT'S STILL A CHALLENGE
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE IN THE
HOME- MAKING SURE THAT WE TOOK
THE BARRIER AWAY. NOT. HAVING
ACCESS ON BASED ON I'M IN.
LOOKING AT ALTER. HAVING
PROVIDER IMMEDIATELY AND BE
ABLE TO DOING REMOTE SUPPORT.
ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO BE
FLEXIBLE INSTEAD OF A ONE HOUR
YOU KNOW IN PERSON SUPPORT YOU
KNOW MAKE IT YEAH THAT- FAMILY
OR THE CHILD ARE NOT ABLE TO
ATTEND FOR ONE FULL HOUR BREAK
IT UP IN FIFTEEN MINUTE
INCREMENTS. YOU KNOW JUST GET
CREATIVE WE HAVE- REALLY USED
OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS IN NON
RESIDENTIAL ALSO TO START
GETTING CREATIVE IN HOW DO YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR GETTING-
KIND OF CONNECTING PEOPLE TO BE
WITH THEIR FRIENDS AND SO
THEY'RE NOT AS ISOLATED- SO
AGAIN EVERYBODY HAS HAD TO
THINK OUTSIDE OF THE BOX. I'M
ON HOW TO SUPPORT- WE HAVE
SEEN- WHERE THERE'S BEEN A NEED
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO- HAVE SOME
RESPITE UNFORTUNATELY ONE OF
THE AREAS THAT WE HAVE HAD THE
GREATEST. IMPACT OF LOSS OF
PROVIDERS. MORE FAILURE TO WE
HAVE TO STILL SEE IF THEY'RE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE.
SERVICES IS OUT OF HOME
RESPITE- SO IMMEDIATELY WE
REALLY DO NEED TO TAKE A LOOK
AT HOW DO WE START GAINING. YOU
KNOW ADAM HOME RESPITE OR THOSE
RESOURCES SO FAMILIES CAN
ACCESS THEM AND NOT HAVE
FURTHER DELAY IN GETTING THAT
REALLY- SO RIGHT NOW WE JUST
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO STAY VERY
DILIGENT- I THINK IT WAS- VERY
WELL NOTED ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT
LONGER TERM. IMPACTS ARE GOING
TO. BE FACED BY THESE FAMILIES
WE HAVE TO STAY IN CONTACT WITH
THEM AND SEE WHAT SUPPORT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE- SO WE
CAN- MEDICAID-ANY ADDITIONAL
OUR FUTURE RESTS. ON SHOULD IT
BE FACED. ONE MORE QUESTION
THROUGH THE CHAIR. OF MARTIN
WHEN WE- TALKED EARLIER IT WHEN
THE ONSET OF CODED. THERE WAS A
LOT OF CONFUSION AND I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE YOUR FLEXIBILITY.
COMPONENT TO THIS BECAUSE ONE
SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL AND YOU
WERE ABLE TO BE ADAPTIVE. AND
ACTUALLY. ENCOURAGED THE
PROVIDERS TO BE FLEXIBLE AND
THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX WHICH WAS
UNIQUE. IN OUR WORLD- BUT WHAT
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ASK IS IT
THEN THE CONFUSION IN THE
BEGINNING AND NOT WHAT HOW MANY
PROVIDERS ACTUALLY WE DID WE
LOSE TO ATTRITION. AND THEN
ALSO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
SCOPE OF THAT. THE WORK FORCE
DON'T ON BEING DELETED ALSO
WHERE ARE WE AS FAR AS BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE A QUALITY
MEASURABLE OUTCOME FOR THE I.
D. D. POPULATION. DUE TO THE
LOSS OF PROVIDERS WHO WORKED
INITIALLY ABLE TO. BEAR THE
BRUNT OF THE OF THE UNCERTAINTY
COM. YOU KNOW WHERE WHERE ARE
WE ON THE- YEAH LET LET ME SEE
IF I CAN ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS
THAT I HEARD AND THEN A FURTHER
CLARITY IS NEEDED PLEASE LET ME
NOW- TO THE QUESTION AND I KNOW
THAT ON THE NEXT PANEL I HAVE A
QUESTION THAT'S BEEN ASKED OF
ME- IS KIND OF WHAT IS THAT
PROVIDER. NETWORK WHAT WHO HAVE
WE LOST- I'LL START WITH WE
HAVE LIMITED VISIBILITY INTO-
IF THERE'S PROVIDERS WERE NO
LONGER PROVIDING SERVICES AND
WE'RE CONTINUING TO TAKE A LOOK
AT IT BUT WHAT WE DO HAVE. IS
WE'RE TAKING- VERY CLOSE LOOK
AT THOSE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
BILLING BUT WHAT WE CALL
CLAIMING SO WE LOOK AT OUR
CLAIMS. AND TO SEE HOW MANY
PROVIDERS WHO WORK- SUBMITTING
BILLS OR CLAIMS. FOR PRIOR TO
KOBE AND HOW MANY- POST CODE.
AND SO- JUST YOUR- WITH YOU
WHAT WERE WERE SEEN AND IN
THOSE NUMBERS- WE HAVE. IT NET.
SO A NET DECREASE OF TWO
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT VENDORS
THAT ARE NOT CLAIMING- THAT AS
COMPARED TO BEFORE- MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY. SO OF THAT WE
HAD. ONE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY FOUR VENDORS THAT- WERE
NOT. HAVE NOT CLAIMED
CURRENTLY- SO THAT WOULD.
INDICATE IS THAT LOSING THOSE
PROVIDERS AND- IT RAISING THAT
QUESTION- HOWEVER WHEN WE LOOK
AT THOSE THAT ARE NOT CLAIMING
LIKE I SAID. ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
CONCERNS IS OUT OF HOME RESPITE
THE OTHER ONE IS ON THIS ONE IS
ACTUALLY TRANSPORTATION- WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH OUR
TRANSPORTATION PROVIDERS ON HOW
DO WE ESTABLISH. KIND OF THOSE
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES IT'S BEEN-
ONE OF THE ONES THAT HAVE BEEN
THE TRICKIEST AND ESTABLISHING
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES RATE. AN
EXAMPLE MENTAL STAFFING SO IN
IN- AT SITES WHETHER IT'S DAY
PROGRAM OTHER SITES THE
SUPPLEMENTAL STAFFING THESE ARE
THE THREE MAIN CATEGORIES AND
WHAT'S WE ARE SEEN. THOSE ONE
THOUSAND SO ROUNDING UP FIFTEEN
HUNDRED- PROVIDERS NOT CLAIMING
WHAT THEY GET. ON THE FLIP SIDE-
ACT KOBE WE HAVE AN-
ESSENTIALLY TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
PROVIDERS- AND THAT'S NOT SO
MUCH PROVIDERS BUT-
VECTORIZATION. SO IT MAY BE
USED BY EXISTING VENDORS ON SO
WE HAVE THOSE THAT ARE
ADDITIONAL CLAIMS NOW WE'RE
SEEING SIMILAR THEN. WE'RE
SUPPORT INTO RESIDENTIAL
SETTINGS THAT'S BEEN AN
INCREASE SO WE'RE SEEN EXISTING
PROVIDERS LIKE ADDING ON
SERVICE CODES- BUT TO GET TO
THE QUESTION AS FAR AS LIKE
THAT THE OVERALL KIND OF
NETWORK- WE DON'T HAVE THAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL- WE TOOK EARLY
ACTION- CERTAINLY THE RETENTION
PAYMENT WAS SUPPORTIVE AND
HELPFUL TO PROVIDERS- BUT WE
ALSO KNEW THAT THAT WAS GOING
TO BE TIME LIMITED WE- RENEW
THAT- NOT ONLY WAS IT NOT
SOMETHING THAT WAS SUSTAINABLE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE. GETTING VISIBILITY AND TO
HELP PROVIDERS WERE PROVIDING
SERVICES TO CONSUMERS. I'M SO
WE REALLY NEED TO TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT IS OUR ALTERNATIVE
APPROACH BECAUSE WE WERE ALSO
NOT GOING TO BE GETTING FEDERAL
DOLLARS. SO WE QUICKLY LOOKED
AT AND WORK WITH PROVIDERS AND
WE GOT INPUT FROM AN ID NUMBER
OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS TO SAY OKAY
WE GET AS AS MRS GOMEZ HAD
NOTED. WE HAD FAMILIES THAT
NEEDED FOOD SO WE NEED TO THINK
REALLY DIFFERENTLY AND SAY OKAY
NOW IS ABOUT THE TIME OF BEING
ALTERNATIVE. NO MEETING PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE SO EVERYTHING
FROM THAT TO SOME EXTREMELY
CREATIVE YOUNG MUSICAL TALENTS
THAT STARTED DOING SOME PRETTY
CREATIVE THINGS AND I. I THINK
THAT THAT THERE'S SOME GOOD
THINGS HAVE COME OUT OF- SOME
OF THE BEST STRUGGLES THAT WE
FACE IN THESE CHALLENGES THAT
HOPEFULLY IS MEETING SOME OF
THE NEEDS AND WE'RE GOING TO
HELP US KIND OF GET BACK TO-
MAYBE DIFFERENTLY BUT- FOCUS
YOU KNOW. ON A NEW NORMAL. SO
IF YOU MISSED ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS PLEASE LET ME KNOW NO
YOU DID UNITS INCLUDE HELLO
VERY WELL I JUST HAVE TO GATHER
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
ADAPTING IN BEING FLEXIBLE LOT
OF. YOUR ROCKER SEES DON'T DO
THAT AND I THINK THAT THROUGH
THAT PROCESS A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN HARMED.
WORF'S HELPED SUBSTANTIALLY AND
I REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEE
NON- BRING IT HERE TO THE
CHAIR- I WILL HAVE A HANDFUL OF
QUESTIONS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
START DIRECTOR PARCHMENT BY A
KNOWLEDGE SHARING AND
APPRECIATING THE ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT CAME OUT LAST FRIDAY. I
WOULD LIKE TO AGREE WITH-
MISTER CARRUTHERS THAT IT WAS
INNOVATIVE AND FORWARD THINKING
AND NOW IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
IT'S IMPLEMENTED WELL. I WANTED
TO GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY IF I
COULD TO- EXPLAIN THE RATIONALE
FOR THE MARCH FIFTEENTH DATE TO
EMPLOYMENT THE ANNOUNCEMENT.
ABOUT THE PRIORITIZATION FOR
IDT AND CAN THE STATE BE MOVED
UP OR THE APPROACH XCELERATED
AND IF NOT WHY NOT. YEAH THANK
YOU DR RAM ELEVEN- SO AS FAR AS
VISIBILITY INTO THE ULTIMATE
DECISION UP ON MARCH FIFTEENTH.
I AS DIRECTOR CROWTHER'S HAD
NOTED THAT THERE'S REALLY
REASONS WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
A THE READINESS OF- THE AMOUNT
OF VACCINES THAT ARE AVAILABLE-
NEEDING TO GET THROUGH- THE
PRIORITY THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
ESTABLISHED IN TIER ONE A. AND
ONE B. IS REALLY IMPORTANT- AND-
YOU DON'T EMPHASIZING THOSE
NEXT STEPS ARE ARE REALLY
CRITICAL. SO THAT GIVES US THE
TIME AND SPACE TO DO THAT THERE
MAY HAVE BEEN OTHER AREAS THAT
HAVE INFLUENCED THE DECISION
FOR THE MARCH FIFTEENTH DATE-
CERTAINLY THE GUIDELINES WORK
GROUP HAD. A LOT OF FACTORS
THAT THEY WERE LOOKING NOT NOT
ONLY WITHIN THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY- FIELD BUT ALSO JUST
THE BROADER CONTEXT AT THOSE AT
RISK INDIVIDUALS- SO YOU KNOW
WE CAN CERTAINLY GET SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION BACK TO
YOU- REGARDING THAT- AS FAR AS-
BEING- YOU KNOW GETTING THAT
SOONER- IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT IS. IS NOT AN OPTION
THE DECISIONS HAVE BEEN MADE
HOWEVER I CAN CERTAINLY TAKE
BACK- THE QUESTION- FOR FURTHER
ELABORATION SHOULD THAT BE
NEEDED. RIGHT NOW WE REALLY
NEED TO FOCUS ON THE HOUSE. HOW
ARE WE GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
POTENTIALLY STRUGGLING TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO A VACCINATION
SITE. I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS WITHIN
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM THAT
ARE SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER YEAH
WE REALLY AREN'T MAKING SURE
THAT THEY ARE GETTING ACCESS TO
VACCINATIONS. THAT WERE NOT
LEAVING THEM BEHIND IT GIVES US
THAT TIME TO ALSO DO THAT. AND
THEN LIKE I SAID IDENTIFY THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE GOING TO
NEED FURTHER ASSISTANCE WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO HAVE THE TIME TO
WORK WITH THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR- ON ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE SOME SYSTEMIC
AND STRUCTURE TO- THE ROLL OUT
IN THIS NEXT PHASE. IT DOES
GIVE US- TIME TO WORK IN
COLLABORATION I WILL SAY ONE OF
THE WORK GROUPS THE- WORKGROUP
THAT DIRECTOR CROWTHER'S HAD.
PARTICIPATED IN IN THE ADVISORY
GROUP AND THE OTHER FOR
ADVOCATES- REALLY HAD
IMPORTANT. IMPORTANT THEY CAN
SEE THAT- HELP INFORM THE
GUIDELINES WORK GROUP BUT ALSO
STEM FROM THAT HAS COME A-
IMPLEMENTATION WORK GROUP-
WHICH- ALL THOSE SAME PARTNERS
ARE INVOLVED IN AND THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
REALLY GET TOO GRANULAR DETAIL
TO YOU. HOW DO WE GO QUESTION
THAT CAME UP AS THE LETTER HOW
ARE WE GOING TO YOU KNOW HAVE
AN EVIDENCE OF VERIFICATION-
AND SO THOSE ARE THE DECISIONS
THAT WE NEED TO- MAKE QUICKLY
AND SWIFTLY SO WE CAN I'M NOT
HAVE OUR FAMILY. STRUGGLE TO
GETTING THAT ACCESS. MISTER
SERVING DURING. COMMENTS STATE
THAT BELIEVES THAT DATA IS
CURRENTLY UNDER REPORTED. HE
SAID THAT THE PANDEMIC
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR US TO
HAVE BETA BETTER DATA SYSTEMS.
AND I'D LIKE TO. FOLLOW UP IF I
COULD ASK THE ADMINISTRATION.
TO ADOPT A DATA DASHBOARD ON
VACCINE ACCESS FOR THE I. D. D.
COMMUNITY. SO THAT WE CAN SHOW
HOW MUCH PROGRESS IS BEING MADE
TO VACCINATE THOSE WHO ARE
SERVED BY THE LANTERN ACT. AND
WANTED TO GET YOUR RESPONSE.
YEAH WE'VE BEEN VERY COMMITTED
TO TRANSPARENCY IN OUR DATA-
AND WHEN WE EARLY ON WE MADE A
STRONG COMMITMENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE POSTING ON OUR
WEBSITE. FOR ALL TO SEE THAT
KOBE AND- DATA AS FAR AS THE
NUMBER OF POSITIVES AND STANLEY
AGAIN THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PASSED. BASED ON WHAT RESIDENTS
HI BASED ON ETHNICITY BASED ON
AGE I'M AND I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE EQUALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ALSO
DEMONSTRATING THAT- THE
INFORMATION FOR THOSE WHO ARE
RECEIVING THE VACCINE IS GOING
TO BE HELPFUL FOR US ALSO TO BE
INFORMED WHERE DO WE NEED TO
FOCUS. EFFORT IF WE'RE SEEN AND
ANY PARTICULAR POPULATION OR-
AT RISK GROUP- THAT IS.
CERTAINLY THOSE THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
WE'RE RESPONSIE TO IT- WE DO
HAVE OUR SYSTEM WHAT THEN.
WHAT'S CALLED STAND AS THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND A REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE ALREADY STARTED
POPULATING THAT INFORMATION- SO
WE'RE WE'RE ALREADY GETTING ON
ON DATA FROM THE REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT TELLS US. WHO IS
ON RECEIVING A VACCINE BUT WE
ALSO WENT FURTHER WITH THAT- WE
ALSO WERE ASKING WHO'S HAVING A
NEGATIVE REACTION IF THERE'S
ANYBODY WHO'S HAVING NEGATIVE
REACTION. BUT WE'RE ALSO
WANTING TO TRACK THOSE ON THAT
ARE NOT GETTING IT IF IT'S BY
CHOICE OR FAILURE TO ACCESS IT.
SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO HELP INFORM
US AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE- KIND OF THAT
TRANSPARENCY ON ON OUR WEBSITE-
SO FOLKS CAN. ALSO TRACK IT AS
WELL. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
BRIDGEMAN- WANTED TO NEXT MOVE
TO THE FLEXIBILITIES- CURRENTLY
THERE ON A MONTH TO MONTH
EXTENSION. AND WANTED TO SEE IF
WE CAN GIVE SOME CLARITY LONG
TERM BY EXTENDING THEM THROUGH
THE END OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY- AND IF YOU THOUGHT
THAT WOULD BE A REASONABLE.
SOLUTION FOR US. THANK AGAIN
FOR THAT THE QUESTION AND-
THAT. IF I HAD NOTED WE HAD
ABOUT FORTY DIFFERENCE GUIDANCE
AND DIRECTIVES- WE REVIEW THOSE
ON. A MONTHLY BASIS- I I'M
REALLY OPEN TO HAVING A
CONVERSATION- WITH THIS
COMMITTEE TO IDENTIFY. YOU KNOW
THOSE- ONES THAT WE'VE ALREADY.
TAKEN THOSE STEPS FORWARD TO
EXTEND- THAT ARE WITHIN THOSE
THIRTY DAYS. FOR EXAMPLE TAKING
A LOOK AT THE PARTICIPANT
DIRECTED THAT WE'RE PUTTING OUT
ON- THROUGH REGULATIONS- BUT
ALSO EVALUATE. EVALUATING THE
REMOTE ACCESS BUT IF THERE'S
FURTHER- CONVERSATIONS MAY BE
MORE THANHAPPY TO PARTICIPATE
AND PROVIDE. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OR INFORMATION AND
DATA THAT COULD HELP INFORM-THAT DISCUSSION. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR AND YOU KNOW. I MUST
SAY I WAS MOVED BY MISS GOMEZ
AND HEARD TESTIMONY REGARDING
DISPARITIES AND- SINCE I
STARTED BY FRAMING MY COMMENTS
IN SPANISH TODAY I. ACTUALLY
I'M REALLY TRYING TO DIG INTO
THIS ISSUE A BIT MORE DIRECTOR
IF I CAN. THE DISPARITIES IN
THE SYSTEM AS ARE ILLUSTRATED-
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION ON PAGE
TWENTY FIVE OF THIS. AGENDA
WHICH LOOKS AT THE- DIFFERENCES
IN RESOURCE- THE POS FOR
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IS. PRETTY SHOCKING ACTUALLY
THERE ARE QUITE WIDE AND
DISTURBING FOR MANY OF US WHO
SAID ON THE STYLUS. WHAT IS IT
THAT WE CAN DO IN THE NAR TERM
TO HELP TO DISRUPT THESE
DISPARITIES IN A MEANINGFUL WAY.
THANK YOU AND- LIKE YOU I AM
ALWAYS MOVES FINEST GOMEZ AND-
HAVE ALWAYS VALUED HER CANDOR
BUT HER PARTNERSHIP. YOU KNOW
SHE IS- BEEN A RESOURCE TO ME-
I'VE I'VE BEEN ABLE TO MEET
WITH WITH HER AND MANY OF HER-
MOMS AND WELL AS BEING ABLE TO
EXTEND TO FATHERS- AND
SIBLINGS- WE HAVE FOCUSED OUR
WORK- OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS ON A DRESSING SERVICE
ACCESS AND- EQUITY OR IN EQUITY
AND IN ACCESSING SERVICES. AND
WHILE WE'VE MADE SOME STRIDES-
WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO AND I'M
TO THE POINT THAT YOU JUST
SHARED IS TO ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO TO
DISRUPT AND- I'M PAYING
ATTENTION TO IT- CERTAINLY ARE
PROPOSAL FOR THE COMMUNITY A
NAVIGATOR IS ONE OF THE ONES
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE USING. SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS SHARED-
WITH THE DEVELOPMENT OF
PROPOSALS AND PROJECTS THROUGH
THE- FUNDS THAT- WE HAVE ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS OF ELEVEN MILLION
SO OUR PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS TO ASK FOR
OUTSIDE OF THOSE FUNDS- TO BE
ABLE TO ESTABLISH THROUGHOUT
THE STATE A COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR
REALLY GET- THAT RESOURCE FROM
A TRUSTED- PARTY THAT CAN. HELP
FAMILIES NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM
WHETHER IT'S WITHIN THE
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE ALSO
ACCESSING OTHER SERVICES- WE
ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT THOSE
SERVICES THAT- ARE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IMPACTED
DISPROPORTIONATELY OF NOT BEING
ABLE TO ACCESS. SUCH AS
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT- THERE'S BEEN THAT
MANY LESSONS LEARNED DURING THE
PANDEMIC- ONE OF THE VERY
VALUABLE LESSONS THAT- I EIGHT
I PERSONALLY LEARNED- IT WAS
ALSO THROUGH SOME OF THE WORK
THAT I'M THIS IS GOMEZ AND
OTHER- COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT
HAVE SHARED ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTY OF ACCESSING
SERVICES VERTICALLY PARTICIPANT
DIRECTED. WHAT WE DID WAS WE
WENT AHEAD AND WE DID A
STATEWIDE TRAINING FOR
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED SERVICES
CHIU SERVICE COORDINATORS AT
THE REGIONAL CENTER SO EVERY
REGIONAL CENTER PARTICIPATED.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
MESSAGING AS TO WHAT ARE
PURCHASE A DIRECT SERVICES. AND
THEN ALSO. FOR THE FIRST TIME I
CERTAINLY IN IN THE TEN YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN AT THE
DEPARTMENT. IS THAT WE HAD A
STATEWIDE TRAINING FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS. AND ALSO ON-
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED SO TO IT
SO WHAT MRS GOMEZ WAS SAYING IS
THAT THE INCONSISTENCIES
BETWEEN REGIONAL CENTERS. YOU
KNOW I NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHY
IS SOME OF THAT PART OF THAT IS
POLICY BUT PART OF IT IS REALLY
COMES ALSO FROM WHAT
INFORMATION ARE WE- SHARING OUT
TO THE COMMUNITY THAT IS
CONSISTENT BETWEEN. TO THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AS WELL AS TO
FAMILY MEMBERS- SO THAT IS IN
ANOTHER AREA IS TO CAN YOU
CONTINUE TO DO STATEWIDE
TRAINING THAT IS ACCESSIBLE TO-
REGIONAL CENTERS TO FAMILY
MEMBERS AND TO- SO ADVOCATES-
WE ALSO FOR THE FIRST TIME DID
A TRAINING ON THIS. I'M ALL IN
SPANISH- BECAUSE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE IT WAS A REQUEST FROM
OUR COMMUNITY AND IT'S ONE OF
THOSE IT'S LIKE HE SHOULD BE
EASY THINGS THAT WE CAN DO.
ACCESS. TO INFORMATION IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. THE DIRECTOR
BARGE MAN I THINK YOU WANT ON
MUTE. ALSO YOU CAN HELLO
THROWING UP THINGS I JUST WE
LOST ABOUT FIFTEEN SECONDS OF
IT I'M SORRY SO I JUST IN A
STATEMENT I THINK IF IT ENDS
MAYBE. REALLY IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT FOR US TO CONTINUE
THOSE STATEWIDE EFFORTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE CONSISTENT ON
MESSAGING TO OUR COMMUNITY- SO
FAMILIES AND SELF ADVOCATES
HERE WHAT IS AVAILABLE
CONSISTENTLY- ACROSS THE STATE
SO ALSO THAT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU HEARD THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
DO A SPANISH SPEAKING TRAINING.
THAT WAS IN SPANISH AS OPPOSED
TO- HAVING EIGHT
INTERPRETATION- AND- FROM
ENGLISH TO SPANISH- SO THESE
ARE AREAS THAT WE NEED TO WORK
ON THIS IS A PRIORITY OF MINE
HAS BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE- TO EXPLORE YOUR SHORT AND
LONG TERM- STRATEGIES TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE INTERRUPTION. YES
NO EXCUSE AND I'M NOT
SUGGESTING FOR A SECOND BUT THE
DATA IS NOT ACCURATE BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO REPORT BASED ON-
SPECIFIC SERVICES- BECAUSE THE
AGGREGATE DATA- WE DO HAVE-
VARIABLES THAT IMPACT THAT
DATA- YOU KNOW AND AGAIN IT'S
NOT MINIMIZING THE PROBLEM.
THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
ISSUE AND WE HAVE TO ADDRESS IT
BUT BASED ON THAT DATA AND THAT
DOES INCLUDE OUR RESIDENTIAL
SETTINGS- WHICH HAS- A- LARGE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
WHITE AS COMPARED TO OUR OTHER
COMMUNITIES- BUT WE DO NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW DO WE
SUPPORT. ALL COMMUNITIES- IN
THE SAME WAY TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS SERVICES IN THE WAITED
EIGHT YEARS IF IT'S AT HOME OR
OUT OF ALL. THANK YOU DIRECTOR-
I WAS HOPING THAT YOU COULD
COMMENT ON THE ROLE THAT
REGIONAL CENTER LIAISONSPLAY
IN HELPING TO REDUCE
DISPARITIES. AND HOW CAN WE
FORMALIZE THIS NEEDED ROLE SO
THAT- WE CAN. ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE THE SYSTEM MIGHT BENEFITS.
THANK YOU I AM ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT I AM PARTICULARLY. PROUD
OF- YES AND I KNOW IT CAME WITH
SOME QUESTIONS FROM- SOME FOLKS
IS TO THE INCREASE OF THE STAFF
THAT WE PUT FORWARD- I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T REMEMBER
EXACTLY WHAT BUDGET YEAR BUT WE
IMPLEMENTED A REORGANIZATION
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT. NOW WE
ADDED JUST OVER FIFTY POSITIONS
MAJORITY OF THEM REALLY WERE IN
THE LATEST ON WORK IS YOU KNOW
IT- SO PRIOR TO THE
REORGANIZATION WE HAD FOUR
LANES ON THAT WERE ACROSS THE
STATE- TODAY NOW WHAT WE HAVE
ARE WE HAVE SEVEN TEAMS THAT
WORK WITH ALL TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL CENTERS THE TEAMS HAVE
ALEJO'S ON AND THEN THEY HAVE
TO SUPPORT. STAFF TO BE ABLE TO
HELP PROVIDE THE INFORMATION OR
RESPONSE TIMELY TO FAMILIES AND
TO REGIONAL CENTRES- RIGHT NOW
WHAT HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL IS
JUST A RESPONSE TO COMPLAINTS.
BUT ALSO JUST LISTENING AND
TALKING TO THE REGIONAL CENTERS
ABOUT WHAT ARE THEIR STRATEGIES
TO ADDRESS ON SOME OF THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES- AS WELL AS
MAKING SURE THAT- OUR STAFF
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ATTEND. EVERY
SINGLE REGIONAL CENTER- BOARD
MEETING COMMUNITY MEETING
WHETHER IT'S ON DISPARITIES
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT- STARTING
TO ATTEND- SOME OF THE LOCAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEES ON SELF
DETERMINATION SO THE PRESENCE
THAT OUR STAFF TO BEING ABLE TO
HAVE. HAS BEEN VERY VALUABLE TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE
CONNECTIONS WE'VE ALSO RECENTLY
HAD A GROUP OF LATINO MOMS THEY
HAD SOME VERY SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT ACCESSING
SERVICES WITH A COUPLE OF
REGIONAL CENTERS. SO OUR LAND
SONS AND THE STAFF THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BUILD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO MEET WITH THEM ALSO
MEET WITH THEIR REGIONAL ENTER
SO WE'RE ABLE TO TIME WE
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES. WHERE WE
DID NOT HAVE THOSE RESOURCES I
WILL ALSO SAY THAT THERE'S NO
WAY WE COULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORTS IN THE
POSSIBILITIES AND THEIR
REACTION AND ACTION ITEMS THAT
WE HAD IN THIS PANDEMIC. YOU
KNOW HOW WE CAN AND NOT BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE THOSE RESOURCES.
TO DO THAT OUR REACH. SO I AS
FAR AS HOW TO. IT I HAVE TO.
KIND OF. ENGAGE IN MORE CALM.
WITH YOU TO UNDERSTAND KIND OF
WERE THE THOUGHT IS- WE'RE
STILL AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE IDENTIFYING THAT THE
BENEFITS OF IT AND ALSO THE
AREAS IN WHICH WE CAN
IMPROVEMENTS AND UTILIZING
THOSE RESOURCES. I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP OFFLINE WITH
THOSE- DID WANT TO ASK ABOUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
DISPARITIES FUNDING- ARE THERE
ANY LESSONS LEARNED THAT WE
HAVE. AGAIN HOW DO WE HELP TO
APPLY THOSE STATE WIDE. AND CAN
THE PENDING EVALUATION BE
SPECIFICALLY USED TO HIGHLIGHT
THOSE BEST PRACTICES THAT CAN
BE EXTENDED ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
YES THANK YOU- SO THE THERE'S
BEEN SOME BEST PRACTICES THAT
HAVE REALLY BEEN IDENTIFIED ONE
IS THAT COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR
AND- FROM A TORAH MODELS IN
USING THOSE TRUSTED
ORGANIZATIONS WHEN WE FIRST AT
THE ELEVEN MILLION AND HAD THE
RESOURCES IT WENT ONLY TO
REGIONAL CENTRES- AND I WILL
GIVE A SHOUT OUT AGAIN TO MRS
GOMEZ BECAUSE THROUGH THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD WITH
THEM. WE HAD REAL HONEST
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HEY YOU
KNOW HERE'S ALL THE FUNDING
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS
SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY. BUT
YOU'RE HAVING THE RESULTS
CENTERS DO THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
ABOUT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHAT ABOUT-
FAMILIES OR- GROUPS THAT WANT
TO DO SOME GRASSROOTS WORK. SO
WE HAD SOME GROWING PAINS EARLY
ON. AND BUT QUICKLY THE SECOND
YEAR WE WENT STRAIGHT INTO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
YOU KNOW HELP TREAT REALLY
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN USE THOSE
TRUSTED NETWORKS TO BE ABLE TO
DO THOSE OUT THAT OUTREACH- WE
HAVE A JUST A AREAS THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO FOCUS ON- WE
DO NEED TO FOCUS. ON IT JUST
NAY ON BUILDING THE LEADERSHIP
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IN THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
SYSTEM. YOU KNOW REACHING OUT
TO THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND REACHING OUT TO
THE LATINO COMMUNITY YOU KNOW
AND HELPING THEM KIND OF BUILD
THEIR- POSITION OF LEADERSHIP.
AND SO THEY HAVE- IN REALLY A
VOICE AT THE TABLE. REMOTE
MEETINGS HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE-
YEAH. YOU KNOW AS MUCH AS I
IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT RIGHT NOW
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO CONNECT WITH
MORE FAMILIES IN KINDA HERE AND
ALSO HERE THE BENEFITS THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGH THE ELEVEN MILLION.
ALSO DID REMARKABLE OUT OF
REACH- MAKING SURE FAMILIES ARE
GETTING PP AND THEY WERE ABLE
TO GET FOOD THAT THEY WERE ABLE
TO GET INFORMATION. AND SO
THAT'LL HAVE BEEN MILLION HAD
BUILT A NETWORK OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. YEAH HIS WAS SO
CRITICAL YOU'RE RESPONDING AND
DOING OUTREACH TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED-
MICROBIT- SO WE ARE WE ARE
CONTINUING TO EVALUATE AND YES
ON THAT QUESTION REGARDING THE
VALUATION WE CAN DEFINITELY.
YOU KNOW TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
ARE THE LESSONS- LEARN WHAT ARE
THE STRENGTHS OF THE PROGRAM
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WOULD BE
RECOMMENDED- WE DO WANT AN
INDEPENDENT- EVALUATION AND
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO DO TO
HELP US- GET TO- THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR. A TASK FORCE I'M
MORE GROUP ONE SERVICE. ACCESS
AND EQUITY TO GIVE US I'M SORRY
COMMENDATIONS RISK OF WORK ON.
HELP US SEE- WE SHOULD FOCUS. I
ARE HIGHLIGHTED ONE OF MISS
GOMEZ'S COMMENTS WHERE SHE'S
THAT- WORK BUT ONLY IF
IMPLEMENTED. I WANTED TO FOLLOW
UP THEN WITH WHAT SHE HAD SAID
THAT SOME REGIONAL CENTER STATE
THAT THE DIRECTIVES ARE
SUGGESTIONS. ARE THEY
SUGGESTIONS ARE ARE THE
DIRECTIVES. YEAH THEIR
DIRECTIVES AND ANYTIME THERE'S-
QUESTIONS OR INCONSISTENCIES
AND REALLY WHAT LED TO OUR
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED TRAINING
WAS WHAT WE WERE HEARING ABOUT
INCONSISTENCIES ARE
IMPLEMENTATION- AND SO THAT'S
WHY WE WENT AHEAD AND SAID HEY
WE JUST NEED TO TAKE SOME
ACTION RIGHT NOW AND DO IT
OVERALL I'M STATEWIDE TRAINING-
SO WE- WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
HEAR THOSE CONCERNS YOU KNOW
AND- WHILE EACH REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE THEIR OWN
POLICIES- THAT ARE DERIVED
BASED ON REGULATIONS AND
STATUTES- THERE IS TIMES WHEN
THERE'S DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATIONS- SYSTEMS NOT
ALWAYS PERFECT IN BEING ABLE TO
NAVIGATE THAT. BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HEAR THOSE
CONCERNS AND IF WE CAN PROVIDE
SOME- SUPPORT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT AND THAT'S THAT'S
HELPFUL TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
INPUT SUCH AS THAT AND SHARING.
THOSE CONCERNS. ON PAGE
FOURTEEN THERE IS THE-
DIRECTIVE LOOKING AT FOCUSED
CONVERSATIONS BY THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND- WANTED TO. ASK
WHAT IS OUR ACCOUNTABILITY TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE MOST
IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS. WHAT'S
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY LOOK LIKE.
SO YOU'RE RIGHT I BELIEVE
YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE PLANS
THAT WERE ASKING A REGIONAL
CENTERS TO HAVE FUN IS THAT
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT. YES SO
WE WERE EACH OF THAT THE
LIAISONS WILL WORK WITH THEIR
pTO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
GETTING THOSE PLANS- AND MAKING
SURE THAT THEIR MEANINGFUL
PLANS- WE WORK WITH ARCA- AND-
PART OF THE BENEFIT OF HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTERS ON A FREQUENT BASIS WE-
WE SIMPLY ME- ONCE A WEEK IF
NOT ONCE A WEEK- WITH MY
EXECUTIVE TEAM AND THE REGIONAL
CENTER DIRECTORS. TO TALK ABOUT
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES ON THE
REGIONAL CENTER DIRECTORS HAVE
ALL SAID YES YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE
THESE ARE IMPORTANT YOU KNOW
IT'S SOMETIMES IT'S CERTAINLY A
BURDEN SOMETIMES TO BE ABLE TO
SAY LET'S PUT THIS IN WRITING-
BUT THEY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT THEY
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF-
BEING ABLE TO HAVE A
TRANSPARENT TO THE COMMUNITY SO
WE'LL WORK WITH- OUR LIAISONS
AND THE REGIONAL CENTERS ON TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THOSE
PLANS AND TRACK THOSE. ON BUT
LIKE I SAID WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO UPDATE WHAT OUR EXPECTATION.
IS BASED ON THE ANNOUNCEMENT ON
FRIDAY- WITH THAT I- CLOSE THE
SECTION BUT BEFORE WE MOVE
FORWARD I WOULD LIKE TO
REITERATE. THE REQUEST THAT ARE
DISCUSSED ON THE AGENDA AND ASK
FOR THE FOLLOWING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. ONE HAD LIKE
FOR THAT PUBLIC FACING DATA
DASHBOARD ON BAXEEN ACCESS IN
THE DDS SERVED POPULATION. TO
I'D LIKE A PROPOSED SET OF
DIRECTIVES THAT ARE APPROPRIATE
TO EXTEND AND CODIFY. FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION BY APRIL FIFTH
OF THIS YEAR. AND THREE IT'S A
SUMMARY OF THOSE REGIONAL
CENTER PLANS BY A DATE THAT'S
DECIDED MUTUALLY BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF. BUT WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO THANK VERY
MUCH- THE FIRST PANEL AND- WE
WILL BE NOW MOVING ON TO PANEL
TO. ON ADEQUACY AND
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES PROVIDER
NETWORK. AGAIN FOR OUR
PANELISTS PLEASE PRESENT IN THE
ORDER THAT YOUR NAME APPEARS IN
THE AGENDA AND PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS AND INFORMATION. TO
WHAT IS REQUESTED IN THE AGENDA
WE ALSO HAVE EIGHT PANELISTS
FOR ISSUE TWO WE WILL HOLD ALL
MEMBERS QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER
THE PRESENTERS HAVE CONCLUDED.
PLEASE BEGIN. WE WILL START
WITH DIRECTOR PART. THANK YOU-
DR ARAMBULA AND I AM QUICKLY
GOING THROUGH RIGHT. YOUR I
FOUND MY PLACE APOLOGIZE FOR
THE DELAY- I HAD- FOR THE FIRST
QUESTION THAT WAS LISTED FOR ME
TO PROVIDE- RESPONSES CHU TO
THIS COMMITTEE. I'VE HAD TO DO
WITH THE PROVIDER NETWORK
INSTALLED GO AHEAD AND JUST
SUMMARIZE THAT AGAIN AND- I
ADDRESS MOST OF THAT- WITH THAT
QUESTION THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER HAD PUT FORWARD- BUT
JUST TO REITERATE AND WE HAD-
BASED ON OUR CLAIMS DATA AND
AGAIN. THAT'S THE MECHANISM FOR
BILLING AND- IT DOESN'T SHOW
THE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS BUT IT
DOES SHOW KIND OF THOSE- NUMBER
OF. KIND OF VENDORS THAT ARE OR
BILLING WITHIN THE DIFFERENT-
SERVICES- WE HAD ABOUT TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND PROVIDERS FOR THE
PERIOD BETWEEN JULY TWENTY
NINETEEN TWO FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY SO THAT WAS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. AND THEN- JUST SHY OF.
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND SO. AGAIN
OF BOB OUT HUNDRED PROVIDE LAST
FOR THE PERIOD OF JULY. TWO
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY I'M I
WISH THAT WE HAD- FURTHER
DETAIL REGARDING THE EMPLOYEES
WE DON'T HAVE THAT- THAT IS-
LIMITATIONS TO THE INFORMATION
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO US I'M AND
I SAID AS I HAD NOTED THAT WE
HAD- ONE THOUSAND FOREIGN FIFTY
FOUR VENDORS LAST- THAT HAD
BILLED AFTER THE PANDEMIC- AND
JUST TO REITERATE THAT THAT
WAS- PRIMARILY OUR OUT OF HOME
RESPITE PROVIDERS
TRANSPORTATION- PROVIDERS AND
SUPPLEMENTAL STAFFING BUT WE
DID SEE- KINDA. INCREASE THIS
INCREASE OF PROVIDERS AND-
CLEANING AND THAT THE CURRENT
YEAR PRIMARILY BECAUSE WE
STARTED SEEING ADDITIONAL
SUPPLEMENTAL STAFFING- I'M I
WAS ALSO ASKED TO TALK TO
SPECIFIC DYNAMICS WITHIN THE
SETTING TYPES THAT- I WANT
WOULD WANT TO POINT OUT AND I
DID THAT EARLIER YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY CONCERNED ABOUT- OUR
OUT OF HOME RESPITE PROVIDERS-
BUT WE'RE ALSO WANTING TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION WITH
TRANSPORTATION PROVIDERS INTO.
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
FITTING WITHIN THE ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES- I WILL ALSO NOTE
THAT- OUR SUPPORTED LIVING
PROVIDERS AND WHILE THIS MAY
NOT BE SPECIFIC QUESTION- BUT
THEY HAD TAKEN ON A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES AND YOU KNOW ALL OF
OUR PROVIDERS- HAD JUST DONE A
REMARKABLE JOB IN PROVIDING
SUPPORTS TO INDIVIDUALS AND
SOME VERY VERY CHALLENGING
SITUATIONS. AND GETTING VERY
CREATIVE I'M PARTICULARLY PROUD
OF THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TEAM- OR-
PROVIDERS THAT WE HAD DESIGNED
TO HELP- PROVIDERS IN
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES TO THINK
ABOUT HOW TO GET CREATED AND
PROVIDE CONTENT THIS VISION
THAT YOU CAN THINK OUTSIDE OF
THE BOX- SO APPRECIATE EASTER
SEALS AND CDSA AND- I KNOW THE
ARC IS A PART OF THAT TEAM AND
THE WORK. THAT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING IN DOING THAT THE LEFT ON
HEALTH PEOPLE OUTSIDE THE BOX I
THINK IT'S ALL VERY. SO FOR
THOSE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
STRUGGLE AT THIS THAT THIS
WOULD BE A RESOURCE I'M SO
HAPPY THAT- YES SIR ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS I THINK
THOSE ARE THE TWO ITEMS THAT I
HAD. FOR MY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU DIRECTOR BIRDMAN NEXT WE
HAVE JIM KNIGHT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR ARAMBULA-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF I
AM JIM LIKE THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. SO I'M-GONNA START WITH EVEN AN UPDATE
ON WHERE WE ARE IN THE STATUS
OF MEDIAN DOWNHOLE THE FEDERAL
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES REQUIREMENTS. THE
THEY'RE KNOWN BY A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT NAMES AND SO OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS A STRANGE
REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE THEY- THEY
DO- SETS A NEW- RULES OR
REGULATIONS AROUND HOW SERVICES
ARE COORDINATED. AND IN
PARTICULAR WHAT PEOPLE'S
EXPERIENCES WHAT CHOICES THEY
HAVE AND THEN OR DO THOSE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT COMMUNITY
PARTICIPATION. SO I'M GONNA
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE KEY
POINTS THAT WERE OUTLINED IN
OUR TRANSITION PLAN WHICH WE
TALKED ABOUT BEFORE AND THAT IS
A REQUIREMENT OF THE SETTING
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL THAT WE
HAVE INITIAL APPROVAL OF THIS.
TRANSITION PLAN THROUGH THE
FEDERAL CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES ALTHOUGH
WE STILL HAVE SOME MORE TO GO
TO GET FINAL APPROVAL ON THAT.
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO DO IS REALLY DO AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHERE WE ARE AND
WHERE THOSE SETTINGS ARE
PROVIDERS ARE. IN MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS AND SO- OVER THE
SUMMER WE- COMPLETED THE FIRST
STEP OF THAT WHICH IS A
PROVIDER SELF ASSESSMENT. TO
WEAR OF THAT IS AS THE NAME
WOULD SUGGEST WHERE- PROVIDERS
GO THROUGH AN INJURY WITH WITH
THE DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS IN
THAT SET THE STAGE REQUIREMENTS
AND IDENTIFY. WHETHER THEY NEED
THOSE THOSE REQUIREMENTS AND IF
NOT. START TO IDENTIFY SOME
SOME THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE TO
IT TO ADDRESS AND CHANGE THAT.
NOW THIS SELF ASSESSMENT
PROCESS IS REALLY- MEARS AND-
ALTHOUGH A LITTLE MORE IN
DEPTH. THAN WHAT WE'VE DONE
OVER THE PREVIOUS FEW YEARS
WITH. HELP FROM FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET. DENTIST OF THAT THERE
BE SOME SUPPORT ACTORS. AND
THEN. MONEY NEEDED FOR
PROVIDERS TO MAKE SOME CHANGES
TO MEET THESE REQUIREMENTS- THE
INITIAL RESULTS OF THE SELF
ASSESSMENT SHOWED THAT 67% OF
THE PROVIDERS REPORTED THAT
THEY WERE MEETING ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS. AND OBVIOUSLY
THAT MEANS THAT 33% OF THE
STATE STILL NEEDED TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES THE RESULTS OF THESE
AND A SUMMARY OF THE RESULTS
ARE POSTED ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
WEBSITE. AND AS REQUIRED BY
STATE STATUTE WILL CONTINUE TO
UPDATE THAT PERIODICALLY WITH
THE NEXT UPDATE IS DUE- I
BELIEVE NEXT MONTH. IN MARCH.
SO THE NEXT STEP WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE THOSE INITIAL-
PROVIDER OF SELF ASSESSMENTS.
THAT WAS FOR ALL APPLICABLE
PROVIDERS THEN NEXT IN WHAT
WE'VE STARTED DOING IS AS
OUTLINED IN THE TRANSITION PLAN
IS AN ON SITE ASSESSMENT. SO
THAT'S WHERE A SAMPLE OF
PROVIDERS NATURALLY TO VALIDATE.
THE RESULT OF THOSE- PROVIDER
SELF ASSESSMENTS SO WE'VE
ENGAGED A CONTRACTOR TO HELP
ASSIST TO HELP THE JUSTICE THAN
THAT- ALWAYS FEEL WE CALLED ON
SITE ASSESSMENTS- IN OUR
TRANSITION PLAN WE'VE HAD TO
CHANGE THAT- WE STARTED IN
PILOTED- WITH. ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY PROVIDERS JOINED-
VIRTUAL OR REMOTE ASSESSMENT.
TO WALK THROUGH THE AND
IDENTIFY WHERE PROVIDERS ARE IT
AND THEN COMPARING THAT TO WHAT
THEIR SELF ASSESSMENTS SAID AS
WELL WE JUST COMPLETED THAT
INITIAL PILOT PHASE HERE JUST
pWEEKS. AND SO WE'RE WE'RE NOW
TRYING TO ASSESS WHAT THE
RESULTS OF THOSE ARE IN AND
WHAT CHANGES WERE MADE TO MAKE.
TO GO FORWARD AND- FOR THE REST
OF THE PROVIDERS THAT NEED TO
DO THAT SO ULTIMATELY WE'RE
LOOKING AT. THINKING THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED- OF THESE. ON SITE
SLASH VIRTUAL ASSESSED. AS
OUTLINE IN OUR TWO. PLAN SO IN
ADDITION TO THAT AS DOES
ASSESSMENT ACTIVITIES- ANOTHER
BIG COMPONENT WAS TRANSITION
PLAN AS ONGOING INFORMATION
SHARING RATHER BE THROUGH
TRAINING- AND THE LIKE FOR-
PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE SERVICES
THEIR FAMILIES PROVIDERS AND
REGIONAL CENTERS AS WELL AS A
WE'VE BEEN CONTINUING TO DO
THAT AND WILL CONTINUE THEIR-
UPCOMING ABOUT THE STRANGE
REQUIREMENTS- WITHIN REAL.
EXTRA EMPHASIS ON PERSON
CENTERED PLANNING AND PRACTICES
SINCE THIS REALLY THAT FORMS
THE BASIS OF THE OF THE
STANDINGS REQUIREMENTS. UNDER
THE HOME IF YOU MAY SERVICES.
SO IN SUMMARY EVEN THOUGH THERE
HAVE BEEN A COUPLE OF DELAYS
AND WE'VE HAD TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES WITH- DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. WE STILL ON TRACK TO
MEET THE FEDERALLY REQUIRED-
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
DEADLINE FOR GETTING A FINAL
APPROVAL OF THE TRANSITION PLAN
THAT TALKED ABOUT EARLIER. AND
JUST TO AT A HIGH LEVEL THE
REQUIREMENTS TO GET FINAL
APPROVAL OF THAT TRANSITION
PLAN. OR FOR A STATE SOME OF
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE INCLUDED
IN THAT AS IS AN ESTIMATE. OF
THE NUMBER OF SETTINGS
PROVIDERS. THAT ARE MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS. LIKEWISE IN THE-
NUMBER OF STANDING DURING
ESTIMATES. THAT ARE CURRENTLY
MEETING THOSE REQUIREMENTS AND
THEN WHAT STEPS WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE TO. TO MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS BOTH IN THE BALLOT
AND THEN ALSO WHAT OUR SYSTEM
IS FOR ONGOING OVERSIGHT. SO
NEXT ON A TOUCH ON OF WHERE WE
ARE WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM. AND
JUST FOR- TO START WITH
CURRENTLY IN WELL ACTUALLY AS
OF THE NINTH OF FEBRUARY WE
HAVE FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
TRANSITIONED AND YOUR- STUFF TO
TERMINATION. COMPARISON ONLY
TAKE ABOUT A YEAR AGO SO AT THE
BEGINNING OF TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY. THERE WERE JUST OVER A
HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO HAD MADE
THAT TRANSITION AND MOST OF
THOSE WERE- INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
BEEN PURCHASED BENSON THE
FORMER SELF DETERMINATION PILOT
PROJECT. SO IT'S BEEN. A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE- SENSE
THAT THEY'RE STILL OBVIOUSLY
WORK WORK SHOULD TWO ZERO AND
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT HERE AND
THE SECOND. SO AND I KNOW ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS WAS WHAT'S
BEEN THE IMPACT OF KOBE AND
WHILE IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFICULT TO SAY EXACTLY-
SPECIFICALLY WHAT'S- FOR SELF
DETERMINATION WHAT THAT. IMPACT
IS BANNED. YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
ADD SOME. REPORTS THAT IN FACT
BECAUSE OF THE FLEXIBILITY IS
THAT SELF DETERMINATION OFFERS
IT'S ACTUALLY ISN'T THAT
TRANSITION FOR SOME INDIVIDUALS
SIXTEEN THAT IS A WAY TO HELP
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CHANGING
NEEDS. THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
ON BY THE PANDEMIC. CONVERSELY
WE WE'VE HEARD ACTUALLY
SOMETIMES JUST THE OPPOSITE
BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING THAT'S
GOING ON WITH THE PANDEMIC. IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES THAT IS ACTUALLY
KINDA IT'S SLOWED THINGS DOWN A
BIT. SO IT IT'S DIDN'T STAND A
LITTLE BIT OF BOTH WELL LIKE I
SAID THERE HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT. YEAR OVER YEAR- WHAT
WE'RE SEEING NOW IN THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE HAVE TRANSITION. SO
MONEY SAID WELL THAT PACE HAS
INCREASED WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S IMPROVEMENTS ARE STILL
NEEDED IN MAY. AND LUCKILY WE
HAVE- THE HELP OF A LOT OF.
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS
AND ONE OF LIKE SAY IS THAT. IN
USE ME IN AUGUST. WE DID GET-
SOME OF THE VERY DETAILED LIST
OF RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
STATE WIDE SELF DETERMINATION
BEISER COMMITTEE. IN A NUMBER
OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR
IMPROVEMENT HAVE BEEN AND TO
LET. AND THEN WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THIS GROUP AND
OTHERS AS WE DEVELOP AN
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THAT'S-
REFERENCED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT'S GONNA HAVE
SPECIFIC STEPS AND STRATEGIES
TO ACHIEVE THE GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM. AND IN ADDITION TO
ASSIST WITH THAT. WE LOOK FOR
SOME EXPERTISE AND SOME OTHER
ASSISTANCE BOTH WITHIN THE
STATE AND NATIONALLY TO HELP
SUPPORT THAT. SO SOME OF THE
NATIONAL EXPERTS SO WE HAD WE
DONE THIS THROUGH AGREEMENT
WITH THE CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES- BEEN
ABLE TO ENLIST THE HELP OF AN
ORGANIZATION WE'RE- KNOWN AS
THE PLIGHTS OF DIRECTION THAT
HAS EXPERTISE AND- HELPING WITH
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AS WELL
AS- MY OWN. EXPERTS FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
DIRECTORS- SO WE'RE VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE OF THEIR
PARTNERSHIP AS WELL AS-
CATHERINE BLAKE MOORE WHOSE
BAND- INTIMATELY INVOLVED WITH
IN CALIFORNIA- IN SELF
DETERMINATION FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND SO WITH THE SUPPORT
OF ALL THOSE AND OTHERS. YOU
REALLY DO LOOK FORWARD TO JEFF
PRESENTING A PLAN THAT THAT
SUPPORTS A BROADER AND
EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION OF. OF
SELF DETERMINATION MOVING
FORWARD- SO THE NEXT COUPLE
QUESTIONS ARE ABOUT- THAT
CHALLENGES AND THE PRIORITIES
AND IN RELATION TO THE PROVIDER
NETWORK AND I KINDA WANT TO.
ADDRESS THOSE TOGETHER BECAUSE
I DO THINK THERE. THERE IS
WIND- YOU KNOW FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE TALK ABOUT
CHALLENGES AND PRIORITIES FOR
THAT WE REALLY DO. WANT TO
EMPHASIZE SAFETY AND IN THE
DELIVERY AND RECEIPT OF
SERVICES AND NOT JUST FROM THE
PROVIDER PERSPECTIVE. BUT ALSO
FOR PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE SERVICES
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND THOSE
THEY LIVE WITH. SO WE HEARD
EARLIER ABOUT. THE NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT ARE AND STRATEGIES
ARE GOING ON WITH. FROM
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT TO ACCESS
TO TESTING AND VACCINES IT
CERTAINLY. MR NINETY ONE ON
MUTE FOR A SECOND. SORRY ABOUT
THAT. SO WE DO HAVE THAT TO
LOOK TO SOME OF THE THING IS
SAFETY THAT- WITH THE ACCESS TO
A PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT- TESTING
IMPACT SEEMS TO REALLY ENHANCE
THE SAFETY SO THAT FOLKS THAT
ARE RECEIVING SERVICES- CAN DO
SO SAFELY AND DOLLARS ARE
PROVIDED THEM AS WELL. AND
AGAIN WE TALK ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES AND PRIORITIES THAT
OF THE PROVIDER NETWORK WE HAVE
TO START WITH WHAT ARE THE
NEEDS OF PERFECT. LOVE SHE
RECEIVED SERVICE AT AND I HAVE
TO INFORM US AS WE MOVE FORWARD
TRYING TO BUILDING AND
MAINTAINING THAT- PROVIDER
NETWORK AS WELL. JONES ALSO AS
NOTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING OUR
CONSUMER ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE. AND TO LOOK AT WHAT IS
THE SERVICE OPTIONS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND BEYOND AND GET
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS ON
POTENTIAL SHORT AND LONG TERM
CHANGES. YEAH WE MENTIONED
EARLIER IN IN THE AGENDA NUMBER
OF PEOPLE TALK ABOUT WE NEED TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF WHAT WE
LEARNED DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND HELPED SHAPE WHAT THINGS
ARE GOING TO LOOK LIKE LONG
TERM CERTAINLY THINGS THAT THAT
DIRECTOR BARGE IN AND OTHERS
HAVE MENTIONED- SOME OF THOSE
THINGS ARE INCREASING THAT
ACCESS TO PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
SERVICES. REMOTE DELIVERY OF
SERVICE AND ACCESS TO SERVICES
AND SOME OTHERS ARE THOSE THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT. TO
CONTINUE AND CODIFY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. WE REALLY DO NEED TO
HAVE A- FOR A PRIORITY A
CONTINUED FOCUS ON INDIVIDUAL
CHOICE. AND FLEXIBILITY NOT
ONLY IN THE WAY THAT SERVICES
ARE RECEIVED BUT THE WAY THAT
THEY'RE DELIVER. SO WITH THESE
AS AS FOCUSED WITH PRIORITIES
ARE WORK- IT REALLY HAS TO THEN
ICLUDE. WHAT IS THE PAYMENT
STRUCTURE AND SERVICE DELIVERY
STRUCTURE THAT'S GONNA ENABLE
PROVIDERS. TO SUPPORT THOSE
OPTIONS AND FLEXIBILITY THAT
CONSUMERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WALKED. SO THAT'LL BE A REALLY
THE YOU KNOW AS WE MOVE FORWARD
REALLY A FOCUS IS TO. ONCE WE
IDENTIFY WHAT THE PRIORITIES
ARE TO HELP AND IDENTIFY WHAT
IT IS THAT WE NEED TO PUT IN
PLACE TO- AND PAYMENT
STRUCTURES ARE STILL GOING TO
BE A BIG PART OF IT. TOO TO
SUPPORT THE ONGOING DELIVERY OF
SERVICES. AND THEN FINALLY I
WANT TO- AND WITH- SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT MINIMUM WAGE SO
THAT AS HAS HAPPENED OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE MINIMUM
WAGE TO INCREASE AGAIN- THIS
JANUARY AND SO LIKE WE DONE
PREVIOUSLY WE DID PUT OUT.
ACTIONS ON ON HOW THAT IS-
GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED IT'S
SIMILAR TO WHAT IT'S BEEN DONE
AND PREVIOUS YEARS. WHICH FOR
THE MOST PART THAT PROVIDERS
ARE IN SYMMETRIC QUESTIONS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OR REGIONAL
CENTER- SO IT WILL TAKE.
BECAUSE OF THE TIMING OF WHEN
THE MINIMUM WAGE GOES AND- INTO
A FACT AND THEN. THE TIME THAT
ULTIMATELY ANY RATE CHANGES GET
IMPLEMENTED. AND THEN CLAIMS
ARE SUBMITTED IT DOES TAKE
SEVERAL MONTHS FOR US TO. TO
ULTIMATELY GET WHAT IS THE
ACTUAL IMPACT OF WHAT DOES THE
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE SAYS. YES
I KNOW THE AGENDA DID ASK TO
LOOK AT SOME PRIOR YEAR
EXPERIENCES. WHAT WE'VE NOTICED
INSIDE YOU JUST FOR- EXAMPLE.
FOR THE INCREASE THAT TOOK
EFFECT IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. THE ESTIMATED ANNUAL
IMPACT FOR THE SUBSEQUENT
FISCAL YEAR WAS ESTIMATED IN
THE BUDGET TO BE. ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
MILLION. WHEREAS WHEN WE LOOK
BACK ON THE ACTUAL EXPENDITURES
WE SEE THAT THAT WAS ABOUT
EIGHTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS AN
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES. SIMILARLY
FOR THE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE
THAT TOOK EFFECT IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY. THE ESTIMATED
ANNUAL IMPACT WAS A HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE ACTUAL- EXPENDITURES
THAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR- WHERE
IT IS A LITTLE OVER A HUNDRED
SEVEN NAY. SO WITH THIS CURRENT
MINIMUM WAGE AND INCREASE- WE
WILL AND SEVERAL MONTHS IN A
LIKELY BE AFTER THEM THAT THE
THIS BUDGET IS ENACTED A LITTLE
BETTER IDEA OF WHAT WE'RE
SEEING- THE IMPACT IS THIS TIME
AND- AS WE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE
THERE ARE SOME. THINGS THAT
MAKE THAT CHALLENGING FOR US TO
ATTEMPT TO- ESTIMATE THE IMPACT
IN ONE OF THOSE IS AS- DIRECTOR
BARGMANN MENTIONED EARLIER TO
AS A WEEK. WE DON'T HAVE
INFORMATION ON THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES. THAT PROVIDERS HAVE
AND THEIR- IN THEIR SALARIES AS
WELL. DO IT AT ALL AND MY
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MR NIGHT
NEXT WE HAVE- STEVEN PAVLOV
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I THINK
YOU CHAIR STEVEN PAUL MCCORMACK
FINANCE FINANCE WITH US- THREE
QUESTIONS THE FIRST WHICH I'VE
BEEN WAS- WHAT IS THE RATIONALE
FOR THIS INSPECTION POLICY
RECOMMENDED YES SO WELL KNOWN
PROVIDER RATES. SO GIVEN THE
FORECASTED STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE
IN THE MULTI YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
SUSPEND THE HOME LOAN RATES ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE SPECIAL TO BE
LEFT THAT IF THEY MINISTRATION
SERMONS THROUGH THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO BUDGET ACT PROCESSES
THAT THEY'RE SUFFICIENT GENERAL
FUND REVENUE SUPPORT AUSTIN
PROGRAMS AND SUBSEQUENT TO
FISCAL YEARS. SO THESE CHANGES
REFLECT A SIMILAR APPROACH
ADOPTED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
ON LEGISLATION PRIOR BUDGETS
YOU KNOW HOW WE HANDLE THAT ARE
YOUR SHORTFALL IN THE NEED FOR
SERVICE PROVISION IS CERTAINLY
DIFFICULT QUESTION AND WE-
WELCOME ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON. THE
ISSUE ABOUT THE BUDGET PROCESS.
THE NEXT ONE. WAS WHAT WOULD BE
THE END OF THE SUSPENSION
PURSUANT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IF IT TOOK PLACE
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. SO THE FUNDING FOR
THE PURCHASE OF SERVICES- WOULD
BE REDUCED HOWEVER THE FUNNY
WOULD NOT RETURN TO INCREASE OF
WOMEN ALREADY- INCREASED
LEVELS. BECAUSE OF SUBSEQUENT
FUNDING HAS BEEN PROVIDED FOR A
CASELOAD AND UTILIZATION AS
WELL AS SB THREE MINIMUM WAGE
ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE JUST
DISCUSSED. AND LASTLY- HOW
WOULD PROVIDERS LIKELY RESPONSE
TO THIS APPREHENSION AROUND
LOSS OF. THE RATE INCREASE IN
IN GERMANY. OF TIME. I WOULD
SAY THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
SENSITIVE TO THE STABILITY OF
THE PROVIDER NETWORK I WOULD
MEAN INVESTMENTS. AND
SUPPLEMENT PROVIDER RATES IN
THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE IN
THE PAST THREE YEARS AND POSTED
USE AGAIN FOR AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR. FORMER THE SITUATION OUR
INITIATION SAY CAN IMMEDIATE
ACTION THIS YEAR TO MEDINA
PROVIDER NETWORK BY REIMBURSING
PROVIDERS FOR ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES DURING THE PANDEMIC.
ALONG WITH PROVIDING OTHER
CLOVER NINETEENTH LOOKS AS
THOUGH HE'S- SO WILL CONTINUE
EXAMINING NEEDS OF. AND WELCOME
DISCUSS ON THIS IS. THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE SUNNY PADDOCK WITH
THE LEAD ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR AMBULANCE THIS
IS SONYA PADDOCK AGAIN FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
WE WERE ASKED TO PROVIDE OUR
OFFICES OBSERVATIONS AND
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE SUSPENSION
POLICY THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST- I WENT THROUGH.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE- THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S NEW PROPOSAL TO-
TO THE EXTENT TO I'M SORRY TO
IMPLEMENT A NEW SUSPENSION
CALCULATION COULD POTENTIALLY
LEAD TO SUSPENSIONS AS OF
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHICH AS NOTED IS
ONE YEAR LATER THAN. IS
CURRENTLY- IN STATUTE- WE NOTE
HOWEVER THAT THESE THE
SUSPENSION IS REALLY AFFECT
CORE ONGOING PROGRAMS ACROSS
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES-
POLICY AREAS INCLUDING MEDIC
CAL IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
AND IN DDS. THIS REALLY CREATES
UNCERTAINTY FOR PROVIDERS MAKES
IT HARD FOR THEM TO BUDGET AND
PLAN IT MAKES IT HARD FOR THEM
TO HIRE AND RETAIN STAFF- THE
L. A- WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL- TO INCLUDE
NEW SUSPENSION LANGUAGE IN THE
BUDGET ACROSS. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS. THE SECOND
QUESTION WE ARE ASKED TO
ADDRESS IS WHAT ARE WE HEARING
ABOUT THE SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
PROVIDER NETWORK AND ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL ACTION STEPS FOR
THE STATE TO TAKE TO ENSURE
THAT THE NETWORK IS ABLE TO
SERVE THE DDS POPULATION POST
PANDEMIC. I'D LIKE TO FIRST
START BY THANKING- THE VARIOUS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE GIVEN OUR OFFICE A LOT OF
TIME TO- GO OVER THESE ISSUES
WITH US AND WE'VE BEEN TALKING
WITH A NUMBER OF THEM ON AND ON
A REGULAR BASIS THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC AND I'M REALLY
GRATEFUL. TO THEM FOR THEIR
TIME- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE HEARD CONSISTENTLY IS
THAT THERE IS A COINCIDENCE
STRAIN ON THE RESIDENTIAL-
SERVICE AND SUPPORT PROVIDERS.
WHILE THERE IS- AT THE SAME
TIME A SORT OF SLACK ON THE NON
RESIDENTIAL SERVICE PROVIDERS
WHO ARE LIMITED IN PROVIDING
SERVICES BECAUSE OF THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS- AND SO THIS IS A
CREATED A UNIQUE SITUATION
WHERE THERE MAY BE SOME BURN
OUT AMONG- STAFF PROVIDING
RESIDENTIAL AND- IN HOME
SUPPORTS- WHILE ON THE
NONRESIDENTIAL SIDE- THEIR
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO YOU KNOW
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
HOURS AND WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THEIR SUPPORTS.
ANOTHER KEY THING THAT WE DO
THAT OUR OFFICE HAS BEEN
HEARING IS THAT THE VARIETY OF
UNCERTAINTY EARLY IN THE SYSTEM
IS MAKING THINGS CHALLENGING ON
FOR THE PROVIDER NETWORK SO FOR
EXAMPLE- THE POTENTIAL
SUSPENSION OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL
READING CREASES AS WE JUST
DISCUSSED HAS BEEN A NOTED TO
OUR OFFICE- IN ADDITION AS
ALREADY DISCUSSED IN THE
HEARING TODAY. THE SORT OF
INCONSISTENT IMPLEMENTATION OF
DTS DIRECTIVES ACROSS REGIONAL.
CENTERS HAS ALSO AFFECTED- NOT
JUST FAMILY ANDINDIVIDUALS
SERVED ALSO ANOTHER PROVIDER
NETWORK- IN ADDITION AS ALSO
DISCUSSED THE DURATION OF THE
FLEXIBILITIES ALLOWED- THAT HAS
ALSO BEEN AN ISSUE THE THIRTY
DAY RENEWALS HAS CREATED SOME
UNCERTAINTY. AND THEN THE LACK
OF INFORMATION ABOUT ULTIMATE
RATE REFORM OR IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE RATE STUDY HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE RAISED TO OUR OFFICE.
WE'VE ALSO HEARD THAT OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC SOME
PROVIDERS HAVE Y. STAFF DUE TO
THINGS LIKE- IN IN ADDITION TO
SORT OF THE REGULAR REASONS
THAT A PROVIDER MIGHT LOSE
STAFF- DURING THE PANDEMIC SOME
PROVIDERS OF LOS STAFF DUE TO
FAMILIAL OBLIGATIONS SUCH AS
DEALING WITH THEIR- CHILDREN
NOT BEING IN SCHOOL- OR DUE TO
MEDICAL CONDITIONS INCLUDING
COVERT NINETEEN. SO I JUST
OFFER A FEW THOUGHTS ON ON
POTENTIAL ACTION STEPS AND
SEVERAL OF THESE HAVE ALREADY
BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY SO I'M NOT
GONNA SPEND A LOT OF TIME THERE
BUT- YOU KNOW EXTENDING SOME OF
THE DIRECTIVES FOR MORE THAN
THIRTY DAYS AT A TIME- COULD BE
HELPFUL TO REDUCE UNCERTAINTY.
AND AS I ALREADY MENTIONED
REJECTING THE SUPPOSE OF I'M
SORRY REJECTING THE PROPOSED
SUSPENSION LANGUAGE- COULD
HELP- WITHTHE SUSTAINABILITY
OF THE PER PROVIDER NETWORK-
YOU EVER. THE ADMINISTRATION TO
COMMENT ON ITS LONG TERM
STRATEGY- IN TERMS OF RATE
REFORM AND OR IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE RATE STUDY- AND IT WOULD
ALSO BE HELPFUL THAT. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN- REQUIRING
PROVIDERS TO SUBMIT THE
INFORMATION- PARTICULARLY IN
THE AREA OF ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES AND NON RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES. TO SUBMIT INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE DELIVERING
SERVICES AND- I WOULD THINK IT
WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA TO INCLUDE
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF STAFF- THAT THEY HAVE
RETAINED OR LOST SO THAT THE-
THE LEGISLATURE. HAS MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHETHER LOTS
OF STAFF IS GOING TO BE A
SERIOUS PROBLEM POST PANDEMIC.
THE LAST QUESTION WE'VE BEEN
ASKED TO ADDRESS OUR POTENTIAL
IDEAS FOR THE FOR HOW THE DDS
BUSINESS MODEL COULD CHANGE AS
A RESULT OF LESSONS LEARNED IN
THE PANDEMIC- THAT COULD
IMPROVE QUALITY OF SERVICES
ACCESS TO SERVICES OR ADDRESS
DISPARITIES IN THE SYSTEM. SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT- MISTER
NIGHT- MENTIONED IS AND SEVERAL
OTHER PEOPLE MENTION TODAY IS
THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS RESULTED
IN. INCREASED ARM FLEXIBILITY
IN SERVICE PROVISION AS WELL AS
A MORE PERSON CENTERED APPROACH
TO DETERMINE. WHAT EACH
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND CAN
HANDLE. I'M AND WE THINK THAT
NOT ONLY COULD SOME OF THOSE
LESSONS BE APPLIED OUTSIDE OF
THE SCOPE OF CONTEXT BUT IT
COULD ALSO HELP THE STATE AND
MOVING TOWARD EACH CBS
COMPLIANCE- AT THE SAME TIME
THE MORE FLEXIBLE AND
INDIVIDUALIZED APPROACH TO
SERVICE DELIVERY DURING THE
PANDEMIC HAS RAISED SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW TO DEFINE
AND BILL FOR PARTICULAR
SERVICES. SO THERE IS SORT OF
AN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW TO
CONSIDER THINGS LIKE THE
SERVICE CODE STRUCTURE- THE
CURRENT PROCESS USED TO THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVER
PROCESS THAT USED TO ACCOUNT
FOR SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES. AND
JUST THE NOTION OF THESE HIGHLY
INDIVIDUALIZED- SERVICE PLANS-
FOR PEOPLE AND THEN THE LAST
THING I WOULD JUST MENTION
WHICH IT SOUNDS LIKE THE- THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALREADY. WELL ON
ITS WAY TO YOU TRYING TO PUT
THIS INTO A REGULATIONS OR OR
MAKE IT A MORE LONG TERM OPTION
IS JUST TO- CONSIDER THE
ADDITIONAL CATEGORIES OF
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED SERVICES-
WE ALSO THINK THAT- AS THE
STATE'S ROLLING OUT THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM THIS IS
AN INTERESTING AREA OF POLICY
BECAUSE IT MIGHT PROVIDE SOME.
GREATER AMOUNT OF CONTROL TO
THE FAMILIES AND- CONSUMERS WHO
DON'T NECESSARILY WANT TO GO
THE ROUTE OF SELF DETERMINATION
BUT WOULD LIKE A GREATER SAY IN
SOME OF THEIR SERVICES. SO
FINALLY IN JUST GOING TO
COMMENT ON THE DISPARITIES
ISSUES AND- MAYBE WHAT'S BEEN
LEARNED DURING THE PANDEMIC
THAT COULD HELP LATER ON. SO AS
WE ALL KNOW THAT- STATEWIDE THE
PANDEMIC HAS REALLY EXACERBATED
SOME OF THE PRE EXISTING RACIAL
AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES IN THE
STATE. AND WE KNOW THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ALSO FACE THEIR
OWN SET OF DISPARITIES. AND
THESE ISSUES CAN REALLY BE
COMPOUNDED FOR A PERSON OF
COLOR WHO HAS A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY. SO JUST FOR A
MOMENT LOOKING OUTSIDE OF DDS
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE
SOME EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE
SERIOUS ADVERSE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC ON PARTICULAR.
POPULATIONS WE YOU KNOW THERE
ARE STILL A VERY
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBERS OF
CASES AND DEATHS ACROSS THE
STATE BUT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
TARGETED EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES. SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
TRIED TO INCREASE ITS EFFORTS
TO REACH PEOPLE SERVE QUORUM
COURT WHERE THEY ARE SO IN
OTHER WORDS- THIS MIGHT INCLUDE
YOU KNOW THE A BETTER
TRANSLATION OF MATERIALS
TARGETED AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS
HIRING CONTACT TRACERS WAS.
CULTURAL COMPETENCY OFFERING
HOTEL ROOMS FOR QUARANTINING
FOR PEOPLE WHO MAYBE DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO SELF ISOLATE.
SO- THERE LIKE LESS THAT CA BE
TAKE FROM THESE EFFORTS AND
APPLIED OUTSIDE OF BOTH THE
PANDEMIC EXPERIENCE AS WELL AS
WITH IN THE DDS. SYSTEM WE HAVE
ACTUALLY RECOMMENDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT IT FUND A
COMPREHENSIVE AFTER ACTION
REVIEW OF THE STATE'S RESPONSE
TO COPE IN NINETEEN THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. IN
IN ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS PROPOSED TO THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY TO
CONDUCT AN EQUITY FOCUSED
RETROSPECTIVE STUDY. THESE
STUDIES REALLY SHOULD BOTH
INCLUDE THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY- SPECIFICALLY AND-
WOULD HOPEFULLY PROVIDE SOME
IMPORTANT LESSONS ABOUT
REACHING CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES TO MITIGATE
DISPARITIES. AND FINALLY- IN
TERMS OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO IMPLEMENT A
COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR- SPENT I'M
SORRY COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR
PROGRAMS STATEWIDE- WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDER. A
FORMAL EVALUATION OF THIS
EFFORT AND THE BEST WAY TO DO
THAT WOULD BE TO REALLY BUILD
IN THAT THE COMPONENTS THAT
WOULD BE NECESSARY FROM THE
OUTSET TO CONDUCT A FORMAL
EVALUATION. SO THAT CONCLUDES
MY COMMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
WE HAVE ERIC SEGMENT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. FOR THE GOLDEN GATE
REGIONAL CENTER. THANK THANK
YOU DR ARAMBULA- I AM EGGMAN-
THE GOLDEN GATE REGIONAL CENTER
SERVES SAN MATTEO SAN FRANCISCO
AND MARIN COUNTIES THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE AND TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTIONS AND YOUR GENDER.
OKAY REGIONAL CENTER HAS
RESPONDED IN MANY WAYS TO THE
PANDEMIC IN TERMS OF PROTECTING
THE HEALTH AND WELFARE OF THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE. BECAUSE THE
COMMITTEE HAS ALREADY HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUES CARLOS AND
LISA ON THE LAST PANEL I WILL
ONLY HIGHLIGHTS FIVE WAYS WE
HAVE DONE THIS. ALMOST A YEAR
AGO G. G. R. C. BEGAN MEETING
WITH SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED
PROVIDERS SERVICE PROVIDERS
EVERY WEEK AND WE'VE BEEN DOING
THAT CONSISTENTLY AND WE DID IT
YESTERDAY- TO FIGHT THE
PANDEMIC WE ESTABLISH AND
DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS WITH
LOCAL DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IN OUR AREA. TO HELP
WITH VIRUS OUTBREAKS AND
RESPOND TO THOSE AND TO- MAKE
TESTING MORE AVAILABLE AND NOW
WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM AROUND
VACCINES. WE DISTRIBUTED PPVS
INITIALLY TO VIRUS OUTBREAK
SITES IN THEM TO OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY STARTING WITH A
MAILING IF I'M NOT A BOX OF
FIFTY MASKS TO SEVEN THOUSAND
FAMILIES- AND TO DATE WE- ARE
DISTRIBUTED TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION PIECES OF BP. YOU START
BY ASKING MESSAGING SYSTEM
CALLED EVERBRIDGE IN OUR
WEBSITE TO SEND INITIAL AND
ONGOING MESSAGES TO EVERYONE IN
OUR COMMUNITY FAMILIES
INDIVIDUAL SERVICE PROVIDERS.
AND OUR OWN STAFF. AND MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY WE HAVE USED THE
DDS HEALTH AND SAFETY DIRECTIVE
TO STABILIZE HOME SUPPORT AND
REDUCE THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
BETWEEN HOMES. IN TERMS OF
DIRECTIVES DDS AND IN MANY WAYS
DDS HAS TAKEN EXTRAORDINARY
EXTRAORDINARY STEPS TO- SUPPORT
OUR WORK. WITH THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY AUTHORITY. GRANTED
REGIONAL CENTERS WE HAVE FUNDED
STAFFING CHANGE CHANGE CHANGES
THAT HAVE REDUCE THE SPREAD AS
I'VE SAID AND SAVE LIVES I
BELIEVE AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO RECOGNIZE THE
HEROIC EFFORTS OF DIRECT CARE
STAFF TO REMAIN AN ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL FACE TO FACE CONTACT.
WITH THE INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE
RISKING THEIR OWN HEALTH AND
SAFETY BECAUSE OF THEIR
COMMITMENT TO THE INDIVIDUALS
THEY SUPPORT AND OFTEN THEY
LOVE. MANY OTHER DDS DIRECTIVES
HAVE BEEN VERY HELPFUL BUT I
WOULD BE REMISS IN MY DUTIES IF
I DIDN'T MENTION ONE MORE
ASPECT OF PANDEMIC DIRECTIVES.
IT IS ONE THING TO DECREE THE
DIRECTIVE AT A POLICY LEVEL AS
BEFORE TODAY IT IS QUITE
ANOTHER TO IMPLEMENT A
CONTINUOUS STREAM OF NEW
DEMANDS FOR SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS ARE BEING DELIVERED.
EDS SHOULD BE PRAISED AND HAS
BEEN PRAISED HERE IN THIS.
HEARING FOR WORKING WITH
REGIONAL CENTERS FAMILIES AND
PROVIDERS TO GAIN FEEDBACK AND
INPUT ON THE CREATION OF MANY
DIRECTIVES. THAT HAS HELPED FOR
SURE. BUT THE HISTORIC
UNDERFUNDING OF REGIONAL CENTER
OPERATIONS AND STAFF MAKES
IMPLEMENTATION VERY CHALLENGING.
IN TERMS OF OTHER CHALLENGES I
THINK THE GREATEST CHALLENGES
AND OPPORTUNITIES COMING OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC. WILL BE SHUTTING
THE HABIT OF ONLY REACTING TO
CRISES. AS A STATE WE NEED TO
CLARIFY WHERE WE ARE HEADED AS
A SYSTEM. WE NEED SYSTEMIC
GOALS TO ALIGN OUR EFFORTS AND
MANAGE OUR RESOURCES. NOW THAT
WE HAVE FOR ALL INTENTS AND
PURPOSES CLOSED LARGE
INSTITUTIONS. WHAT WILL BE OUR
NEW NORTH STAR. SPECIFICALLY IN
TERMS OF THE PANDEMIC RELATED
CHALLENGES. WE NEED AND
ESPECIALLY IN CONSIDERING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WE
NEED TO STOP LOOKING AT
INTERNET ACCESS AS HARDWARE
HARDWARE AND UTILITY COSTS AND
START LOOKING AT THESE
INVESTMENTS AS A NEW METHOD OF
TRANSPORTATION. IT IS ANOTHER
MEANS OF GETTING SUPPORT. TO BE
INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE. SECONDLY
WE NEED TO LEARN FROM THOSE WE
SERVE IN OUR PROVIDERS WE HAVE
IN FRONT OF US I BELIEVE A ONCE
IN A. GENERATION OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN FROM REMOTE AND OF
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES. AND SONY
WAS JUST MENTIONING WE NEED I
BELIEVE THE PILOT FROM PROGRAMS
THAT WILL BRING PERSON CENTRED
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS WHERE AND
WHEN AND HOW. WE NEED THEM
FINALLY THE VERY FOUNDATION OF
THE ENTITLEMENT RESTS ON DDS
REGIONAL CENTERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND HOW WE WORK
TOGETHER IN ORDER TO LISTEN TO
OUR COMMUNITIES AND RESPOND TO
THE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WE
SERVE. WE AS A STATE CANNOT
ACCOMPLISH THIS WITHOUT
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TWO YEARS
AGO THE STATE MADE CLEAR
INVESTMENTS IN TWO PARTS OF THE
SUPPORT OF THE SUPPORT SYSTEM
YES AS DIRECTOR BARTON WAS
MENTIONING WAS FUNDED TO HAVE A
10% INCREASE IN STAFF AT IT AT
AT ITS HEADQUARTERS IN MOST BUT
NOT ALL SERVICE PROVIDERS
RECEIVED AN EIGHT POINT TWO.
PERCENT INCREASE IN THEIR
FUNDING. REGIONAL CENTERS
HOWEVER HAVE BEEN LEFT TO
CONTEND WITH AN EVER INCREASING
WORKLOAD BASED ON TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND DDS DIRECTIVES
WITH INADEQUATE FUNDING
SUPPORTING CAPACITY. WE MUST
HAVE CASELOADS AND WORKLOADS A
REGIONAL CENTER TO MEET ALL THE
NEEDS OF ALL THOSE WE SERVE
INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS AND
UNDERSERVED ETHNIC AND LANGUAGE
COMMUNITIES. INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND INDIVIDUALS
TRANSITIONING INTO THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. ALMOST
EVERYONE IN OUR COMMUNITY
HONESTLY IS EXHAUSTED FROM THE
STRESS AND THE CHALLENGES OF
THIS PANDEMIC. FAMILIES
INDIVIDUALS DIRECT CARE WORKERS
DDS STAFF AND REGIONAL CENTER
STAFF. BUT WE ARE DOING THE
BEST WE CAN TO SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITIES WE ASK THIS
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER'S REGIONAL
CENTER PROVIDER BUDGET.
REQUESTS FOR THE FUTURE OF
THOSE WE SERVE. I REALLY
BELIEVE NOW IS THE TIME FOR YOU
TO ACT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WE WILL MOVE
ON TO HARRY BROUGH WELL
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF PATH POINT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE COMPARABLE AND YOUNG ONE
SERVICE PROVIDER IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. I WAS REQUIREMENTS
WHAT IS OUR EXPERIENCES
PROVIDERS DURING. WHAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
THE WATER ARGUES FOR THE FUTURE
THE DTS BUSINESS MODEL MY SHORT
ANSWERS ARE THANK YOU FOR
STAYING IN THE SYSTEM MAINTAIN
STABILITY THROUGH THE
TRANSITION AND BUILD BETTER.
EXPAND ON EACH ONE. IN TERMS OF
OUR EXPERIENCE DURING THE
PROVIDER WHAT WORKS IS HUGE
THANK YOU YES MINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE DDS COLLABORATED
WITH INDIVIDUAL SERVICE
FAMILIES PROVIDERS REGIONAL
CENTERS AND OTHERS YOU DON'T
HEARD AND THAT WE ARE WORKING
IN PARTNERSHIP TO ADDRESS THE-
ISSUES. THIS IS. THE
FLEXIBILITIES. WORKSTREAM AND
HELPFUL. LET'S TURN SERVICES
AND REVERSE. NEEDS HELP PEOPLE
AND ALLOW FOR INTERNET. HOW ARE
ALL SERVICE. THOUSAND OF
INDIVIDUALS ARE CONTINUING TO
RECEIVE SERVICES OFTEN DEALER
TO THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS WE MANY
WONDERFUL STORIES OF HEROES
RECEIVING ERRORS PROVIDING
SERVICES AND WE RETAIN THE
PROVIDER WORKFORCE. WHAT STILL
NEEDS ADDRESSING THE REMAINING
WORKFORCE CHALLENGES ESPECIALLY
WITH RESIDENTIAL PROVIDERS ONE
ONE SERVICES SUCH AS SUPPORTED.
STAFF AUSTIN IT'S DIFFERENT TO
HIRE TURNING SERVICES GYM WORK
FOR EVERYONE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO SUPPORT
EVERYONE INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND
DESIRES AND THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS DON'T WORK OUT INCLUDING
DEVELOPING AN ACCOUNTABILITY
STRUCTURE STREAMLINING BILLING.
RATES FOR SOME SERVICE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THE EAST IN
COLLABORATION WITH GPS AND ALL
STATE. WHAT TO HAPPEN IN THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS MAINTAIN
STABILITY THROUGH THE
TRANSITION. REMOVE THE
SUSPENSION DATE CURRENTLY FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL RATING. AS
MENTIONED EARLIER THE
SUSPENSION IS CREATING SCIENCE
CERTAIN TIME THAT THE SYSTEM
NEEDS AS MUCH STABILITY. IT
ALSO MAKES IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT. SUPPORT THE DIRECTOR
MARC FORSTER MORE EQUITABLE
MEANS THE JUSTIN RATES WHEN
STATE MINIMUM WAGE RATES
MAINTAIN THE FLEXIBILITY IS BY
CONTINUING ALTERNATE SERVICES
AND MARKET RATES WE DON'T WANT
TO INCENTIVIZE QUINCY PRACTICES
BY CUTTING BACK. TOO SOON ON
THE FLEXIBILITIES. ABOUT AN
OUTCOME BASED. STRUCTURE THAT
INTO NEEDS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS FOR
RESIDENTIAL AND ONE ONES. IN
TERMS OF THE FUTURE BACK BETTER
WE HAVE A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD A STRONGER SYSTEM
CENTERED ON PERSONAL CHOICE.
PANDEMIC DDS SYSTEM THEY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES IT HAS A
ONE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLAR
FUNDING DEFICIT AS A GENOCIDE
BINARY STUDY INSTRUCTURE
PRIMARILY ON NORMALIZATION
BASED FEE FOR SERVICE FINAL AND
IT'S RIGID STRUCTURE LIMITS
CHOICE AND CREATIVITY. CMS'S
PORTION FOR VALUE BASED PAYMENT
STRUCTURE AND IS JUNE NINTH
MENTIONED WE NEED TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH EACH CBS
SETTINGS WILL JUST OVER TWO
YEARS. OUR CHALLENGE IS TO TAKE
WHAT WE LEARNED. YEAH ALIGNED
WITH THE DIRECTION FROM C. N.
AT CMS. I DON'T REMEMBER WHERE
AN ACT- SYSTEM REALIZING WE ARE
GOING BACK TO FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY YOUR SOME STEPS. MENTAL
TURNER SERVICES BONNET TO
REDRESS DISPARITIES INSERTED
INDIVIDUALS TO RECEIVE.
SERVICES WHEN AND HOW THEY WANT.
DON'T REALLY CARE. BASED ON
INTO THE OUT CHOI. OUR COUNTRY
ARE EUROS COUNTY SATISFY WAS TO
REAL. LIKE THIS. IS ON HOW A
TRUE CENTERED PLAN. IN THE UC
TECHNO. NOT JUST FOR REMOTE
SERVICE FOR PROVIDING OF. BOB
HOW WE WORK INTERACT CONTINUE
MONTHLY RATES POTENTIALLY
EXPANDED OR SERVICES WOULD
REQUIRE OUR STATE COME TRUE
VALUE BASED. SURE THE MARKET
RATES ARE EQUITY CONSISTENT
ADEQUATE COST STATE ONE FOR
READS STUDY- O. THIS IS A WIN
WIN WIN KERN. INDIVIDUALS
SUPPORTED FAMILIES DDS REGIONAL
CENTERS AND PROVIDERS HAVE A
COMMON GOAL BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO LEAD THE WINDS
EIGHT UNIONS AFTER ALL THIS IS
WHY WERE ALL INVOLVED IN THIS
WORK. SO SUMMARIZING THANK YOU
FOR STAYING IN THE SYSTEM
MAINTAIN STABILITY THROUGH THE
TRANSITION FROM THE PANDEMICS
OF THE POST CODE ENVIRONMENT
AND BUILD BACK BETTER THANKS
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF PEOPLE WITH
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WE HAVE
JORDAN LINDSAY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. OF THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU DR RAM
RELIANT COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF. I AM JORDAN LINDSAY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ARC
IN UNITED'S PEOPLE POLICY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION. VERY
QUICKLY BEFORE I ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS IN THE AGENDA I
WANTED VERY QUICKLY COMMAND
EXPRESSED TREMENDOUS GRATITUDE
FOR THE VARIOUS COMPONENTS OF
OUR AND DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
SYSTEM WELL COLLABORATED AND
COMMUNICATED THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC. TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE
AND HEALTHY I HAVE NEVER BEFORE
SEEN THIS LEVEL OF PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN FAMILIES REGIONAL
CENTERS PROVIDERS THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE ALL IN AN EFFORT TO
SAVE LIVES AND IT HAS.
UNDOUBTEDLY DONE EXACTLY THAT.
I ALSO WANT TO QUICKLY
EXPRESSED GRATITUDE TO YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHO. DURING THE
LAST BUDGET CYCLE DEMONSTRATED
GREAT LEADERSHIP BY PROTECTING
OUR STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
FROM CUTS IN SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS. EXACTLY THE TIME THEY
NEEDED SUPPORT THE MOST SO
THANK YOU AGAIN. TO ADDRESS MY
QUESTIONS TODAY I'LL DIVIDE MY
REMARKS INTO THREE CATEGORIES
PANDEMIC RESPONSE EQUITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY. FIRST PROPOSALS
SPECIFIC TO PANDEMIC RESPONSE
WHICH INCLUDE THE MINIMUM WAGE
PROPOSAL BY ASSEMBLYMAN HOLDEN.
AND THE REGIONAL CENTER SERVICE
COORDINATOR PROPOSAL BY
ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER. AS HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED WIVES HAVE BEEN
TURNED UPSIDE DOWN AND THE
IMPACTS TO PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. HAS BEEN EXPONENTIAL
AT EVERY SINGLE PART OF A
PERSON SUPPORT SYSTEMS BEEN
IMPACTED. MY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
WHICH IS MADE UP ENTIRELY OF
PEOPLE WITH ID AND FAMILY
MEMBERS AND WHO ARE. FAIRLY
WELL NO HAVE OFTEN BEEN AT A
LOSS OF HOW TO GET BEST
SUPPORT. OR SUPPORT THEIR LOVED
ONES. IN THE IMPACTS ESPECIALLY
THE IMPACTS TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF CONSUMERS AND ALSO TO
FAMILY. WELL BEING HAS BEEN
DRASTIC. THE IMPACTS WOULD BE
MUCH WORSE HOWEVER IF IT
WEREN'T FOR THE HERO WITH THEM
THAT HAS BEEN DISPLAYED UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. BY OUR DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS THEY HAVE
SACRIFICED THEIR OWN HEALTH
THEIR OWN WELL BEING THE WELL
BEING OF THEIR FAMILIES TO
ENSURE. AS MUCH CONTINUITY IN
SAFETY AS POSSIBLE FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THEY SIR. THIS IS A
WORK FORCE THAT IS
PREDOMINANTLY WOMEN AND WOMEN
OF COLOR. AND THEY HAVE BEEN
AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
ESSENTIAL IN OUR RESPONSE TO
THIS PANDEMIC. AND THEY HAVE
MADE THE SACRIFICES WHILE
EARNING NEAR OR AT MINIMUM WAGE
DUE TO LOW RATES. AND AS WE
KNOW MINIMUM WAGE CALIFORNIA IS
ABOUT TO GO UP AGAIN BUT IN OUR
SYSTEM THIS INCREASES APPLIED
IN IN AN EQUITABLE. AND
ACTUALLY PERVERSE METHOD
BECAUSE SOME ORGANIZATIONS WILL
RECEIVE AN INCREASE IN PAYMENTS
TO OFFSET THE INCREASE THE
MINIMUM WAGE IN SOMEWHAT. THAT
MEANS SOME OF THESE ESSENTIAL
HEROES WILL RECEIVE WAGE
INCREASES AND SOME WALKED. AND
THIS WAS HIGHLIGHTED BY MR
KNIGHT'S COMMENTS WHICH
HIGHLIGHTED THE IMMENSE UNDER
UTILIZATION OF THE BUDGETED
FUNDS FOR MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES. THERE IS A PROPOSAL
FROM ASSEMBLYMAN HOLDEN TO
FINALLY MAKE THIS METHOD
EQUITABLE. INTO INCENTIVIZE
ORGANIZATIONS TO PAY HIGHER
WAGE INSTEAD OF WHAT WE
CURRENTLY DO TO INCENTIVIZE
ORGANIZATIONS TO KEEP STAFF AT
MINIMUM WAGE. THIS WOULD BE
DONE BY STANDARD THE STANDARD
PERCENTAGE INCREASE TO LOW WAGE
EARNERS REGARDLESS IF YOU MAKE
MINIMUM WAGE OR MORE THAN
MINIMUM WAGE. IT MAKES SENSE
AND IT PROVIDES EQUITY NOW IS
THE TIME FOR THE STATE TO
REPLACE THE OUTDATED AND
INEQUITABLE COMPENSATION
METHODOLOGY WITH THE UNIFORMITY
JUST MEANT. THAT WOULD ALLOW
PROVIDERS TO PAY COMPETITIVE
WAGES REFLECTIVE OF THE SKILLS
AND DEDICATION DEDICATION.
DEMANDED FOR QUALITY DIRECT
SUPPORT. ALSO AS RELATES TO OUR
PANDEMIC RESPONSE WE MUST
STRENGTHEN INDIVIDUAL AND
FAMILY ACCESS TO CRITICAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. AS I
MENTIONED FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS ARE SEARCHING FOR
METHODS OF SUPPORTS AND ADDS
NEW OPTIONS BECOME AVAILABLE
SUCH AS ALTERNATIVE SERVICES
FAMILIES RELY MORE AND MORE ON
THEIR SERVICE COORDINATORS AT
THE REGIONAL CENTERS. OUR
SERVICE COORDINATORS HOWEVER
HAVE BEEN BURDENED WITH
UNMANAGEABLE CASELOAD RATIOS
NEARLY NINETY OR HUNDRED
CLIENTS. BUT THE COMMITTEE YOUR
COMMITTEE HAS A PROPOSAL FROM A
SETTLEMENT FRAZIER TO REDUCE
THESE CASELOAD RATIOS. SO THAT
ALL FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS
CAN HAVE TIMELY ACCESS TO
SERVICE COORDINATION EXACTLY
THIS TIME WHEN THEY NEED IT
MOST. THE LEGISLATURE ANY
MINISTRATION SHOULD ENSURE
ACCESS TO SERVICE COORDINATION
OF REGIONAL CENTERS ESPECIALLY
AS SERVICES AND SUPPORTS ARE
RAPIDLY CHANGING AS MR ZIGMAN-
MENTIONED. AND THEY NEED TO DO
SO BY ENHANCING FUNDING FIRST
SERVICE COORDINATORS AT
REGIONALS REGIONAL CENTERS CAN
COMPLY. WITH CURRENT FEDERAL
GUIDANCE ON TOP KESSLER RATIOS.
NEXT I WANT TO DISCUSS
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE OUR
SYSTEM MORE EQUITABLE TO DOOR
TO DIVERSE COMMUNITIES WE
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO INCLUDE FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION TO IMPLEMENT A NEW
COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR MARC MODEL
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR FORTY
SEVEN FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS.
IN OUR CURRENT CRISIS THIS WILL
HELP SPECIFICALLY IN TWO WAYS
ONE PROVIDES CRITICAL
INFORMATION BY A TRUSTED SOURCE
TO INCREASE UTILIZATION OF
SERVICES BY DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
IN CHIU IT'LL ALSO HELP
MITIGATE. THE SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE IN EARLY START
UTILIZATION THAT DIRECTOR
PARCHMENT SHE'S EARLY START THE
ONLY RESOURCE CENTERS ALREADY
HAVE A CONTRACT TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION REFERRALS BUT
THEY'VE BEEN CHRONICALLY
UNDERFUNDED. AND WHILE THE
COVER ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
THEY HAVE DONE SO WITH MINIMAL
STAFF SOMETHING LIKE ONE OR TWO
STAFF SOMETIMES TO ADEQUATELY
MEET THE NEED ON IT AND THE
NEED IS. ESPECIALLY NOW THERE
IS THE NEED. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL UNDOUBTEDLY HELP EACH
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER TO
INCREASE OUR OUTREACH AND THIS
COMBINED WITH THE EQUITY GRANTS
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO ANY AND
ALL ORGANIZATIONS OUR SYSTEM
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S DEMONSTRATING A
CLEAR COMMITMENT. EQUITY FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS WITH.
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. IN IF YOU CAN
ACROSS AN EXTRA MONEY EVEN IF
YOU MILLION THIS WOULD ARGUABLY
BE THE BEST BANG FOR YOUR BUCK
TO INCREASE. OUR BEYOND THE
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL. AND THEN FINALLY I
QUICKLY WANT TO DISCUSS THAT
SUSTAINABILITY IN THE PANDEMIC
IN BEYOND YOUR FORTY HER GREAT
COMMENTS FROM IS RULE AND
OTHERS- FIRST WE ARE GRATEFUL
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED RETAINER
PAYMENTS. AND THE TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION FOR
INCREASED UTILIZATION FOR AN IN
PERSON SERVICES. IT STABILIZE
SERVICE DELIVERY SO THAT WE
COLLECT COLLECTIVELY. COULDN'T
MOVE OUR FOCUS AWAY FROM
RETAINING OUR WORKFORCE AND
INSTEAD. FOCUS ON MOBILIZING A
RESPONSE AND WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THAT. I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION THAT THIS. RESPONSE
THAT WE'VE ALL QUICKLY BEEN
TALKING ABOUT HAS HAPPENED. BY
A SYSTEM THAT IS ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS UNDER FIVE. I
WANT TO SAY MANAGING THE
RESPONSE WE COULD HAVE RIGHT
NOW WE HADN'T BEEN HOLDING ON
BY A THREAD FOR THE LAST TWO
DECADES. IMAGINE THE RESPONSE
WHAT COULD BE HAPPENING. ABOVE
AND BEYOND WHAT WE'RE DOING.
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
COMMUNITY FOUGHT HARD TO REDUCE
THIS UNDER FUNDING FROM ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION TO ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION. AND WE'RE
PREPARED TO MAKE MORE WE WERE
PREPARED TO MAKE MORE PROGRESS
THIS YEAR TO IMPLEMENT THE RATE
STUDY. BUT I IMPLORE THE
COMEDIAN ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDER THIS PANDEMIC IS ONLY
A POLICY IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE RATE STUDY. MR SIEGMAN
USE THAT THE PHRASE NORTHSTAR
AND I WANT TO STEAL THAT AND
STAY OFF AS WE DID CLOSE
INSTITUTIONS WHAT IS THAT NORTH
STAR NOW AND THE RATE STUDY IS
A PART OF THAT NORTH STAR AND
WE CAN'T FORGET THAT AND PUT IT
ON THE SHELF. OTHERWISE THIS
WOULD BE YET ANOTHER STUDY THAT
CONFIRMS YES CALIFORNIA'S
UNDERFUNDING INDIVIDUALS WITH
I. D. D. THEIR FAMILIES AND OUR
SUPPORT STAFF. WE ARE GOING TO
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT. EVEN
WORSE. IS THE PROPOSAL IN
JANUARY BUDGET THAT SAYS YES WE
CONFIRM YOU WERE HUGELY
UNDERFUNDED BUT NEXT YEAR WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE MONEY AWAY FROM
YOU. BY KNOCKING THE SUSPENSION
OF ANY PROGRESS YOU MADE IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS. ALL THE
COMMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE BY THE
L. A. O. YOU MISTER CHAIR AT
THE BEGINNING THE HEARING
COMMENTS FROM OTHER
LEGISLATURES ARE LEGISLATORS
OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS PUSHING
BACK. ON THIS STATUTE IN
EMPHASIZING THAT AT THE LANE
AND CUT IN SERVICES IS IN GOOD
GOOD ENOUGH. IT ONLY SERVES TO
CREATE MORE UNCERTAINTY IN
MORNINGSIDE. IN A TIME WHEN
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
THEIR FAMILIES. AND THEIR
SUPPORT STAFF NEEDS STABILITY.
THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WE HAVE JACKIE DILLARD FOSTER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF STEP AND
BOARD MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LIVING NETWORK. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THE
TIME TODAY MY NAME IS JACKIE
FOSTER IN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIES TO
EMPOWER PEOPLE WE PROVIDES
SUPPORTED LIVING INDEPENDENT
LIVING EMPLOYMENT DAY SERVICES
I ALSO SIT ON THE BOARD OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
NETWORK. THAT REPRESENTS
SUPPORTED LIVING INDEPENDENT
LIVING EMPLOYMENT PERSONAL
ASSISTANCE AND RESPITE CARE
THESE ARE ALL IN PERSON
SERVICES SO I'M GOING TO REALLY
FOCUS MY- MY COMMENTS ON THE
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
AND- THREE FOCUS AREAS THE
TRIUMPHS AND THE CHALLENGES
FIRST WITH THE PANDEMIC BEGAN.
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT PROGRAMS ARE
ALREADY UNDERSTAFFED IN PERSON
SUPPORT WORK IS COMPLICATED
WORK THAT REQUIRES DEDICATED
TRAINED PERSONNEL THEIR WORK IS
UNDERVALUED AND HAS ALWAYS BEEN
UNDERPAID BY THE STATE MAKING
IT DIFFICULT ALREADY TO ATTRACT
RECRUIT AND RETAIN. ADEQUATE
STAFFING THE PACKED THE
PANDEMIC ONLY MAGNIFIED THIS
PROBLEM WHEN THE SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDER OCCURRED
TRADITIONAL DAY PROGRAM AND DAY
SERVICES WERE FORCED TO CLOSE
AND MANY MOVE TO SOME FORMER
REMOTE OR VIRTUAL SERVICES.
THAT MEANT THOSE RESURGENT
RECEIVING SERVICES ARE SPENDING
ALMOST ALL OF THEIR TIME IN
ISOLATION AND THE NEED FOR IN
PERSON DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS INCREASE AS THEY
NOW NEEDED TO COVER THOSE DAY
PROGRAM HOURS AS WELL BUT THE
AVAILABLE WORKFORCE WAS
DECREASING. MOST OF OUR STAFF
ARE WOMEN THEIR SINGLE MOTHERS
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE AND LIKE
WITH WORKING WOMEN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THEY SUDDENLY HAD THE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITY OF
HOME SCHOOLING THEIR CHILDREN
AND CARING FOR THEIR OWN
PARENTS AND LOVED ONES. THERE
WERE MEN WHO ALSO HAD TO MAKE
THE SACRIFICES MANY OUR OF OUR
STAFF HAVE HAD TO LEAVE THE
WORK FORCE TO TAKE ON THESE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES OF
HOME SCHOOLING AND CHILDCARE
AND THIS HAS EXASPERATED THE
ALREADY EXISTING STAFFIG
CRISIS. ANOTHER LAYER OF
UNCERTAINTY FOR STAFFING WAS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO CODE
NINETEEN WHEN THE STAFF WAS
EXPOSED OR TESTED POSITIVE THEY
WOULD ENTER FOURTEEN DAY
QUARANTINE WHEN YOU ARE ALREADY
UNDERSTAFFED THIS WAS NOT ONLY
A DENTED ADDED STRESSOR TO THE
PROVIDER BUT THE PERSON
SUPPORTED BECAUSE. WERE THEY
EXPOSED AT ALL SO THEY HAD
INSTEAD. IN STAFF. ADDITIONALLY
THE WAS THE UNSUNG MAN. FOR
PROVIDERS OF THE EIGHTY HOUR
COLD SICK TIME PAY ENACTED BY
CALIFORNIA. A SERVICE FOR
GROWTH REVIVES THE BIGGEST
QUESTIONS WE HAD WORKED WATER
ESSENTIAL WORKFORCE CONTINUE TO
SHOW UP. DURING TO WORK DURING
THIS DEADLY PANDEMIC WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF THEY DIDN'T SHOW UP.
ONE OF THOSE RECEIVING SERVICES
WERE LEFT HOME ALONE HOW WOULD
WE PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
NECESSARY TRAINING FOR THEM TO
BECOME INFECTION CONTROL
EXPERT. COULD WE SECURE THE P.
P. COULD BE SECURE SANITATION
SUPPLIES. BUT JUST LIKE
EMERGENCY ROOM DOCTORS NURSES
FIREFIGHTERS AND POLICE
OFFICERS OUR STAFF DID SHOW UP
BECAUSE THEY KNEW THEY COULD BE
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH FOR THEIR CLIENTS NOT
ONLY DID THEY SHOW UP. THEY
BECAME THE BACKBONE OF THE
RESPONSE TO THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS MANY HAVEWORK EXCESSIVE
OVERTIME HOURS DUE TO THE
STAFFING SHORTAGE. THE DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS HAVE BEEN
THE HIDDEN WORKFORCE THEY DID
NOT GET THE RECOGNITION OF THE
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS OR
EVEN GROCERY STORE CLERKS BUT
WHAT THEY DID AND WHAT THEY
CONTINUE TO DO HAS BEEN
INVALUABLE. I THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS PANDEMIC
THAT WE TALK ABOUT THE DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS. I WANTED
TO INTRODUCE YOU TO LUSTENAU
LAWSON L. AND IS A DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL SINCE. TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SHE WORKS WITH
DAHLE. THIS JANUARY DOM WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH COPD NINETEEN
WHEN HE WAS TAKEN BY EMTS TO
THE HOSPITAL THE HOSPITAL DID
NOT WANT TO ADMIT DOM. BECAUSE
OF HIS COMPLEX BEHAVIORS EVEN
THOUGH AS BLOOD OFF LEVEL WAS
AT 86% HE WAS SENT HOME
LUSTENAU MADE THE CHOICE AT
THAT TIME. THAT SHE WAS GOING
TO BE THE PRIMARY CARETAKER FOR
DAHLE. SHE STAYED WITH HIM FOR
EIGHTEEN DAYS SHE LEFT HER
FIANCE HER ELDERLY IN LAWS WHO
MOVED IN DURING THE PANDEMIC
SHE LEFT THE CHILDREN AT HOME
TO STAY WITH DON BECAUSE SHE
KNEW IF SHE DID NOT STAY THERE.
THAT DAHLE MAY NOT SURVIVE
COBIT NINETEEN. THIS IS A
PICTURE OF DOM I REALLY WANT TO
SHOW THIS THIS DUMB AND LAZY
BOY CHAIR THAT THE VIBRATING
CHAIR. IS VIBRATING CHAIR WHO
KNEW THAT A MASSAGE CHAIR WOULD-BE A REALLY CRITICAL COMPONENT
TO COVER NINETEEN. BECAUSE HE
COULD SET UP AND IT KEPT HIS
LUNGS CLEAR SHE MADE SURE HE
HAD THAT SHARE SHE MADE SURE HE
WAS IN THE CHAIR. SHE ONLY
SLEPT WHEN HE SLEPT. SHE WAS
AWAKE ALL THAT TIME I REMEMBER
SHE TEXTED ME AND SHE SAID YOU
KNOW WHAT DON'T FEELING BETTER
BECAUSE HE HIT ME TODAY SO WE
KNOW THAT DON WAS FEELING
BETTER THIS IS LOS ANALES
COMMITMENT. BUT IT WASN'T JUST
LAWSUIT NOW MAKING THIS
COMMITMENT THESE WERE DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THESE DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS BECAME
ENTERTAINERS TEACHERS NURSES
COUNSELORS COMMUNICATION
FACILITATORS AND TECH SUPPORT
IN THE CLIENT'S HOME. THEY HAVE
KEPT PEOPLE OUT OF THE HOSPITAL
BY KEEPING THEM SAFE AT HOME
SUPPORTING THEM EFFECTIVELY
WHEN THEY DID BECOME ILL
SOMETIMES A GREAT SACRIFICE TO
THEMSELVES. BUT ALL THEIR
EFFORTS WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THEIR LIVES WERE SAVED BECAUSE
OF THE WORK OF THESE DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE DDS- MADE
AVAILABLE IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE WISH IT HAPPENED
SOONER. BUT THE ISOLATION RIGHT
BECAUSE LAW TO KNOW WAS ABLE TO
GET A COMPETITIVE WAGE WHILE
SHE WAS THERE WITH DON NOW OUR.
ONLY HOPE IS THAT COMPETITIVE
WAGE WOULD BECOME A MORE PER.
WAY FOR SOMEONE LIKE LOS NOW.
HAD A WEEK MAINTAIN QUALITY
SERVICES AS A QUEST WILL BE IN.
WELL WE PROFESSIONALS THE WORK
FORCE THIS WORK FORCE WE CALL
THEM DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS BUT WE DON'T PAY
THEM PROFESSIONAL WAGES. WE
NEED TO PAY THESE DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS A
COMPETITIVE WAGE EVEN THOUGH
OUR STAFF PROVIDE THE LICENSING
CARE THE STATE'S WAGE RATE IS
EMBARRASSINGLY LOW. OFTEN NEAR
MINIMUM WAGE OR MINIMUM WAGE
FOR MANY INSTANCES. SUPPORTING
IN EDUCATING THE WORKFORCE
AROUND VACCINES AND ITS SAFETY
IS GOING TO BE ANOTHER CRITICAL
COMPORTAMIENTO- COMPONENT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. NUMBER THREE WE
MUST IMPLEMENT LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS THAT EMPHASIZE EQUITY
AND ACCESS AND ACHIEVE QUALITY
OUTCOMES. ACCOUNTABILITY WE
HAVE TO ALIGN OUR RESOURCES
WITH MEASURABLE QUALITY
OUTCOMES C. C. L. N. IS PROUD
OF THE- INTRODUCTION OF AB
EIGHT ONE THREE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MALL AND IT'S A PILOT
PROJECT TO MEASURE QUALITY
OUTCOMES WE THINK HAT'S A
CRITICAL COMPONENT. I AGREE
WITH EVERYONE ELSE YOU CANNOT
LEAVE THIS EIGHT POINT TWO
SUNSETTING MANY PROVIDERS HAVE
GIVEN THOSE BONUSES OR THEY'VE
USE THAT TO RECRUIT STAFF COULD
YOU IMAGINE. WE END UP HAVING
TO CUT WAGES AFTER EVERYTHING'S
THESE THESE DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS HAVE DONE WE ALSO
NEED A LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE
FUNDED THIS HAS BEEN AN
ONGOING. CONVERSATION WE
APPRECIATE IS STILL HAPPENING.
BUT I ALSO REALLY WANTED IN
WITH THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT FOR ME AS A PROVIDER WHO.
WHO DOES SUPPORTED LIVING
SERVICES WE CANNOT MAKE
ISOLATION A HABIT. OUR
COMMUNITY HAS FOUGHT TO GET
ISOLATION FOR THIRTY YEARS THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS ARE
CLOSED AS WE MOVE TOWARDS THIS
NEW NORMAL WE MUST STAY
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING A
PERSON'S CHOSEN WAY OF LIFE.
AND HAVING FULL INCLUSION IN
THE IN THE COMMUNITY SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS I TALK
REALLY FAST BECAUSE. I WAS TOLD
TO SELL. THANK YOU- WE HAVE
JUDY PRESS. OF DISSENT VOICES
UNITED. THANK YOU DOCTOR ON A
LOT THANK YOU MANY MEMBERS I'M
JUDY MARC I'M A PROUD MOM OF
JOSHUA WHO'S TWENTY FOUR AND
HAS AUTISM I'M ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED STATEWIDE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION DIRECTED BY PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY
BUT HOPEFULLY YOU'VE SAVED THE
BEST FOR LAST I AM HONORED TO
TESTIFIED TODAY BECAUSE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT YOU LISTEN FIRST
AND HOPEFULLY NOT LAST TO THE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. AS THE PENALTY
WAS GIVEN THE GAME AND ONE WHO
CAN NEVER RETIRE FROM
ADVOCATING FOR MY SON AND
OTHERS I HOPE TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE REALITIES WE FACE IN
ACCESSING SERVICES. DURING THE
PAST PANDEMIC. VOICES UNITED
HAS LISTEN TO SELF ADVOCATES
AND FAMILIES THROUGH TWENTY TWO
WEBINARS IN A STATEWIDE SURVEY.
HERE'S WHAT WE LEARNED AND SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVING
OUR SERVICES TO. NUMBER NE
DIRECTIVES FROM DDS ARE NOT
GETTING DIRECTLY TO FAMILIES.
WE WERE GRATIFIED THE DDS
ISSUED AN ARRAY OF DIRECTIVES
GETTING INDIVIDUALS BY A
VITALLY NEEDED FLEXIBILITY. FEW
HOWEVER HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
THEM BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
INFORMED OR WERE DENIED THE
SERVICE. FOR EXAMPLE DDS DATA
SHOW THAT VERY FEW FAMILIES
HAVE ACTUALLY USED FOR
DISSIDENT DIRECTED SERVICES IN
THE PAST YEAR. NUMBER TWO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR CONTINUE
TO FACE SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES. ARE RECENT
ANALYSIS OF POS DATA SHOWS THAT
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES
PERSIST DESPITE FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO COMBAT THIS
PROBLEM. LET'S YOU KNOW
CONTINUE TO FACE THE GREATEST
DISPARITIES GETTING ONLY 42% OF
WHAT WHITES RECEIVED MAKE IT
STATEWIDE LAST FISCAL YEAR. NOT
A SINGLE REGIONAL CENTER IS
MAKING SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS.
AND MOST ARE MOVING BACKWARDS.
AND WE FEARED DISPARITIES HAVE
BEEN DISASTER BY THE CANTON.
THERE NEEDS TO BE CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS AND CONSEQUENCES
FOR REGIONAL CENTERS WHO ARE
NOT MAKING PROGRESS ON
ELIMINATING DISPARITIES. NUMBER
THREE THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM IS BEING BLOCKED BY
LAYERS OF UNNECESSARY
BUREAUCRACY. THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM WAS
TAILOR MADE FOR A PACK THOSE IN
THE PROGRAM HAD THE FLEXIBILITY
TO DO UNIQUE THINGS TO MAKE
THEM HAPPY HEALTHY AND SAFE.
IMPLEMENTATION BARRIERS HAVE
BEEN SO GREAT THAT FEWER THAN
20% OF FEES AND PARTICIPANTS
HAVE MOVED INTO THE PROGRAM.
DDS MISTER PROVIDE MORE
OVERSIGHT AND CLEAR DIRECTION I
REGIONAL CENTERS NEED TO REDUCE
BUREAUCRACY IN ORDER TO
ELIMINATE BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATION ESPECIALLY IF THE
PROGRAMS TO FULL IMPLEMENTATION
IN LESS THAN FIVE MONTHS. THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM
WHICH THE LEGISLATURE CREATED
EIGHT LONG YEARS AGO MUST BE
ALLOWED. TO FULFILL ITS PROMISE.
NUMBER FOUR THE NEEDS OF MANY
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
NOT BEING BACKED INTO THE ONTO
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES MODEL.
WELL DDS QUICKLY DEVELOPED THE
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO SUSTAIN THE
PROVIDER NETWORK WE HAVE NOT
YET SEEN DATA ON CONSUMER
SATISFACTION WITH ALTERNATIVE
SERVICE. BEFORE THE SYSTEM WAS
LAUNCHED HEADWALL PROVIDERS
WERE STILL BEING FULLY PAID
GIVING YOU AND OTHERS CONDUCTED
SURVEYS. AND FOUND THAT ONLY
HALF OF THE INDIVIDUALS AND
CLOSED PROGRAMS WILL CONTINUE
TO RESTART RECEIVE SERVICE. DO
YOU HAVE REGIONAL CENTERS WE TO
ENSURE THAT SERVICE PROVIDERS
ARE ACTUALLY MEETING THE NEEDS
OF CLIENTS. FOR MANY A THIRTY
MINUTE ZERO CLASS EVERY DAY IS
NOT ENOUGH. WE HAVE SEEN THAT
THERE IS A SAFE WAY TO PROVIDE
IN PERSON INDIVIDUAL I SERVICES
AND CONSUMERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THAT NOW. THE IRONY IS
THAT AS AWFUL AS THE LAST YEAR
IS BANNED WE HAVE PRESENT WE'VE
BEEN PRESENTED WITH
OPPORTUNITIES TO FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE OUR SYSTEM. TO BE MORE
PERSON CENTERED AND OUTCOME
DRIVEN. THIS IS THE TIME TO
MOVE AWAY FROM PROVIDING
SERVICES IN CONGREGATE SETTINGS
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF THE DANGERS
OF PENTAX. BUT BECAUSE OF THE
IMPENDING AGE CBS RULE. THE
SETTINGS MUST BE PERSON
CENTERED AND COMMUNITY BASED TO
RECEIVE FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS
IN TWO SHORT YEARS. IT JUST
MAKES SENSE TO FOCUS ON HELPING
PROVIDERS MAKE THE CHANGES
NECESSARY TO COMPLY WITH THE
RULE BEFORE THE- INSTEAD OF
LETTING THEM RETURN TO PRE
PANDEMIC OUTDATED SERVICE.
ULTIMATELY WE NEED A SYSTEM
WHERE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
COME FIRST IN THE PAST YEAR
PROVIDERS GOT PAID IN ORDER TO
SUSTAIN THE SERVICES STAFF
REGIONAL CENTERS MAINTAIN THEIR
OPERATIONS BUT MANY FAMILIES
HAD TO BEG FOR MORE HOURS A
RESPITE OR DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
THEY CAN ASK FOR HELP DURING A
CRISIS. I HOPE MY TESTIMONY
MAKES CLEAR THAT OUR SYSTEM IS
UPSIDE DOWN. WHAT WE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN REGIONAL CENTRES
WE MUST FOCUS ON IMPROVING OUR-
ELIMINATING RACIAL THIS RACIAL
DISPARITIES AND MEETING THE
PANDEMIC NEEDS A FAMILIES TO
SELF DETERMINE ANY SELF
DETERMINATION AND FLEXIBILITY.
THE SYSTEM IS OURS. BUT
SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T FEEL THAT
WAY PARTICULARLY IN THE FAST
PAST YEAR. MY ORGANIZATIONS
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND HE ASKED TO
MEET THESE CHALLENGES TO
MEANINGFULLY IMPROVE OUR SYSTEM
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAS AND SEE IF MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'M- LIKE TO GO TO
A DRUG DEPARTMENT. WITH A
QUESTION HOME. THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF- ANGST IN THE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY WHEN THEY LOOK AT-
THE POSSIBILITY INAPE THEY FEEL
THAT THERE'S A DIRECT OF COMING
OR SOME KIND OF- ISSUE COMING
WITH THE- AVOIDERS A GOT THE
PPP. AND THAT THERE WAS GOING
TO BE A PENALTY FOR RECEIVING
THAT THAT YOU WOULD BE REDUCING
PAYMENTS TO THOSE PROVIDERS-
BECAUSE- THEY THEY HAD THIS
HELP. YOU KNOW THIS WAS TO HELP%
INCENTIVIZE AND KEEP EMPLOYEES
PAY LEASES AND- RANTON ALL OF
THESE THINGS I'M- THROUGH THIS
ALREADY UNDERFUNDED. SYSTEM I'M
HOPING THE DDS RECOGNIZES THAT
THERE WAS INTENDED TO KEEP
PEOPLE SOLVING KEEP PEOPLE
EMPLOYED IN AND NOT PENALIZE
THESE PROVIDERS FOR. GETTING
THIS THIS HELP I'M ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FOUGHT
THROUGH THE ADMINISTRATION OR
OR- FINANCE THAT THE
POSSIBILITY OF BEING TAXED ON
THIS THROUGH THE STATE I KNOW
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ISN'T
TAXING BUT IF. IF THE STATE IS
CONSIDERING TAXING THE P. P. P.
THEN WE REALLY DIMINISH THE
ABILITY TO HELP PEOPLE WHEN WE
START CONTINUALLY TAKING THIS.
APPROACH SO THAT WAS MY FIRST
QUESTION TO DIRECTOR BARGING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER- THE ISSUE- YOU COULD
USE OF SAID PAYMENT PROTECTION
PROGRAM THE FUNDING- AS IT
RELATES TO THE TIME PERIOD IN
WHICH- RETAINER PAYMENTS WERE
PROVIDED TO SERVICE PROVIDERS-
HAS COME TO QUESTION AND AS FAR
AS HOW DO YOU I'M PROVIDERS BUT
ALSO THE STATE AND THEN THIS IS
GOING TO QUESTION THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED EVEN ON FEDERALLY- YOU
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NOT A
DUPLICATION OF PAYMENT FOR SAME
TYPE. OF EXPENDITURES- SO
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE FURTHER
CLARITY- WE ARE WORKING ON
CLARIFYING ARE- FAQS TO THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE IT IT DOES APPEAR
TO BE- THAT THERE ARE SOME
QUESTIONS FROM OUR COMMUNITY
THAT WE CAN ASSIST WHAT- BY
PROVIDING THAT CLARITY- WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE AREAS
IN WHICH- PROVIDERS HAVE ACCESS
TO THOSE RESOURCES THAT WERE.
MADE AVAILABLE FROM THE STATE
AS WELL AS A FEDERALLY FUNDED
THOSE RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE-
AND IF THERE'S ANY KIND OF
CLARITY ON THE PROTECTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE MADE- WELL WE'RE
WORKING TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT THAT CLARITY TO IT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE. LESS
CONFUSION. ARE NO CONFUSION IF
WE CAN GET THERE. I APPRECIATE
THAT- MY NEXT QUESTION IS TO
THE OF FINE. I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU BROUGHT UP WAS
THE- THE MINIMUM WAGE A
COMPONENT. AND I THINK WE'RE IN
THE FIRST PANEL LISA CLIMB UP
HAD MENTIONED THE HIGHER COST
OF LIVING IN OTHER REGIONS AND
THERE ARE THE HIGHER. THE
HIGHER MINIMUM WAGE ADJUSTMENTS
THAT ARE MADE AND SOME PEOPLE
GET PAID MORE AND SOME PEOPLE
GET PAID LESS- NO THIS IS A
LEGISLATURE YOU WAS THE AND YOU
KNOW VERY RESOUNDING SUPPORT
FOR INCREASING THE MINIMUM WAGE
STATEWIDE. IN THREE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF GOING FORWARD ABOUT
TWO AND TO NOT ACKNOWLEDGE THE
COST OF LIVING IN CERTAIN
AREAS. AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ACTUALLY GOOD KNOWLEDGE IN THAT
AND TRYING TO HELP THE WORK
FORCE. WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT AND MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S TECHNOLOGY UNFUNDED
IN THIS PROGRAM IN THIS IN THIS
BUDGET CYCLE I MEAN. SERIOUSLY
WE HAVE A HARD ENOUGH TIME
KEEPING ON A WORK FORCE GOING
BECAUSE AS IT WAS MENTIONED BY
ONE OF THE ADVOCATES. IS
PRIMARILY A HELLO IN THE
PROVIDERS WORKFORCE THE
WORKFORCE THEMSELVES. A MINIMUM
WAGE JOB AND DURING THIS
PANDEMIC IN THE CHARISMATIC AND
ALL THE THINGS WITH HIM GOING
TO PLUMMET IT'S ACTUALLY BEEN
MORE BENEFICIAL FOR THE WORK
FORCE TO GO GET UNEMPLOYMENT
THAT ACTUALLY WORK FOR THE- THE
FOLKS. ARE GOING FOR BECAUSE
THEY MAKE MORE MONEY.
UNEMPLOYMENT AND SO- BUT WOULD
HOPE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
THROUGH THE FINANCE AND BUDGET
WITH OUR COMMITTEE ACKNOWLEDGED
THE MINIMUM WAGE HAS TO BE
ACKNOWLEDGED IN THE
JURISDICTIONS THAT THAT
ACTUALLY IT IS HIGHER. CAN YOU
OF KIND OF. ELABORATE ON THE
SENSE OF WHY EXIST ACROSS THE
BOARD. I THANK YOU SOME NUMBER-
STEVEN PUBLIC DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO NO WE WELCOME THESE
DISCUSSIONS AT AND SAY THAT YOU
KNOW GROWING THE MAGICIAN HAS
NOT WANTED- YOU KNOW WAGE
INCREASES THAT HAVE BEEN DRIVEN
BY A LOCAL- MINIMUM WAGE
DECISIONS WELL THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES- PROPOSES AND
STATED. HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
MILLION TOTAL FIND- BUT THAT IS
THE ONLY ADJUSTMENT- THERE'S
BEEN PROVIDED FOR SB THREE
MINIMUM. WAGE THE GOVERNMENT
WHAT IT. OKAY BUT AND I JUST
WANNA. THAT MY STAFF KIND OF
DID A HISTORIC BUDGET ANALYSIS
FOR THE LAST THIRTY YEARS. AND
IN NINETEEN NINETY BETWEEN
NINETEEN NINETY AND NOW PRESENT
TIME TWENTY TWENTY. WE'RE
ACTUALLY PAYING THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS LESS PER CONSUMER THAT
WE WERE IN NINETEEN NINETY WHEN
COMPARED OF DOLLARS. AND SO YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT OTHER
COMPONENTS OF THE BUDGET WERE.
THE CALIFORNIA PRISON SYSTEM
MORE SPENDING SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE PER
PRISONER BUT WE'RE ONLY PAYING
WORK AT THIS POINT IN THAT.
THIS IS WHAT MY STAFF IS
PROVIDED TO ME IN TWENTY TWENTY
DOLLARS WE'RE SPENDING ABOUT
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER CONSUMER. AND SO WE NEED TO
LOOK AT AND AS OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED. UNDERSTANDING OF THE
RATE STUDY CAME OUT A KNOWLEDGE
UNDER FUNDING OF SERVICES AND
MONEY. AND GOING FORWARD WITH
THE AND KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT
THE WE HAVE LIVED OFF THE BACKS
OF THIS POPULATION ON EVERY
RECESSION EVERY CUT BACK
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE DONE. AND
I'M YU KNOW A SHAME THAT WE
HAVE DONE THAT. BUT WE NEED TO
STEP UP AND IGNORES IT. IT
COSTS MORE IN TODAY'S DOLLARS
TO PROVIDE. THE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES ARE REQUIRED THE
CENSUS HAS GROWN DRAMATICALLY
AS IT SAYS IN THIS BUDGET I
THINK IT'S FIFTEEN THOUSAND
MORE PEOPLE IN IN THE SYSTEM.
BUT YET WE TALK ABOUT. NOT
SUSTAINING. PROGRAMS IN ALL OF
THESE THINGS AND WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE SO I'M I'M
HOPING THAT WE CAN FIND. A
COMMON GROUND THAT THE ASSESS
THE TASTE AND I'M GOING TO BE
INTRODUCING AN ACA THAT
REQUIRES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE SAME KIND OF
SIMILARITY IS PROP NINETY EIGHT
FOR EDUCATION. IS THAT WE HAVE
TO FUND AS A BASIC LEVEL OF
FUNDING HOPEFULLY INCLUDING THE
RATE STUDY- THAT'S COME TO
CONCLUSION THROUGH COMMITTEE
AND ALL OF THAT. AND AND
FINANCE BUT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO PROTECT THIS COMMUNITY. AND
BY DOING SO WITH THIS AC I'M
HOPING THAT WE CAN FIND THAT
COMMON GROUND. AND STEP FORWARD
AS THE OTHER ADVOCATES OF SAID.
YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME VERY
SHINING MOMENTS IN THIS IN THIS
WORLD PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HELPED
BUT THERE ALSO IS THE DISPARITY
COMPONENT. HAVEN'T WE NEED TO
FIND A COMMON GROUND AND GET
THAT MONEY OUT THERE TO THE
PEOPLE. AN INCREASE. THE MONEY
FOR THE WORK FORCE BECAUSE THE
WORKFORCE IS SORELY SORELY
UNDERPAID FOR WHAT THEY HAVE TO
DO. THAT WAS DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DO YOU WISH TO COMMENT. I SEE
MOBILE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
YEAH ONCE AGAIN I AND WE'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS THROUGHOUT THE
BUDGET PROCESS. THANK YOU.
CANCEL ONE OF THE THINGS I'D
LIKE TO GO BACK TO OUR REGIONAL
CENTER- ERICA'S EGGMAN IF YOU
WOULD COME UP ABOARD AND SO I
COULD ASK MORE QUESTIONS. WHAT
WHEN WE HAVE THE- DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS AND THE
ADULT GROUP HOMES. I'M HEARING
THAT THERE IS. ACTUALLY THERE.
ONE OF THE PROVIDERS THAT HAVE
BEEN HARDEST HIT. AND WHO ARE
GOING OUT OF BUSINESS HOW ARE
WE ADAPTING TO THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL PLACEMENTS. IN YOUR
AREA OR YOU KNOW WE DON'T WITH
THE DEMISE OF THE THEY WERE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND NO
BACKUPS WHAT ARE WE DOING WHEN
SOMEBODY HAS NO ABILITY WHERE
THEY CAN'T GET EMPLOYEES TO DO
IT ANYMORE WHAT WHAT'S THE
BACKUP WHAT'S THE PLAN B. FOR
THESE FOR THESE- ADULTERANTS
QUOTED PERIOD. BOB MERRICK
SICKENING GOLDEN GATE REGIONAL
CENTER THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER FOR THE QUESTION- IT'S
COMPLICATED OF COURSE WE
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY KIND OF MASS-
CLOSURES OF HOMES FOR SURE WE
WOULD HAVE AS I SAID PREVIOUSLY
TO STAND THEM THROUGH. HEALTH
AND SAFETY FUNDING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT WHICH IS JUST
INCREDIBLE- IT IS A MATTER OF
DEVELOPING OTHER MODELS- IN
ADDITION TO A LICENSED GROUP
HOMES HOMEOWNERS SUPPORTED
LIVING AS JACKIE TALKED ABOUT
AND- FAMILY OKAY AGENCY AN IOS
SERVICES. SPECIALIZED
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES ARE NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT MODELS THAT ARE
CONSTANTLY BEING- DEVELOPED AN
EVEN TEN MINUTES THE PANDEMIC
WE'VE STILL HAD SOME OUT REACH.
OF PEOPLE AMAZINGLY WANTING TO-
START SERVICES ON THE OTHER
SIDE I HAVE HEARD SOME
ANECDOTAL YOU KNOW EVIDENCE
THAT- PROVIDERS HAVE TAKEN THIS
OPPORTUNITY ESPECIALLY AT THE
END OF. MAYBE THEIR CAREER IN
GROUP HOMES TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RETIRE- WHICH
HAS- HAS CREATED DEFINITE
CHALLENGES. ONE OF THINGS WE
DON'T HAVE IN THIS SYSTEM WHICH
WE WOULD LOVE TO WORK. ON IS
SOME KIND OF RESCUE HOUSING
WHERE AN OWNER OPERATED GROUP
HOME- DECIDES IT'S THE END OF
THEIR TWENTY OR THIRTY OR MORE
YEAR TEN YEAR OF BEING ABLE TO
SUPPORT THEIR INDIVIDUALS. WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE A MECHANISM
TO RESCUE THAT HOUSING UNLESS
THAT- OWNER OPERATOR HAS
SOMEONE ELSE USUALLY IN THE
FAMILY TO PASS IT ON TO IT SO-
THAT OBVIOUSLY IS. PART OF THE
SOLUTION AND AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE HOUSING IS A HUGE
PART OF THE SOLUTION I THINK
IT'S- AS WE MOVE INTO THE
FUTURE SET ASIDE FOR PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AND- AND- AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE HOUSING A MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT HAS- OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES HAS
SUPPORTED IN MANY AREAS
INCLUDING OURS. WILL BE. A
ANOTHER PART OF. RELATING NEW
UP. FOR FIVE. AS WELL AS MAYBE
SOME M. STARTED TO YOUR ARM
IS ALL YOU KNOW WHAT IN THE
SHORT TERM- WE DON'T HAVE A
GOOD WAY IT'S BEEN STATED MANY
TIMES THIS AFTERNOON. OF HAVING
KIND OF UNIFIED CONSISTENT DATA
WITHIN THIS- WITH THIS WITHIN
THIS SYSTEM SO- I KNOW OUR
CREDENTIALS OF A STUDY OF
CLOSURES OF. PROGRAMS EVERY
YEAR- BUT IT TAKES TIME FOR
THAT TO SHOW ANY KIND OF-
STATEWIDE DATABASE VIEW OF HOW
MANY. HOMES ARE PROVIDERS ARE
REALLY CLOSING SO- I THINK
THROUGH ALL THE EFFORTS MY
FEELING IN OUR AREA WHICH IS
EXTREMELY HIGH COSTS SORT OF
GROUND ZERO FOR HIGH COSTS. IN
THIS IN THE STATE IN THE
COUNTRY- THE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY- SOMEONE ALREADY
MENTIONED HAS BEEN LIMPING
ALONG AND- AND- DOING THE BEST
THEY CAN- BUT ARE CERTAINLY
VULNERABLE ESPECIALLY SMALLPOX
WILL PROVIDERS WHO DON'T. HAVE
A CONNECTION TO LARGER
ORGANIZATIONS BUT MAYBE MAYBE
PROVIDING SOME OF THE MOST-
SOME OF THE MOST INNOVATIVE
AND- RESPONSIVE. PERSON CENTRED
SERVICE SINCE. THANK FOR THAT.
MISTER KERRISON WHO MENTIONED
YOU KNOW I'LL BE INTRODUCING
THE NACA TO CREATE A LEVEL
FUNDING FOR THE SPECIAL NEEDS
POPULATION THROUGH DAS BUT
ALSO CERTIFICATION PROCESS
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SO WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A
WORKFORCE THAT ACTUALLY HAS A
CERTIFICATE AND WE CAN
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MAKE MORE MONEY
BECAUSE OF THIS TRAINING THIS.
LOWER WAGE- IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
CARING FOR THE VULNERABLE
POPULATION AND WE EXPECT. WE
DON'T DO THAT TO ARGUE OR AGING
POPULATION WE DON'T DO IT TO
ANYBODY ELSE BUT WE DO IT TO
THE SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATION
WHICH IS A SHAME IT'S A REALLY
A SHAME SO WE'LL BE LOOKING I'M
HOPING THAT WE ALL CAN COMBINE.
ON THIS COULD BE A COMMITTEE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SURFACE
WORKFORCES AND KNOWLEDGE AND
PAID A LIVING WAGE. THANK YOU.
I'M GOING TO- BEGIN MY COMMENTS
BY ACTUALLY THANKING YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER FOR
BEING A LONGTIME CHAMPION IN
THIS SPACE AND- JUST WANT TO.
EXTEND A PERSONAL APPRECIATION
FOR YOUR ADVOCACY HERE TODAY.
I'M GONNA FOCUS MY COMMENTS- IN
FOUR AREAS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION FIRST ON THE
SUSPENSION POLICY NEXT ON
PROVIDER RETENTION. ON THE-
THIRD ON THE NEXT STEPS IN THE
RIGHT STUDY AND FINALLY ON THE
COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR PROPOSAL.
I'M GONNA BEGIN ON THE
SUSPENSION POLICY AND- THE
QUESTION IS FOR YOU DIRECTOR
BARGE MAN I'M- REALLY WANTING
TO DIG IN A LITTLE BIT I THINK
WE HEARD CLEARLY TODAY THAT
SUSPENSION CREATES UNCERTAINTY
AND ANXIETY. WHEN WE NEED
STABILITY. IT'S WITH THAT IN
MIND THAT I WANTED TO ASK YOU
WHAT WOULD BE THE IMPACT OF THE
PROVIDER AND IDT COMMUNITY. IF
THE SUSPENSION POLICY WENT INTO
EFFECT EITHER ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
OR DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND HOW DOES THIS
RECONCILE WITH ALL OF THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC. TO HELP TO PRESERVE
THE DDS PROVIDER NETWORK. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- REGULAR
DOCTOR AMBULANCE- I DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION HERE BUT HAPPY
TO PROVIDE THAT TO YOU SO WE'LL
WE'LL HAVE OUR OUR TEAM- TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT DETAIL AND PROVIDE
IT TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR D. O.
F. THEN IF I CAN FOLLOW UP. WHY
ARE THESE SUSPENSIONS ALL
CONCENTRATED IN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AREA- EVEN
UNDERSTANDING THE ARCHITECTURAL
CURTAILING. OF ONGOING SPENDING
Y. CONCENTRATES THIS FOCUS ON
THE MOST CRITICAL SERVICES FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
BUT STILL WELL OR NO FINANCE I
THINK YOU CHAIR FOR THE
QUESTION SO YOU KNOW I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT SINCE THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACTORS MEN
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAM
INVESTMENTS. THESE ARE COSTS
WHICH ARE LIKELY TO INCREASE A
SLOWING. GROWTH ENDING THESE
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
STRUCTURALLY BALANCED BUDGETS
SUPPORT MY ONGOING BASIS AND SO
THE SUSPENSION SPRING MARKET IS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
TO ADDRESS THIS IMBALANCE. AND
AGAIN THAT THIS IS A DIFFICULT
ISSUE AND WE WELCOME CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS LEGISLATURE THE
PROPOSAL. I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING FROM MANY OF US IS THAT
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCES A GAPING
WOUND AND THIS FEELS LIKE A
BANDAID THAT WE'RE PUTTING ON
FOR IT THESE WORK COMMITMENTS
THAT MANY OF US MADE FOR ON
GOING PROGRAMS AND- JUST WANT
TO ELEVATE AGAIN THE NECESSITY
FOR US TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THIS YEAR. I'D
LIKE TO NOW MOVE ON IF I CAN TO
THE PROVIDER RETENTION AND FOR
THE DEPARTMENT WHAT IS YOUR
BEST ASSESSMENT OF STRATEGIES
TO HELP TO RETAIN. AND KEEP THE
TALENTS THAT WE HAVE WITHIN THE
DDS WORK FORCE AND DOES IT
INCLUDE IMPROVED WAGES GROWING
THE WORK FORCE TO REDUCE THE
DEMANDS ON A SINGLE WORKER. AND
MORE FLEXIBILITIES. FOR WORK
LIFE BALANCE. THANK YOU DR
ARAMBULA YOU KNOW TALKING AND
LISTENING- CERTAINLY TO THE
PROVIDERS AND- WE ARE OUR
DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONALS
AND THEY ARE REALLY THOSE THAT
ARE WORKING DAY TODAY WITH THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE- I
STARTED MY CAREER AS A DRUG
SERVICE PROFESSIONAL- I
CERTAINLY DON'T- HAVE THE YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE THAT MANY OF THEM
HAVE DEDICATED THEIR LIVES- TO
PROVIDING THE SUPPORT AS-
JACKIE HAD SHARED EARLIER IN
HER TESTIMONY ABOUT- DOES THAT
THEY SUPPORT. AND HAVE
DEDICATED AND IT'S REALLY
SACRIFICE SOME OF THEIR TIMES
IT'S REALLY MOVING TO SEE THOSE
WORK. IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO EVALUATE OUR SYSTEM
AS IT'S BEEN- SAID TO TAKE A
LOOK AT IS THERE AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE AS- AS WE FACE THIS
PANDEMIC- AND FINDING- ARE
STRATEGIES THAT HAVE BEEN A
BENEFIT- TO BE ABLE TO HELP
NAVIGATE I. WELL I DON'T HAVE A
PARTICULAR STRATEGIES- WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH OUR-
TASK FORCE BUT ALSO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT ARE
THE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO AND
LOOKING AT OUR POST AND THEN
MAKE- FUTURE- WHAT WHAT IS KIND
OF THAT. YOU KNOW WE STARTED
THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT SIX
MONTHS AGO AND REALIZED IT WAS
TOO SOON TO BE ABLE TO AND I
THINK WE ARE ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF IT- BUT- WE NEED TO
REIMAGINE SOME EFFORTS AND
REALLY- UC'S OPPORTUNITIES TO
SAY HOW DO WE STABILIZE. THE
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM POST
PANDEMIC AND THAT SHOULD.
INCLUDE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
WORK FORCE AND- REALLY DO HOPE
THAT OUR OUR STAFF THAT ARE OUT
THERE EVERY DAY ARE GETTING
SOME WORK LIFE BALANCE BECAUSE
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A VERY
DIFFICULT. ABOUT EARLIER WE
HEARD OF THE NEED FOR US TO
BUILD BACK BETTER AND- I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT BRINGS US INTO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT NEXT STEPS
IN TERMS OF THE RATE STUDY. I
WANTED THE FIRST TASK IS THE
RATE STUDY OUR NORTH STAR HOW
ARE WE- WORKING TOWARDS
ACHIEVING THAT TRADE STUDY. AND
WHAT WOULD WHAT DIRECTIONS WITH
THE BURDEN STUDY NATURALLY
POINTS TO US AS A NEXT STEP IN
RATES IMPROVEMENTS. IF ONE
COULD BE CONSIDERED. YEAH THANK
YOU- DOCTOR AMBULANCE SO- WE
DON'T HAVE A STRATEGY OR PLAN
AT THIS TIME FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RATE
STUDY BUT AS WE HAVE. I'M USED
TO PRIOR- CONVERSATIONS IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS- WE REALLY
ARE FOCUSED ON USING THE
INFORMATION THAT HAS INFORMED
US ON SOME REALLY CRITICAL
PARTS ABOUT OUR SYSTEM- I DO
SEE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
TAKE A LOOK AT. HOW DO WE GET
TO A STRATEGY OF DELIVERING
SERVICES- IN A WAY THAT IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON OUTCOMES AND
PERSON- FOCUSED AND- THE
INFORMATION THAT HAS ALSO BEEN
PROVIDED TO US THROUGH THE RATE
STUDY IS INFORMATIVE AND SHOULD
HELP US IN IN GUIDING OUR
CONVERSATIONS- SO AGAIN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO. KIND OF DIVING INTO
SOME OF THOSE DETAILS. WE HAVE
A COMPLICATED SYSTEM. I'M AND
THAT COMPLICATED SYSTEM- GOT
MAGNIFIED BY THE PANDEMIC- AND
WE DO NEED TO PRIORITIZE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
STRATEGIES GOING FORWARD- AND
LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING IN
THOSE DISCUSSIONS WITH- OUR.
COMMUNITY AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. I FOUND IT-
POWERFUL WHEN WE HEARD EARLIER
THAT HISTORICAL UNDERFUNDING
MADE IMPLEMENTATION DIFFICULT
DURING THIS PANDEMIC I THINK
THAT'S- AN IMPORTANT PART FOR
US TO OWN AS A STATE- IN THIS
CONVERSATION AND HOPE WE CAN
TAKE TO- NEXT STEPS TOGETHER
AND- REALIZING THIS RATE STUDY
IN THE NEED FOR IT WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM. I WOULD LIKE TO END IF
I CAN ON THE COMMUNITY
NAVIGATOR PROPOSAL I WAS QUITE
PLEASED WITH IT AND- IF I CAN I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE SUB
COMMITTEE RECEIVE A COPY OF THE
PROMO TORA EVALUATION WHICH WAS
REFERENCED AS JUSTIFICATION FOR
THIS PROPOSAL. BUT WANTED TO
ASK THE- ADMINISTRATION IF I
COULD HOW DID YOU ARRIVE AT
THIS NUMBER FOR THE INVESTMENT
TEND TO THE ARGUMENT TO BE MADE
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THIS
PURPOSE AND IF NOT WHY NOT. YES
MAY BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE- THE STUDY THAT IS
REFERENCED AND I'M ON THE
ASSUMPTIONS WE CAN PROVIDE
THAT- MORE OF THE DETAIL
DISPENSED BUT BROADLY. I'LL
TELL YOU THAT WHEN WE ARE
LOOKING AT- THE PROPOSAL THAT
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
TOUCH ALL TWENTY ONE GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS AND SO THE ASSUMPTION IS
BASED ON TWENTY ONE- PHYSICIANS
IF YOU WILL AND THEN SUPPORT OF
AS FAR AS LIKE OVERHEAD AND
OTHER KIND OF SUPPORTED
ANCILLARY- EXPENSES THAT WOULD
BE RELATED TO THAT- AND THEN
ALSO LOOKING AT MAKING SURE AS
WE HAD NOTED THAT IT WOULD BE.
DIRECTED TO YOUR FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS- WHICH WOULD
BE FURTHER DEFINED THROUGH
GUIDANCE AS FAR AS- IT JUST
SMALL- IT'S ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT I WAS REALLY WANTING TO DO
WAS TO STANDARDIZE SOMETHING
ACROSS THE STATE SO WHAT WOULD
ALLOW US TIME TO BE A- ABLE TO
EVALUATE- IT WAS NOTED ABOUT
WHAT ARE THE AREAS IN WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO USE. AS OUR-
MEASURES- UP FRONT SO WE'RE
ABLE TO REALLY MONITOR THE
SUCCESS AND THE OUTCOMES ON
THAT COULD HELP INFORM US AS TO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FURTHER
EXPANSION OR MODIFICATION-
REGARDING BECAUSE I'M I AM
HOPEFUL THAT THIS IS GOING TO
BE VERY SUCCESSFUL- SO THIS
WILL HELP- BY HAVING JUST. THE
STANDARD THAT WE PUT FORWARD IT
WILL HELP US AND BE INFORMED TO
ON THE THINGS THAT WE WOULD
NEED TO MODIFY- BEFORE WE WOULD
MOVE FORWARD. WITH THAT DISHMOK
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
BARGED AS WELL AS TO ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS I WANT TO APPRECIATE-
YOUR COMMENTS HERE TODAY. AT
THIS TIME WE WILL NOW BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT AND AS A
REMINDER WE WILL WELCOME PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY ISSUE THAT'S IN
THE AGENDA. INCLUDING THE NON
PRESENTATION ISSUES. WE DO HAVE
A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND THEREFORE I WANT
TO URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS BRIEF SO THAT WE CAN
HEAR FROM EVERYONE. SINCE WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE PRESENT HERE IN
PERSON WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND AS A REMINDER OF THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE. THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS TOLL FREE. ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWENTY NINETY
NINE AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU. OPERATOR WE ARE
READY TO BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD MAYBE TRY YOUR QUESTION
AT ANYTIME BY REPEATING THE ONE
ZERO COMMAND IF YOU ARE USING A
SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE PICK UP THE
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHARE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE A COMMENT
AND OUR FIRST COMIC COMES FROM
MY EIGHTY ONE. PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME. I THINK HERE MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DONNED KHAKI.
WOULD MAKE YOU KEPT UNITS THE
OUTCOME TO HAPPEN CALIFORNIA.
REACH THAT SAYS. AND THE CHILD
OF THE PREVENTION CENTER OF
WHOM WISHED YOU CAN BASS STRAW.
SUPPORT FOR THE- CAN. NOW PER.
TO PROVIDE. TO BE RESEARCH
CENTERS SUPPORT THIS AND- FACT.
AND MODELED. EACH ARE SENATE A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF SIX K.
NOW APPROACHES SUPPORT AND NEED
TO NEEDS OF AND STATEWIDE.
SERVING AS A TRUSTED RESOURCE
AMERICA. ACROSS THE STATE
CONSTRUCTED BUILT ON OUR AND
WITH THEM OR CONVENE. INCLUDING
COLLECTED THAT MAC AND LINUX
MAY OF THE BE STATE. WE
THURMOND RECORD OF THEM.
SUCCESSFUL CONNECTION. THANK
YOU AND NOW TO OUR NEXT-
COMMENTED THAT COMES FROM LINE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FORTY FIVE. HELLO. CAN YOU HEAR
ME I COULD GO AHEAD. YES HI- MY
EMAIL MY DAUGHTER AND I AM TO
TALK I'LL BRING MY AT THIS TO
THE ATTENTION OF EDS- ABOVE THE
DIRECTOR. AND THE WASHINGTON
THE DIRECTOR THAT HAD BEEN
GIVENBY THE EDITING TWENTY
TWENTY I HAVE HAD A CONSISTENT
BLOCKAGE GOING COMING FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTERS BUT THE
DIRECTOR THERE HAS BEEN EVEN
MORE RUBBISH IS THE LATEST
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED REST THE
SEVENTH DAY. IS DIRECTING HAS
WATCHED TO BE TO LIMIT TO
BENEFIT DISABILITY COMMUNITIES
DURING THIS DIFFICULT TIME I'LL
CALL THE NINETEENTH AND THEN
MAKE DURING A CENTER CLIENTS IN
PALM IT HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
ACTIVISTS ACTED UPON DIRECT
DIRECT EXPERIMENTS TO PUT IT
EACH SEPARATE PROVIDED THEY
HAVE BEEN TRAINED AT HOME TO
WORKING OVERTIME. THIS NOVEMBER
TO PRETEND AND HAVE NOT BEEN
PAID FOR HOURS ALREADY WORK
BOMBINGS HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
MAKE IT RIGHT TO NOT CENTERS
INCLEMENT WEATHER WHAT'S
INTENDED IN THESE DIRECTORS.
WHICH WAS SENT TO MINIMIZE THE
NUMBER TO PROVIDE ITS ENTRY IN
THE FAMILY HOME SH NEED
WILLINGTON DIRECTIVES IF NOT
IMPLEMENTED BUT REGION THAT
CENTER ADJUSTMENT FOR FINALLY
DOING IT VERY DIFFICULT TIME. I
pKNOW COOLEY NINETEEN IS STILL
REAL MY FAMILY HAS BEEN A
VICTIM OF THE NINETEEN AND I AM
HERE BECAUSE GOD IS HELPING ME
BY. GIVING ME THE STRENGTH TO
KEEP GOING. I HAVE LOST MY- AND
MY YOUR WITH THAT THEY ARE PART
DUE TO COVER NINETY. THAT IS
WHY I HAVE THE URGE TO BRING MY
CHILDREN THE TWIN ALL. BY FIVE
MINUTES THEY AT HOME. BY
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
THEIR HOMES. FAMILIES NEED TO
BE. PROTECT AND NUTS NEED TO BE
A- FOR THE BLOCK. OF THESE WELL
IN. TO IDEAS. DDS NEED TO CALL
TO. REGION OF. TO REMEDIATE
OUTGOING. WE IN. IN REGARDS OF
THE VERY IMPORTANT MATTER TO
HELPED OVER. TWENTY TWENTY WITH
NANCY. COMMITTEE AND WE KNOW
THAT WHY IS IT RESEARCH THE-
CREATED IN APPROVED THESE WERE
INTENDED DIRECTOR STEVEN
DECEMBER THIRD TWENTY. HOW A-
HOW WE SUPPORT TO KNOW THAT WE
DO KNOW HOW THEIR ARRESTED
UNDER THE PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
COACH SHE WE NAY HAD THAT
INFORMATION PROVIDED BY THE
SERVICE COORDINATORS WHO ARE
PAID TO HELP XIN DIRECTOR
COMMENTED THE INFORMING THE
OPTIONS INDIFFERENCE. BETWEEN
COATS OVERTIME WEST SPACES
MARCH TO OCTOBER IN WHAT THE
STOCK WITHOUT PREVIOUS
NOTIFICATION TO FAMILIES. I
LOVE MY SISTER LIKE I SAID IN
MY KNEE TO YOU. IN UNIT BEING
OF THESE CATASTROPHE EVENTS AND
MY FAMILY I WOULD PUT MY
CHILDREN TO RAISE. WE GET MORE
PEOPLE INTO MY HOUSEHOLD ONLY
BECAUSE NOBODY FROM THE REGION
NOT CENTER INFORMING TWENTY
FOUR MAX ABOUT. OUT OPTION
BETWEEN CODES NO ONE AFTER
GOING TO THESE TERRIFIC
SITUATION WITH WITH THEIR
PLANETARY. I TRULY BELIEVE THAT
DDS. HOBBIT HARD TO PROTECT ALL
FAMILIES. NO JUST THE ONES WHO
ARE I DEFECTED TO BE DIRECT
DIRECTED STAR B. CULT HOW DID
YOU PICK AND CHOOSE. I AM
FORCING YOU TO HELP US TO
RESOLVE THIS MATTER. REGARDLESS
OF THE DIRECTIVE DAY TO ENCODE.
IF I WILL HAVE KNOWN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CODES TRUST
ME I WOULD CHOOSE THE PARTY BUT
DIRECTOR OF RESTED STARTED LONG
TIME AGO. SHREDDING FOR MEN
SURE NO CHAIR. RESTED OUT BEING
BLOCKED BUT ORIGINAL CENTERS.
THEY SERVICE PROVIDERS OR THE
ONLY SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
FAMILIES HOW DID NOT REFUTE HEY.
THERE ARE WAITING FOR SUMMIT
FOR SO LONG BECAUSE BE RESOLVED
THE LAST POSTED. SO PLEASE I
URGE YOU TO HELP US TO RESOLVE
THESE I'M GOING MATTER. TWENTY
TWENTY FAMILIES ARE SUFFERING.
PLEASE HELP. THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT TOOK ME ONE
WITH THIRTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF OUR SEVEN THOUSAND
DIRECT SUPPORT AND REGIONAL
CENTER WORKERS I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE IN THE FACT THAT
THE QUESTIONS PRESENT IN
TODAY'S HEARING AS WELL AS YOUR
ONGOING SUPPORT FOR THE IT D.
COMMUNITY- I ALSO WANTED TO.
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MR
LINDSEY WITH THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA THAT IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF BOTH THE CONSUMERS AND
PROVIDERS IN THE SYSTEM R. ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AND
A PENNY TO THE SYSTEM IS
CRUCIAL TO SPEND TIME ON. AND
REALLY ADDRESS THE MANY ISSUES
THAT HAVE ONLY GOTTEN WORSE
DURING THE PANDEMIC SO WE
WELCOME THE COMMENTS BY-
DIRECTOR BARGE REPORTING
PARTNERING- WITH THAT ASPECT WE
ALSO SUPPORT REMOVAL OF THE
SUSPENSIONS THAT ARE LOOMING
OVER OUR HEADS AT THIS.
TEMPORARY FIX CAN'T TO BE ON
THE CHOPPING BLOCK AN HOUR IN
THE FUTURE- WHAT WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT THE SITUATION MAY BE
DOWN THE LINE AND THEN LASTLY
WE ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT ON BOTH
PROPOSALS FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN RELATED TO ADDRESSING
THE MINIMUM WAGE AS WELL AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU SIR
FOR BRINGING FORTH THE PROPOSAL
TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS- AND- A
TIP ON THE EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SERVICE COORDINATORS.
BETTER DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
BRING CASELOAD RATIOS INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. FOR IN TODAY'S.
THANK YOU MA'AM. THE COLOR PLAY.
AND THAT IS LINE SIXTY SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THANK YOU AND SINCE AND
ASSEMBLY MY NAME IS CLAIRE WILL.
AND I AM SENIOR DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENTAL WE PROVIDE
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FROM
THE SENIOR CITIZEN IN A VARIETY
pTHE PROPOSAL TO SUSPEND THE
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE INCREASE AS
YOU OCCURRED TO THIS TO THE
CONCERNED FOR ALL OF US. I
WOULD JUST IN THE FUNDING WOULD
BE DETRIMENTAL TO CALIFORNIA
THIS SYSTEM HAS BEEN
UNDERFUNDED FOR YEARS. WHICH IS
DELINEATED IN THE STATE STREET
STUDY OUTLINING A ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS TO
SHOWCASE AND THANK. THE
SUSPENSION OF THIS RATE
INCREASE THAT WE RECEIVE. WOULD
BE A DIRECT. ON THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE SEVENTH
IS PREVENTING GOT THE PROVIDE
IS TO INVEST IN THE FUTURE
ENHANCEMENTS. SUCH AS
TECHNOLOGY HAS SOME PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT PROGRAM THAT CAP AND
HAMPTON THE MUPPET TYPICALLY IT
WILL ADDRESS ISSUES AS IT
RELATES TO OUR STAFF WAGES. WHO
ARE ESSENTIAL TO THE SEVEN IS
THAT WE PROVIDE. CALIFORNIA
MENTAL GAVE NECESSARY WAGE
INCREASES TO ALL OF US THAT
WHEN WE RECEIVE THIS RATE
INCREASE LAST YEAR. IT WAS AN
IMPERATIVE THING FOR US TO DO
TO RETAIN OUR STAFF AND RECRUIT
QUALIFIED EMPLOYEES AND ADDRESS
ANY WAGE COMPRESSION ISSUE. I
CAN'T IMAGINE THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO ALLOW WILL GO BACK TO
THOSE EMPLOYEES AND ADDRESS
THEIR WAGES. THEY ARE.
CURRENTLY UNDERPAID DOES THAT
IS. I WOULD AFTER THE- TO
SUSPEND THE RATE. INCREASE BE
REJECTED. NATHAN NEEDS TO THE
STATE US. AND WE DO NOT WANT TO
SEND THE MESSAGE THAT WE ARE
JUST TEMPORARY. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SHOW MY CONSENT.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND THAT COMES FROM
LINE EIGHTY TWO LINE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS NOT ONLY AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
NETWORK WE ARE STATEWIDE
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION WITH
OVER ONE HUNDRED PROVIDER
MEMBERS REPRESENTING SUPPORTED
LIVING INDEPENDENT LIVING
RESPITE PERSONAL ASSISTANT AND
EMPLOYMENT. THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THANKS TO ALL OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY FROM OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY TO KEEP PEOPLE
HEALTHY IN PAPER UP WITH
CONTENT THEM BACK. WE ALSO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND APPRECIATE
MEDIA THE COLLABORATION PPL AND
HAS HAD AND CONTINUES TO HAVE
EVEN THAT'S DIFFICULT. AND
CHALLENGING TIME. AN ECHO OF
THE PREVIOUS IN ON IN PREVIOUS
COMMENT ON WOMEN THANK THAT
LANGUAGE IN THE IN POINT 2%
RATING IN. COULD THE TABLE I
THINK A PUBLIC HEALTH. ALSO THE-
CHAPTER RICK ARE VIDEO DIRECT
WHILE WELLINGTON. IN AND-
IMPLEMENT. OF DTS DIRECT IT
DOES VERY Y. VERY VERY. BY WE
THE STATE. AS A BIG WIDE.
SHOULD OPEN THE WITH FALL LARGE
SMALL THE IN THING WE HAVE THE
DIFFERENCES FROM OVER ONE
HUNDRED. NOW. SEE THE MAULER
PROVIDER THAT SEEM TO STRUGGLE
TO NOT. THE DIRECTED NOT THE
DIRECTOR MUST BE MORE SPECIFIC
PROVIDE SELECTED FOR. AND
SHOULD NOT BE USED AS ACT TO
THERE I'M TO COVER. IF YOU WANT
TO BE THE BILL AB EIGHT ONE BY
MOLLEN THIS BILL AS OPPOSED A
PILE PROJECT AND THE NAY. AND
USING SERVICE OUTCOMES THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICE PERFORM INSPIRED BY THE
FEELINGS WORK ON COMPETITIVE
WAGES AND THE PAINT STARTED OUT
PROJECT EVEN A PANDEMIC WE MUST
FOCUS ON THE PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE BUT AND I ON EACH
VEHICLE. BOB DIRECTOR CORPORATE.
WE MUST PAY A COMPETITIVE WAY.
IF THAT WERE THAT CONNECTS WITH
THE SERVE YAK POINT WHICH THEIR
TO WE HAVE LIFE. WE ARE WITHOUT
THEM PAY THEM ACCORDINGLY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE- TO PROVIDE
COMMENT. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER. AND THAT COMES FROM THE
LINE A NINE WE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS PATTY MORAN WITH ALPHA
RESOURCE CENTER SERVING SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY WERE APPARENT
DIRECTED FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER
STAFFED BY PARENTS A PURCHASER
FIRE LOCAL REGIONAL CENTER. I'M
HERE TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR
PROPOSAL LAST YEAR WE SERVED
OVER FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILY MEMBERS
SERVED BY TRI COUNTIES REGIONAL
CENTER IN CULVER HEALTH OF
THOSE SERVICES WERE PROVIDED TO
THOSE. WHO ARE PRIMARILY NON
ENGLISH SPEAKERS WHILE PARENT
TO PARENT SUPPORT IS THE
FOUNDATION OF ALL WE DO MOST OF
OUR RELATIONSHIP START WITH A
FAMILY MEMBER CALLING FOR HELP
WITH ACCESSING SERVICES. WE
ENSURE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
HAVE THE HELP THEY NEED TO
NAVIGATE THE VERY SYSTEMS AND
SERVICES THAT ARE IN PLACE. TO
SERVE THEM AND MY OVER THIRTY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WORKING IN
A FIELD AND HAD. OF AN ADULT
YOU DON'T KNOW IF. I PROMISE
YOU THAT FIFTY THE BECAUSE MORE
COMMON AND CHALLENGING AND
AFTER THE- COBIT OF MAKE. THE
BAY AREA YEAH WE ARE HERE TO
CONTINUE TO LESS ON WE PROVIDE
THE OF LUXURY THE THING I BY. I
AM WITH OKAY TIGHT CVS OTHER SO
I. AND RECENT OF OUR WE HAVE
WITH THEIR OFFICE. SEVEN EIGHT
FIFTY ELECTRICAL A HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT HOME. HE PROVIDED
NO WELLNESS CHECK THE NICKEL.
WITH OUR SO THAT THEY CAN THE-
TO ENSURE THOSE ANIMALS I.
APART AREA WE NEED SERVICES.
FOR THANK YOU AND THAT COMES
FROM LINE EIGHTY EIGHT LINE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
YES THANK YOU MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA CANTARELLA- AND- I AM
THE- OF REGISTERED NURSE AND A
PARENT ADVOCATE FOR DISABILITY
COMMUNITY IN THOSE WITH COMPLEX
MEDICAL NEEDS- DOCTOR ARIK.
ARAMBULA THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
UP THE IMPORTANT QUESTION
REGARDING THE VACCINE IN THE
POSSIBILITY OF MOVING THAT
MARCH FIFTEENTH DATE UP- I
HIGHLY RECOMMEND THIS OCCURRING
HERE'S WHY. IN EARLY JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY I SPENT EIGHTY
THAT THE BAD SIDE OF MY TWENTY
TWO YEAR OLD SON JOHNNY AS HE
LAY INTUBATED ON A VENTILATOR
IN THE ICU FROM AN UNKNOWN
ILLNESS. MOST LIKELY WAS COLD
IT NOW KNOWING THAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THIS WHAT NOW KNOWING
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THIS VIRUS.
I KNOW HOW FIRSTHAND HOW
QUICKLY AND SEVERELY PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AND COMPLEX MEDICAL NEEDS CAN
BECOME SICK. I FEEL STRONGLY
THAT THE VACCINE SHOULD INCLUDE
PEOPLE WITH ALL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES BECAUSE SO OFTEN
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY TO EXPRESS WHEN THEY
DO NOT FEEL WELL AND OFTEN
TIMES IT IS NOT UNTIL THEY'RE
EXTREMELY SICK. THAT THEIR CARE
GIVERS REALIZE SOMETHING IS
WRONG. I'M GRATEFUL TO BE IN
MINUTES. THAT THEY DECIDED TO
INCLUDE SOME OF OUR DISABILITY
COMMUNITY. AS WE HEARD EARLIER
SINCE DECEMBER TWO MONTHS AGO
THE DEATH RATE FOR REGIONAL
CENTER CONSUMERS HAS RISEN
SUBSTANTIALLY. WAITING UNTIL
MARCH FIFTEENTH MEANS THAT IF.
THE PERSON WITH THE DISABILITY
IS ABLE TO GET VACCINATED ON
THAT DAY IT WOULD BE A MINIMUM
OF NINE TO TEN WEEKS. BEFORE
THAT PERSON WOULD BE FULLY
VACCINATED AND SAVED FROM
SERIOUS HEALTH COMPLICATIONS.
BECAUSE OF THE LIMITED AMOUNT
OF VACCINE RIGHT NOW I WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION RECONSIDER THE
ELIGIBILITY ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND PUT A
TEMPORARY HOLD ON VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION EXCEPT FOR
ESSENTIAL FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. PEOPLE WITH MEDICAL
ISSUES WHO ARE AT HIGHEST RISK
OF BEING HOSPITALIZED AND DYING
FROM COLD IT INCLUDING- SIXTY
FIVE YEARS AND OLDER AND THOSE
WITH DISABILITIES HAVE MEDICAL
ISSUES AND OR HAVE DIFFICULTY
EXPRESSING THEIR HEALTHCARE
NEEDS. NOT ONLY WOULD THIS
PROVIDE HEALTH EQUITY FOR
DISABILITY COMMUNITY WHICH IS
SO OFTEN FORGOTTEN BUT IT WOULD
ALSO BE COST EFFECTIVE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BY
DECREASING THE AMOUNT OF ER
VISITS AND HOSPITALIZATIONS BY
MEDICARE RECIPIENTS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND THAT'S
LINE FIFTY SEVEN LINE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK
HE HAD DISCONNECTED IF YOU DID
DISCONNECT THERE A LINE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE RE QUEUE UP. AND
NOW WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT ONE
SENATOR WE LOST THAT ONE ALSO
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. HEADLINE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS ANYWHERE
PLAYING ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES JUST
FORTY FOUR YOU WANTED TO
REFLECT ON WHAT WE'VE HEARD
THIS AFTERNOON BUT INDEED THIS
WAS A TERRIBLE YEAR FOR SO MANY
BUT THAT DURING THE HNH SO
MANY PEOPLE CAME TOGETHER IN
SIGNIFICANT COLLABORATION WE
FOUND CREATIVITY AND
FLEXIBILITY. WE APPRECIATE THAT.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES.
INVESTMENT IN CRITICAL
POPULATIONS SPECIFICALLY THE
COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR PROGRAM
INVESTMENTS IN- SERVICES TO
SUPPORT FOSTER CHILDREN CRISIS
SERVICES. THE FRIEND THAT
POPULATION AND SO MANY MORE WE
APPRECIATE BUT A PRESERVATION
OF FUNDS FOR RESULT IN OUR
OPERATION. AND WITH ADDS THESE
BONDS ARE ALLOW FOR CRITICAL
WORK TO BE DONE TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES AS YOU HEARD THIS
AFTERNOON- WORKING DIFFERENTLY.
WITH A FOCUS ON COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS RESOURCES-
VACCINATION TESTING AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT COMES WITH
A. PANDEMIC OF THIS MAGNITUDE.
ALSO AGREED A MEMBER FRAZIER
FOR- SUPPORTING THE- FOR
ADDITIONAL. BUNCH TO LOWER
CASELOAD RATIOS AS YOU HEARD-
WE ARE CURRENTLY EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY SERVICE COORDINATOR SHORT
AND SO GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT IN THAT AREA. ALTHOUGH
SOME COURT- IN APPRECIATE DR
ARAMBULA WERE RAISING THE ISSUE
WAITED TO- RATHER THAN SPENDING
THE SUNSET ON PROVIDER RATE
ELIMINATING THEM BECAUSE THAT
WOULD GIVE SO MUCH MORE
CERTAINTY NOT ONLY TO SERVICE
PROVIDERS BUT TO THE PEOPLE
THAT THEY'RE SUPPORTING YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT ONLY ABOUT IS THE
PROVIDER GOING TO BE THERE NEXT
YEAR BUT ARE THEY GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE. TO SUPPORT THE
PEOPLE THAT COUNT ON THEM. ALL
SUPPORT OF MR. REQUEST RELATED
DIFFERENT WAY TO CALCULATE THE
MINIMUM WAGE- AND ADDITIONALLY-
INVESTMENT IN NUMBER GC
COORDINATION FINALLY DO YOU
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS MADE
BY- HEADACHE RELATED TO OUR
ANTIQUATED DATA SYSTEMS ON SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT POSES
FOR US AND- ONE THING THAT WE
WERE HARDLY FIFTY IN LAST
YEAR'S. BUDGET PROPOSAL WAS A
PROPOSAL TO REPLACE THE RESULT
OF THE ANTIQUATED. ACCOUNTING
SYSTEM AND- MORE DISAPPOINTED
THAT THAT WOULD MAKE IN YEAR'S
BECAUSE THIS IS AN ONGOING IS
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO- MORE
EFFICIENTLY FIVE THIRTEEN AN
INTERCOM FINANCED WITH FEDERAL
FUNDING DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. AND PROVIDE MORE
READY ACCESS TO DATA TO INFORM
THE WORK OF DECISION MAKERS SO
REALLY APPRECIATE- THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION THIS AFTERNOON I
APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS AND
YOUR- NOMINAL STAFF ORDER-
CONVENING THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION. AND MAKING IT ALL
POSSIBLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
THAT COMES FROM LINE EIGHTY SIX
LINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FOR EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERSOF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY
NAME IS SHERRY AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION. I WISH THE WEATHER
SITUATION REPRESENTING ONE
HUNDRED MEMBERS- WITH A WIDE
ARRAY OF SERVICES I WANT TO
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS- A BROTHER
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
AND SUPPORT OF OUR SYSTEM A
COMMUNITY AND- FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS THIS EVENING. HOUSE
LIMITATION APARTMENT-
INTRAPARTUM FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AND FLEXIBILITY AS
WE ALL FACED THIS VERY
DIFFICULT HERE- WE'VE BEEN-
WE'VE HEARD FROM PLENTY OF
PANELISTS TONIGHT ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN PHASED IN
DIFFERENT SERVICE TYPES WHETHER
IT'S A NATIONAL STAFFING. OF
THE SAFETY CHALLENGES FOR
HAVING COMPLETELY PAID IT CAN
NEW MODELS OF SERVICE- TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE MEETING THE NEEDS.
OF THE CLIENTS IN OUR SYSTEM- I
ENTERED MARGIN. A FEW DAYS
BUSINESS PRIVATE PARKING. TO ON
THE TARNISHES A TECHNICAL AND
CALL. TO MAKE SURE AS WE CAN
THESE OLD SIR. WERE BEST. AND
MAKING SURE SERVICES ARE MEAN
TO THE CLIENTS ON THE SO THAT.
A I THINK IT PONDERED RESULT
ASSISTANCE. AND- BUT- ONLY
THREE HORSES KIND OF IN IN A
LOT OF THE- FOR TONIGHT IS OF
THESE TAKEAWAYS IS. THE MORE
IMPORTANT IS. SORRY SO MAKING
SURE THAT CONTACT BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS RESEARCH AND- AND-
DRESSERS PROFESSIONAL OR ARE
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO MAKING
SURE WE'RE DOING THE FULL
SERVICES. AND IN MEETING THE
NEEDS OF OUR CLIENTS AND TO OUR
HEADQUARTERS IN THE MONEY- HERE
IS AROUND CONNECTING AND
PROTECT THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF
OUR SYSTEM EXCUSE AFTER ACTOR
CALL PROFESSIONAL WORK FORCE.
MAKING SURE THEY'RE ADEQUATELY
COMPENSATED. MAKING SURE THAT
POLICY IS DRIVEN TOWARD MAKING
SURE WE HAVE THAT STABILITY IN
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE
ACTING ON THE INITIAL RESEARCH
AND SO WE ARE OF COURSE
GRATEFUL AND SUPPORTER OF THE-
TO REMOVE LEVINE. A SUSPENSION
DAY FROM THE SUPPLEMENTAL RATE
INCREASES. PATTERSON FURTHER
DESTABILIZING IN A VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE FUTURE CRIME
THE MAXWELL IN THAT REGARD- WE
ALSO SPONSOR HOLDEN PROPOSAL TO
MODERNIZE. IDEAS P. WAGE
INCREASES AROUND- STATE MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASES. IT WOULD BE
PROVIDED MORE EQUITABLE SYSTEM
TO INSURE THAT. BROAD THE BROAD
SWATH OF THE STATE IS ELIGIBLE
FOR THOSE AND WE WOULDN'T SEE.
SO MUCH OF THOSE APPROPRIATED
DOLLARS TURNS TO THE SYSTEM
EACH YEAR- AND ALSO WANT TO
MENTION- CALLER ARE SUPPORT FOR
THE INCREASED. FUNDING FOR CASE
MANAGERS AND REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM. FINALLY ONE PROPOSAL
THAT HASN'T BEEN DISCUSSED- IS
A PROPOSAL WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH- AS WE LOOK TOWARD
THAT BUILDING BACK BETTER- IN
LOOKING TOWARD IMPROVING
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH. INTELLECTUAL.
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
LEARNING HOW WE CAN GET ONLY A
PORTION AND USEFUL TOOL TO MAKE
SURE YOU HAVE THE DOLLARS THAT
ARE ALREADY APPROPRIATED IN THE
STATE. I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR THE COMMISSARY AND A
SPECIAL THANK YOU FROM A SECOND
FLOOR. ACTUALLY AND- AND
QUESTIONS. FOR PANELISTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR I AT THE
THAT- APPRECIATION PROCESS
COULD NOT COLOR BLUE. THANK YOU
AND THAT COMES FROM NINE TO
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS EILEEN CROWN I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
FAMILY RESOURCE NAVIGATORS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY- WE HAVE BEEN
DOING THE- OUR COMMUNITY
NAVIGATOR PROGRAMS FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS UNDER DDS GRANTS.
AND I WANT TO STRONGLY ENDORSE
THAT THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM FOR A FAMILY- FOR US IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WE'VE WORKED
WITH VARIOUS COMMUNITIES IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES WE'VE
SERVED. BY TEANECK FAMILY
MIDDLE EASTERN FAMILY SOUTH
ASIAN FAMILIES AFRICAN AMERICAN
FAMILY. ALL WITH PEOPLE FROM
THE COMMUNITY I SPENT A VERY
EFFECTIVE- INTERVENTION FOR THE
FAMILY- IN GENERAL FAMILIES
HAVE GONE FROM HAVING ONE OR
TWO SERVICES EIGHT OR NINE
SERVICES AT THE END OF
NAVIGATION. AND WE GET
EXTREMELY STRONG REACTIONS IN
THEIR INCREASE IN THEIR
CONFIDENCE IN ADVOCATING FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
AS WELL AS THEIR INCREASE. IN
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE SYSTEMS AND
HOW THEY WORK THIS IS A REALLY
FABULOUS PROGRAM I AM SO
EXCITED TO SEE IT AND I REALLY
WANT TO ENDORSE THAT IT'S A
GREAT WAY TO HELP FAMILY. IN A
WAY THAT IS PERSONABLE THAT IS
CULTURALLY COMPETENT THAT IS
INDIVIDUAL AND THAT REALLY
MAKES A DIFFERENCE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND I
COME FROM THE LINE NINETY FIVE
LINE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I I WANT TO THANK- THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR-
THE HEARING ON THIS AND THE
IMPORTANT ISSUES- I HAVE BEEN
I'VE SPENT MOST OF MY- CAREER
ADVOCATING FOR BETTER WAGES FOR
OUR- FIRST STAFF TO PROVIDE
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND-
I THINK THIS PAST YEAR HAS
SHOWN MORE THAN EVER BEFORE
WHAT ON FONG HEROES ARE STAFF
ARE- AT. RISK TO THEIR OWN
HEALTH IN THE FAMILY HEALTH- MY
STAFF CAME TO WORK EVERY DAY
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC AND TO
PROVIDE SERVICES THEY BECAME
LIFELINES TO OUR FOLKS WHO
BECAME INCREASINGLY MORE
ISOLATED BECAUSE OF LOSS OF
JOBS BECAUSE THEY COULD
SOMETIMES SEE THEIR FAMILIES.
IF THEIR FAMILIES HAD MEDICAL
ISSUES THE AND YOU KNOW LOTS
OF- GOING TO SCHOOL- TAKING
CLASSES THEY BECAME. ISOLATED
AS WE ALL HEALTHCARE IN PLACE
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE NOTHING
REALLY ALL THAT THE HORSES THAT
MANY OF US HAVE. AND WITHOUT
JOBS IN THEIR DAILY
COMPANIONSHIP AND CHECKING IN
ON- I THINK THAT WE WOULD HAVE
SEEN EVEN MORE. SERIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES- WE ALREADY ARE
SEEING SO I AM SO PROUD OF
STAFF AND DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE SO
GROSSLY UNDERPAID SO I REALLY-
HOPE AND I'M HAPPY TO HEAR THAT
THE- COMMITTEE AND LOOKING TO
GET RID OF THE LANGUAGE OF THE
SUSPENSION- LANGUAGE. BECAUSE
WE CAN'T TAKE AWAY WHAT IS ALSO
GREATLY NEEDED WE HAVE TO GET
MORE I STRONGLY SUPPORT HOLDEN
BILL- AS A WAY TO REALLY HELP
DEAL WITH HIGH COST AREAS LIKE
THE BAY AREA- AND I ALSO- ONCE
YOU ARE AFFECTED WHAT GARY.
GUARDINI SAID ABOUT THE NEED TO
PUT MORE MONEY TOWARDS
EMPLOYMENT OUR FOLKS THE PEOPLE
WE SUPPORT ARE OFTEN THE LAST
HIRED AND FIRST FIRED SO MANY
OF OUR FOLKS HAVE LOST YOUR JOB
WE REALLY HAPPY- PUT- MONEY
THAT IS AFTER NOT BEING SPENT
NOW TO STRENGTHEN THE CIE AND
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM. AND. I
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE WORK YOU
DO THANK YOU. THANK MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU NAY
COMES FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
INTO ONE- TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ON THE FLOOR I
AM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A VERY
WITH OFFICES IN NAPA CLEARLAKE
AND SACRAMENTO- BAYBERRY IS A
CHAPTER OF THE ART OF
CALIFORNIA AND ADDITIONALLY I
AM A BOARD MEMBER FOR. THE
AMERICAN NETWORK OF COMMUNITY
OPTIONS AND RESOURCES ALSO
KNOWN AS AN COR WITH OFFICES
IN- VIRGINIA AND IN WASHINGTON
DC. I FULLY SUPPORT THE
TESTIMONY OF MY COLLEAGUES
JACQUI THOUGHT VERY WELL AND
CERTAINLY CAN'T BE ANY MORE
ELOQUENT THAN JORDAN WEDNESDAY
AND STAYED IN MY POSITION. FROM
THE VARIOUS ITEMS DISCUSSED
TODAY THE NOT LIGHT I WANT TO
LIMIT MY COMMENTS TO TWO POINTS.
FIRST IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE
RECENT EIGHT POINT TWO PERCENT.
FUNDING INCREASE NOT BE
SUSPENDED PLEASE CONSIDER IT.
AN INCREMENTAL STEPS TOWARD
ADDRESSING A ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION. DOLLAR DEFICIT- IF IT
WERE TO BE- A SUSPENDED- THAT
WOULD BE- THAT WOULD
DESTABILIZE OUR SYSTEM WITHOUT
A DOUBT. AND SECONDLY AND
LASTLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
FRAZIER MENTIONED
PROFESSIONALIZATION OF THE
WORKFORCE YES. CALL OF THE
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF ANGKOR I HAVE
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH THEM TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. SHE
RECOGNIZES THE GST AND
IDENTIFIES THAT BY THEIR VERY
OWN STANDARD OCCUPATIONAL
CLASSIFICATION. AND I CERTAINLY
DO APPRECIATE ANY WORK. I DO
APPRECIATE ANY WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TOWARDS MAKING THIS
HAPPEN AND CERTAINLY LOOK LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING MORE ABOUT
ANY WORK THAT CAN BE DONE TO
BRING THIS TO FRUITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AND LINE ONE ZERO
FOUR ONE HUNDRED AND FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ALISON CANAAN-
I'M A PROGRAM COORDINATOR AT
MERIDIAN JURORS IN MARIN
COUNTY- I WAS JUST CALLING IN
TO SUPPORT- MODERN ABOUT
MODERNIZING WAGE INCREASES FOR
DSPS- I JUST FEEL LIKE THAT
IT'S TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
ONE. AND WE ALL KNOW HOW
EXPENSIVE LICENSE WHY IS IT
THAT WE STILL VALUE CERTAIN
PROFESSIONS OVER OTHERS IN
TERMS OF PAY AND JOB
WORTHINESS. SLASH
PROFESSIONALISM- TO WORK AT THE
DSP PROVIDES IS ESSENTIAL TO
THE OVERALL WELL BEING OF OUR
CLIENTS IT'S VITAL WORK AND
IT'S IMPORTANT WORK. WHY SHOULD
THEY HAVE TO WORK TWO THREE
FOUR JOBS. TO DO THE WORK THAT
OUR CLIENTS O. SO NEEDS- OUR
CLIENT NEED WORKERS WHO WANT TO
BE THERE AND THEY DESERVE THAT-
BUT THAT'S GETTING HARDER AND
HARDER FOR ON STAFF TO DO. ON
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS SO
EXPENSIVE- SO. IT'S TIME TO
STOP THE TREND OF HISTORICALLY
LOW WAGES AND BE FORWARD
THINKING AND INNOVATIVE AND
CREATIVE AND FLEXIBLE AND
HELPING- GET. ADEQUATE
ADEQUATELY JUST TO THOSE THAT
WANT TO. BE HERE HELPING. THOSE
SO BADLY IN THE THANKS. THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE ONE ONE OR YOUR PHONE ON
MUTE. NO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. WHO HI MY NAME IS TORY
ACTION AKA I AM THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES DIRECTORATE MORE
INDENTURED AND I'M ALSO A
PARENT. I WANT TO START BY
THANKING DR ROBERT LEFT FOR
OPENING WITH THE IMPORTANT
POINT ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
SUSPENSION OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL
RATE INCREASES. AND ALSO ECHOED
THAT CONCERN THROUGHOUT THE
DISCUSSION TODAY. IT REALLY
SHOULDN'T BE HARD TO SEE WHAT
LITTLE SENSE IT MAKES TO PLAN
FOR AN END OF FUNDING FOR
SERVICES WHEN THERE IS NO
QUESTION OF FUTURE ONGOING
NEED. JUSTICE THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT A DIAGNOSIS WITH
A DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY IS A
LIFELONG DIAGNOSIS. THE NEED
FOR SERVICES JUST DOESN'T GO
AWAY IT DOESN'T GO AWAY WHEN
CIRCUMSTANCES CHANGE DURING DUE
TO A PANDEMIC. OF THE NEED WILL
NOT GO AWAY ON THE CHILDREN
SUSPENSION DATE. SIMPLY PUT
NEEDS WILL NOT SUNSET NORMAL
THEY SUSPEND. FUNDING TO ALLOW
FOR THE CONTINUED ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT SHOULDN'T
SUSPENDED EITHER THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
THAT COMES FROM LINE THIRTY
LINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AT YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. SHE WELL
OF NO RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON
JULY AND ONE TWENTY FIVE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE HUNDRED GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S JAMIE DAVIS
SIGN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF MY
ADVENTURES AND SEMAFO. I
SUBMITTED WRITTEN TESTIMONY
WHICH SUPPORTS THE- ELIMINATION
OF THE SUSPENSION OF THE RATE
INCREASE AND I JUST WANT TO
PROVIDE A POINT OF COMPARISON-
INVENTORS WAS FOUND IN NINETEEN
NINETY AND I WAS. A DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL AT THAT
TIME. AND WE STARTED AROUND
EIGHT DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS
AN HOUR WHICH WAS DOUBLE ABOUT
DOUBLE THE CALIFORNIA MINIMUM
WAGE. NOW WE'RE STARTING
EMPLOYEE TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR. WHICH IS A TOTAL
BUDGETARY STRETCH FOR US AND
HARD TO DO. AND THAT IS A YOU
KNOW FIFTEEN DOLLARS IS. BEING
CONSIDERED SORT OF A BASIC
MINIMUM WAGE THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. I THINK THAT.
WHAT I'VE SEEN OVER MY THIRTY
THREE YEARS IN THE FIELD IS. A
MOVE AWAY FROM THE IDEA OF A
PROFESSIONAL LIFE STAFF AND
WE'RE JUST REALLY TRYING TO
CLAW BACK TO THAT STATUS. AND
THAT ARE. FINANCED THAT HAVE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
DESERVE THAT. AND THEY HAVE
LIVES THAT ARE VALUABLE AND
THEY WANT MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITIES AND WITHOUT A
PROFESSIONAL WORK FORCE THIS
PAID PROFESSIONAL WAGE IT'S
JUST REALLY REALLY HARD TO DO.
SO APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND THAT
COMES FROM LIGHT NINETY FOUR
LINE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS NEVER
GONNA. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. I THINK I DON'T HAVE A
FANCY TITLE I AM JUST THE MOM
OF THE EXCEPTIONAL HUMAN BEING
WHO IS. INCREDIBLY AMAZING I
DON'T KNOW WHERE WE FAIL OR
WHERE THE SYSTEM FAILED HIM
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T FIND OUT
THAT HE WAS OPTIMISTIC UNTIL HE
WAS. A MONTH AWAY FROM BEING
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD YET HE WAS
HOSPITALIZED FOR DEPRESSION AND
ANXIETY THE PREVIOUS TWO YEARS
MORE THAN THIRTY DAYS PER YEAR.
MY QUESTION IS. I AM HAVING
TROUBLE UNDERSTANDING WHY THE
DDS. DOESN'T PROVIDE FAMILIES
WHO SPEAK SPANISH. I'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THEIR DATA AND THEY
HAVE AN AVERAGE OF 20% HISPANIC
FAMILIES NOT HAVING SERVICE
THAT. I SPEAK ENGLISH AND THE
FIRST YEAR OF SERVICE ALL I GOT
THE MEDIA. WAS A YEARLY PHONE
CALL AND ASSESSMENT TELLING ME
MY SON. HAD A DISABILITY THAT
HIS THAT THERE WILL BE LESS APT
AT THEM. AND THAT WAS PRETTY
MUCH IT I HAVE TO FIGURE IT OUT
ON MY OWN A 100% THE ROUTE.
ADVOCATING WITH THE WITH DONALD
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO GET HIM
THE SERVICES. I WAS WAITING FOR
ABA THERAPY BY- REGIONAL CENTER
THEN I FOUND THAT IT WAS
THROUGH MY OWN INSURANCE.
PLEASE THERE HAS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY- EDS- ALL RIGHT
NOT TEDIOUS REGIONAL PARTNERS
THAT HAVE TWO HUNDRED TO DO THE
S. WHY ISN'T THAT A LOT OF
DAMAGE THEM BENESCH SPEAKING
FAMILIES. OR HISPANIC FAMILIES
BECAUSE I SPEAK ENGLISH MY SON
SPEAKS ENGLISH WE ONLY GOT THE
FIRST MONTH THE FIRST YEAR THE
SECOND. YEAR WHAT WE DID AND
THAT ANYTHING. THIS IS OUR
THIRTY YEAR AND LITTLE LEAGUE.
ALL WE GOT WAS RESPITE HOURS
AND I GOT THE REST BUT OURS
BECAUSE I CALL AND ASK FOR THEM
BECAUSE I HEAR FROM OTHER I
HAVE MET WITH THE OTHER PARENT.
AND THEY WERE TELLING ME THERE
WAS ALL THIS. FOR AVAILABLE AND
I HAVE LOST MY JOB I WAS GOING
CRAZY TRYING TO PROVIDE FOR MY
FOR MY FAMILY. AND THERE WAS SO
MUCH OUT THERE AND THEY DIDN'T
CALL ME. I REALLY NEED YOU GUYS
IN POWER YOU GUYS TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOMETHING TO
PLEASE ASK THEM AND SO WHO ARE
THOSE PEOPLE ARE NOT GETTING TO
REDUCE BIAS THAT THAT THE
HISPANIC. POPULATION ONE OUT OF
FOUR DO NOT WANT SERVICE IN ONE
YEAR PLEASE HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE THAT IS NOT
RIGHT THAT THERE ARE SERVICES
AND RESOURCES FOR US FOR
FAMILIES TO KEEP THEM THANK.
AND THAT THEY'RE NOT TO. THOSE
FAMILIES PLEASE. ONLY LOOK AT
THE BIG NUMBERS LOOK AT HOME IS
NOT GETTING SERVICES. PLEASE
LOOK INTO THAT AND I AM GETTING
PHONE CALLS BECAUSE I WILL BE
ABLE TO ADVOCATE FOR MY CHILD.
HOURS OF WORK BUT I'M GETTING
CALLS FROM OTHER MOMS ARE
TELLING ME THAT THERE FOURTEEN
YEARS ARE SAYING THAT THE
DIRECTIVE ARE OPTIONS THAT THEY
WERE NOT. I GUARANTEE AND
THEY'RE OFFERING TWENTY HOURS A
SERVICE THE ONE THERE'S MORE
THAN THAT PLEASE. EVERY FAMILY
THAT IS NOT RECEIVING 50% OF
THE ALLOWED IT HOURS PLEASE
REACH OUT TO THEM AND ASK THEM
WHAT DO THEY NEED BECAUSE WE DO
NEED SERVICE BUT- BUT THE
HISPANIC COMMITTEE COME FROM.
IN MY OWN FAMILY WE HAD OUT
THIS AND WE DIDN'T COLLECT
THAT. MY GRANDMOTHER'S BROTHER.
HE NEVER MARRIED NEVER WENT OUT
OF THE HOUSE BECAUSE-
APPARENTLY HE WILL THOUGHT THAT
THE NORTH NONVERBAL AUTISTIC
MAIL. THAT NUMBER WILL
DIAGNOSE. AND ALL HE DID WAS
LIVE WITH HIS MOTHER AND TO THE
DAY HE PASSED AWAY. NOW I KNOW
WHAT THAT IS. AND I'M NOT GONNA
STOP MY SON FROM LIVING A FULL
LIFE. BUT WITHOUT SERVICES
WITHOUT A BREAKING THE SILENCE.
IT'S NEVER GONNA HAPPEN SO WE
CANNOT FIND OUT OR CULTURAL
DIFFERENCES AND HELP BIRDS
BECAUSE- IT CANNOT BE THAT
PEOPLE LIVE IN THE CONDITIONS.
THERE'S MONEY ALLOCATED TO THEM
AND THEY DON'T GET NOTHING AND
DON'T LET A CULTURAL BARRIER A
LANGUAGE VERY ME THAT DESPITE
ANY. CHAPTER PLEASE WE DO THAT
IT JUST IN OUR CULTURE IS
REALLY DIFFICULT TO HAVE
SOMEBODY COME INTO OUR HOME. IT
IS VERY DIFFICULT TO SPEAK OUT
TO SAY ALTHOUGH SHAMEFUL THINGS
THAT HAPPEN TO WIN MY TELL ME
IT'S VERY PAINFUL AND VERY
DIFFICULT TO SAY THAT'S READY.%
TO BE JUDGED. THAT BEHAVIOR
BECAUSE FOR ANY. AND THAT.
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED SUPPORT
IT. YES A J. IT HAS TO BE
HONEST SOURCE OF. THIS FAMILY
NEED TO RESTORE WITH POLICE I
ARE YOU TO PLEASE LOOK AT THE
PHONE LOOK AT BOTH. PEOPLE
THEIR WITH WITHOUT WE PUT. AND
BREAK AWAY FROM WHAT THE COACH
BEAR ARE AND MAKE THEM THE
THINGS. OR A FAMILY TO BE OF
THE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU GAVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN THE.
THANK YOU MISS GOMEZ AND YOU'RE
LUCKY TO HAVE YOU AS AN
ADVOCATE ON HIS BEHALF. THANK
YOU AND NOW TO LINE FIFTY SEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T
WANT TO PUT ON THE TABLE YOU'RE
KIND OF PLAYING THAT COMFORT
WHAT ARE YOUR BACK ON LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHAT THE RESPONSE WILL
MOVE TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. HI MY NAME IS MARY ELLEN
ORANGE COUNTY- SOME COMMENTS ON
YES I CAN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY-
I'M NOT SMALL BUSINESS AND A
DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDER FOR A
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL CENTER- I'M
CALLING BECAUSE I- WANTED TO
PUT MY FEET UP SUPPORT FOR
DEMONSTRATIONS REQUEST. FOR
SERVICE COORDINATORS FINDING
OUT SERVICE COORDINATION
FUNDING RIGHT- I'VE I'VE WORKED
WITH THE COURTNEY AT THE CENTER
AND- I DO BELIEVE THAT- WE DO
NEED MORE FUNDING FOR
DISTRICTS. TO HAVE- LESS-
BETTER CASELOAD FOR OUR SERVICE
COORDINATOR- I AM ALSO- CALLING
BECAUSE I WANTED TO- SUGGEST
THAT YOU- USE MORE OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST- ARMS FOR- DEVELOPING
THESE- TRANSPORT THAT THE
CLIENTS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- I USED TO WORK
FOR A DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER THAT
WAS CLOSED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
AND WE HAD EIGHT HUNDRED
CLIENTS AND SIX OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST- SERVICES WERE
PROVIDED A LOT OF THE- THE
PROGRAM- PROVIDERS WERE YOU SIX
TERRAPINS. AND- RIGHT NOW- WITH
THAT THE- THE REGIONAL KIND OF
GUY WORKS FOR. THEY'RE IN
CHARGE OF FOURTEEN THOUSAND
CLIENTS AND THERE'S ONLY ONE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST. IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER I'M I'M JUST
CONCERNED THAT- AT. YOU DON'T
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY IS BUT IT IT IT
ACTUALLY IS THE PROFESSION THAT
HELPS PEOPLE ACROSS THE
LIFESPAN. TO DO THE THINGS THAT
THEY WANT THEY NEED TO DO. JUDY
IS A THERAPEUTIC ACTIVITIES.
AND YOU- THEM OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY IS- PROVIDED AGAINST
THAT CLIENTS ARE ASSESSED-
PRIOR TO AND DURING EARLY
INTERVENTION BUT THEY'RE NOT
SAYS ONCE THEY COME BACK FROM
SCHOOL DISTRICT THANK. AND I
FEEL LIKE IT'S A LOT OF WASTE
OF MONEY BECAUSE- YOU WANT YOUR
YOUR CLIENTS YOU KNOW TO BE
HAPPY TO BE INDEPENDENT- SO
ANYWAY THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO
SAY- THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND I COME FROM LIVE
ONE TWENTY ONE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE. DR ARAMBULA AND
FRAZIER- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE- PUBLIC
COMMENT MY NAME IS- DOCTOR
BAPTISTE SON. INTERESTED HAD A
RARE GENETIC CONDITION THAT
MADE HIM ELIGIBLE FOR SERVICES
AND- I LIVE AND WORK IN
NORTHEAST LOS ANGELES- AND THEN
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY AT THE
EASTERN LOS ANGELES FAMILY
RESOURCE AND- I'M ALSO THE
CHAIR OF THE FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE REPRESENTS- FORTY SEVEN
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS WHO
SUPPORT REGIONAL CENTER
FAMILIES AND SELF ADVOCATES IN
ALL FIFTY EIGHT TIMES FOR OVER
A LOT FOR THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS. WE ARE SEEING CA
SUPPORTS THE PROPOSAL FOR
COMMUNITY NAVIGATORS. IN THE
MEDIA EXPANSION. THIS PROGRAM
SHOULD SOMEWHERE THAT WE'RE
ALREADY DOING AND ALLOW FOR
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND ON OUR
LESSONS LEARNED NOT ONLY DURING
THE CALL THE CRISIS THAT IS-
FOR EXAMPLE HELPING WHAT. WILL
FERRELL AND ACCESS TO BASIC.
SERVICES LIKE FOOD AND
DISRUPTING PP- BUT ALSO IT
ALONE- AN INCREASING
OPPORTUNITY FOR US- SO YOU KNOW
WE INTENTIONALLY SUPPORT AROUND
ECONOMIC RACIAL AND GEOGRAPHIC
STRUGGLES REALLY THAT FAMILY
FAMILY'S ENCOUNTER- THOSE
TROUBLES ARE NOT NEW BUT THE
RESOURCES THAT THE DEPARTMENT-
IS- SUGGESTING YOU HAVE
DIRECTED BUNCH MY MOUTH. AND
YES TO AS MUCH. MY WOULD BE
GREAT- IT IS WELL IS. BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE WAITED- SO LONG TO-
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO REACH
DEEPER INTO FAMILIES YOU KNOW
YOU KIND OF FEEL LIKE YOU WANT
TO. TAKE WHAT'S GIVEN THAT YOU
LOVE THAT LET ME SUGGEST. THAT
MORE MIGHT BE NEEDED. I AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF US FOR INSTANCE
FAMILIES CAN BE IMPORTANT FOR
THE NAVIGATOR PROGRAM TO
INCLUDE EXPERIENCE- FAMILY
CENTERED ORGANIZATIONS-
ABSTRACT CAN BUILD TRUST USING
REALLY. PERFECT COLLABORATION
PRACTICES WHERE BOTH PARTIES
ARE VALUED AND- THAT REFLECT
THE COMMUNITY CENTER AND FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS THAT- AND WHO
CAN SUPPORT ACCESSING LOCAL AND
RELEVANT REFERRAL SOURCES AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SAM AND
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS TO- IT
IS. TO PROVIDE EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT- THAT FAMILIES. MEET. I
JUST WANT TO SINCE YOU LOVE
WEEK- TO MAKE MYSELF A LOCATION
WITHIN THE NEEDED ABOUT. THEIR
WORK BOB- AND TO JUST OUR
DIRECTOR. AND HER STAFF WERE
REALLY ENGAGING SUPPORT. OVER
THE- THE LAST YEAR REALLY TO
GET A SENSE OF THE NEED- HER
UNIQUE RESPONSE TO LEAN INTO
THIS CRISIS IS WHAT WE NEED
MORE OFTEN GOVERNMENT AND I'M
GLAD THAT SHE HAS PARTON'S-
LIKE THIS COMMITTEE AND ALL OF
THE FOLKS WHO HAVE- SPOKEN
THAT'S FAR TO HELP US TO BUILD
A BETTER CALIFORNIA FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT USE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL. DISABILITIES
STEPS TO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM MEXICO PLEASE. AND THAT
COMES FROM LINE NINETY THREE
LIGHT LINE NINETY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN I MEAN-
YES. THANKS SO MUCH FOR SOMEONE
THANK YOU DR ROMULO. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER OR CONNECT WITH
AN TODAY AND ALSO THANK RECORD
ALL THE AND FIRST THAT GIVE
AWAY ROUNDED. AT AND SUCCESSES
ARE JUST- YOU GET WORD OF LAST
YEAR- AND CAN LIVE DECADES
ACTUALLY MY NAME IS MIKE
PEREIRA AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE HELICOPTER CENTERS ON A
SERVICE PROVIDER IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND I AM ALSO. THE
CO CHAIR OF THE A LEGISLATIVE
COALITION REPRESENTING
STAKEHOLDERS OF ALL TIMES TOP
ADVOCATES FAMILIES PARENTS
WHILE SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
REGIONAL CENTER CITY COUNCIL.
IN THE STATE. AND WHAT I WANTED
DO FIRST WAS A- JUST COMING
DIRECTLY ON. HOW WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO. TOGETHER BY PROMOTING
ERA PLUS. AND ADAPTABILITY AND
FLEXIBILITY AS ART MY
COLLEAGUES GOAL SAID IN HIS
COMMENTS WE WANT TO BUILD BACK
BETTER. AND SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO TO TAKE
THOSE STEPS TO DO THAT. IS TO
SUPPORT THE ELIMINATION OF THIS
NEED 20% DISPENSED ONE. WE ALSO
LIKE TO REALLY KIND OF
UNDERSCORE THE IMPORTANCE OF
CONTINUING TO EXAMINE OUR
SYSTEM. AND THE REFORM EFFORTS
THERE AND SO THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS THESE HUGE ISSUES THAT
ALL OF THE PANELISTS EVERYBODY
ON THESE CALLS HAS DISCUSSED.
HOW DO WE CREATE MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES. HOW DO WE RETAIN OUR
WORKFORCE AND CRYSTALLIZE OUR
SECTOR. HOW DO WE- DEVELOPER
EATEN SERVICE PAYMENT
STRUCTURES- AND ALSO. HOW DO WE
OVERCOME THIS HUGE DEFICIT THAT
WE HAVE WHICH IS ABOUT A ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
FINALLY WE WANT TO ONE
UNDERSCORE THE IMPORTANCE OF.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDENS AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER'S
PROPOSALS- AND KIND OF WHAT YOU
MENTIONED DR ARAMBULA WHICH IS
IN THE COMMONSENSE PERSONALLY
EDS CORRECT THAT THE EXTENDED A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER. IN ORDER TO
AGAIN CREATE SYSTEMS ABILITY.
AND ALLOW US AS SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO DO WE NEED TO DO
BEST WHICH IS FOCUSED ON THE
CONTINUANCE OF CARE FOR OUR
FOLKS. SO FINALLY I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME THINGS THAT YOU
GUYS CAN DO TO HELP SUPPORT OUR
SYSTEM EVEN FURTHER WHICH
THEY'VE BEEN. GOOD PARTNERS.
BUT CERTAINLY LOOKING AT WAYS
TO KIND OF ENHANCED SEVERAL
SUPPORT WOULD BE HELPFUL. AND I
THINK ERIC IS A CONVENTION
WHICH IS REALLOCATING INTERNET
SERVICES FOR UTILITY TO ACCESS.
AND THEN ADDITIONALLY LOOKING
WAYS THAT WE CAN. EXTEND THE
LEFT MAX. AND SIGNED ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTS FEDERALLY TO THE-
RECOGNITION OF REMOTE
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES AT CVS
COMPLIANCE SERVICE. VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND THAT COMES FROM A
LINE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
LINDA LANDRY- APPARENT AND I'M
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES. AND I
JUST WANTED TO THROW MY HAT IN
THE RING TO SAY HOW HAPPY I AM
TO HEAR ABOUT THE- STATEWIDE
COMMUNITY NAVIGATORS PROGRAM I
CAME INTO THIS SYSTEM THIRTY
SOME YEARS AGO. HELLO MY
DAUGHTER WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
THEIR REAL RARE CHROMOSOME
ANOMALY AND- I HAVE WORKED IN
THE SYSTEM FOR TEN YEARS I
SPEAK ENGLISH I KNOW SYSTEMS
AND IT WAS REALLY HARD TO
NAVIGATE. AND FROM THE MOMENT
SHE MOMENT SHE WAS IDENTIFIED
AND I JOINED A PARENT SUPPORT
GROUP I WAS ON THE BAND WAGON
FOR FAMILY SUPPORT. WELL WAS
ONE OF THE FOUNDING FATHERS OF
THE FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER
NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA. AND OUR
BIGGEST PIECE IT WAS TO. IT
FIRST BILL NICE. PROVIDE.
SERVICES AND RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT IN THEIR CHOSEN
LANGUAGE. INITIATE PARENT
LEADERSHIP AND TO GET ALL THAT
GOING IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE
HAVE SEVEN REGIONAL CENTERS I
HEARD THE COMMENTS ABOUT IT'S
INTERPRETED DIFFERENT AND EACH
ONE MANY TIMES AND I'M ON THE
BORDERLINE SO I HAVE A REGIONAL
CENTER ACROSS THE STREET
DIFFERENT THAN THE ONE I HAVE
HERE MY HOUSE. SO THE NAVIGATOR
SYSTEM IS JUST THE PROGRAM IS
JUST SOMETHING THAT IS A
WONDERFUL INVESTMENT AND IT'S
AN INVESTMENT OF FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN INVESTMENT. AND HAVING
MORE LEADERSHIP WITH FAMILIES
AND HAVING THEM- GET THE GAIN
THE ABILITY TO BE MAKING
INFORMED. DECISIONS ON THEIR
CHILD- SERVICES AND HOPEFULLY
WITH SELF DETERMINATION. THAT-
CONSUMER WILL MAKE THEIR OWN
INFORMED DECISIONS LATER ON SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR GOOD WORK
GOOD LUCK. THANK YOU MA'AM
LAWLER PLEASE. AND I COME FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GIVE INPUT MY NAME IS CONNIE
FRIEND SO- OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
OFFICE OF SOCIETY A FORMER
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE WHO.
USED TO RUN VACCINE CLINICS
AND- AND MY MOM OF THE THIRTY
THREE YEAR OLD SON WITH AUTISM
I WOULD LOVE TO GIVE YOU SOME
COMMENTS- STANDS- I APPRECIATE
THE INPUT THAT YOU'RE GIVING ME
TIME FOR. SORRY I'M GOING TO
TURN OFF THE- PLEASE FORGIVE ME.
ANYWAY I WON TO TALK ABOUT WITH
DANCING BARGMANN MENTION IN IN
TERMS OF THE HELP TO IN TERMS
OF GIVING PRIORITY TO ARE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED. I'D
LIKE TO SAY SUGGEST THAT WE
KEEP IT SIMPLE WHAT ERIN
CARUTHERS SENSE- SAID MADE A
LOT OF SENSE TO ME IN OTHER
WORDS. ALL THE REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS SHOULD BE GIVEN
PRIORITY THEY ARE ALL HIGH RISK
AND SO I THINK IF WE COULD JUST
EVEN HAVE A LETTER FROM DDS OF
THE REGIONAL CENTRE STATING
THAT THERE ARE- DDS CLIENTS.
THAT COULD SIMPLIFY THINGS IN
TERMS OF GIVING THEM PRIORITY.
US SEPARATELY AND LIKE TO SEE
SOME SPECIALIZED CLINICS IF
NEEDED I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
DRIVE THROUGH CLINIC FOR THOSE
WHO WERE. PERHAPS BEHAVIORALLY
CHALLENGED THAT THAT WOULD-
MAKE IT MUCH EASIER FOR
PARENTS- I WATCHED THE OTHER
DAY AT THE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS A
MOTHER STRUGGLING WITH HER SON
HE WAS A TEENAGER HE OBVIOUSLY
HAD A LOT TO THEM HE WAS TRYING
TO RUN AWAY. I THINK SEEM SHE
WAS TRYING TO GET HER VACCINE.
AND HER JUST TRIED TO KEEP HIM
IN LINE IN THESE LONG LINES IT
REALLY WAS VERY- DIFFICULT I
WANTED TO GO OUT AND HELP HER.
SO IF WE COULD HELP THEM
SPECIAL CLINICS MAY BE PUT ON
THROUGH THE REGIONAL CENTERS
LIKE THEY'RE CURRENTLY DOING
THEY'RE- THEY'RE DISTRIBUTING
P. P. ET WHY NOT HELP THEM
DRIVE GROUP OF VACCINE CLINICS.
FOR THOSE WHO NEED IT- THIRDLY
I'D LIKE ADDRESS THAT. HAS A IN
THE KEY GIVE AND TALKING ABOUT
CARE GIVERS IN GROUP HOMES OR
SUPPORTED LIVING. RESPITE
WORKERS ANY OTHER CONGREGATE
SETTINGS. WHAT I'VE OBSERVED
AND IN FACT IN MY OWN WITH MY
OWN SON SOME OF THEM ARE
REFUSING TO GET VACCINATED NOW
THIS IS PUTTING THEMSELVES AT
RISK AND ALSO PUTTING OUR
CLIENTS THEY'RE CARING FOR AT
RISK. IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
REQUIREMENT FOR TUBERCULOSIS
BEFORE YOU CAN WORK IN A
HOSPITAL OR WHATEVER YOU NEED
TO TB CLEARANCE BUT WITH CORONA
WITH THE CODE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ANY SORT OF REQUIREMENTS
AND ACTUALLY- CODE IS A LOT
MORE COMMUNICABLE BENCHMARKING
LOS'S. LIKE TO ASK- PEOPLE HERE
TO DISCUSS HOW WE CAN. HELP
REMOVE THESE BARRIERS I KNOW
SOME OF ITS CULTURAL SOME OF
ITS PEOPLE ARE JUST AFRAID LACK
OF KNOWLEDGE BUT- TO COME UP
WITH SOME INCENTIVES IN TERMS
OF- HELPING PEOPLE WHO ARE
RELUCTANT WHO ARE IN CARE
GIVING ROLES TO GET A VACCINE.
I MEAN WE MIGHT NEED TO
CONSIDER MAKING IT MANDATORY
JUST SIMPLY AS WE DO WITH
TUBERCULOSIS WE REQUIRE PEOPLE
IF THEY WANT A JOB. THEY HAVE
TO GET A TB CLEARANCE AND WE
MIGHT HAVE TO GO TO WITHOUT
CONSIDERING THE VARIANCE. AND
THE RISKS HERE I WOULD STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO DISCUSS THIS ISSUE
AS WELL. IN MY OWN HOUSEHOLD-
THIS WAS BEFORE WE HAD THE
VACCINE ONE OF THE CARE GIVERS
CUTS CORONA AND IT WAS VERY
SCARY FOR ME BECAUSE I HAD THE
OTHER CARE GIVERS SAYING WELL
WE'RE NOT SURE WE WANT TO SHOW
UP TO WORK ANYMORE. AND SO THIS
IS A REAL ISSUE AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ALLOWING ME
TO GIVE INPUT. THANKS THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
AND ACTIVISTS LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JOHN. I AM REGIONAL-
ASSEMBLYMEN FRAZIER THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING UP THE CRITICAL
ISSUE OF RESPITE. RESPITE
PERSONAL ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
FOR CONSUMERS AND FAMILIES
SHOULD BE FIRST AND FOREMOST. I
HAVE BEEN ON THE WAITING LIST
FOR SELF DETERMINATION SINCE
EARLY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. HI
LIKE MANY CONSUMERS WHO HAVE
BEHAVIORAL NEEDS AND YOUR
MEDICARE HEALTH CARE NEEDS HAVE
BEEN DENIED ACCESS TO QUALITY
DAY PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF THE
LEVEL OF SUPPORT WE NEED SO I
AM EXCITED TO BE IN SELF
DETERMINATION WHEN I'M EXCEPT
IN. I THANK MEDIA STRICKER
BITING US PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
SERVICES FOR PERSONAL
ASSISTANCE DURING KOBE'S BUT I
STILL DO NOT HAVE ANY QUALITY
PROGRAMMING TO DO DURING THE
DAY. CAN THEY PLEASE OPEN UP
ACTUALLY P. EARLIER HAVE
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED SERVICES
TO INCLUDE ALTERNATIVE SERVICES
LIKE VIRTUAL PROGRAMS FROM NON
BANK PROVIDERS SO I CAN HAVE
SOMETHING TO ME. DURING THE DAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK DAYS
EIGHT YOU AS WELL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE
MORE- CALLER IN Q. AND IF AGAIN
YOU WOULD LIKE TO QUEUE UP
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND
NOW TO LIVE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE WHITE
PM HERE ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND WE WANTED
TO AT JUST COMMENTED ON THE
RECENT THAT SECRETARY GALLEON
GOVERNOR NEW PLAN- RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED- AN UPDATE ON THE
DISTRIBUTION OF VACCINE AND- WE
APPRECIATE ART THE PRIOR PRIOR
TO PATIENT- WORKING WITH
DISABILITIES AND THAT
DISTRIBUTION OF VACCINE. OUT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT BASED ON
NATIONAL AND STATEWIDE DATA
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
VULNERABLE TO GETTING SEVERELY
SECOND DYING FROM KOBE- IN FACT
MANY OTHER STATES ALREADY
PRIORITIZED PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. REGARDING
VACCINES INCLUDING TENNESSEE
OHIO NEW MEXICO AND
PENNSYLVANIA I WE HOPE THE
CALIFORNIA GETS THE VACCINES TO
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AT
FIRST BUT DISABILITIES POSSIBLE
IN ORDER TO SAVE. LIFE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS STARK
CONTRAST CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. YES THIS IS DARK
INTERESTS AND I AM A MEMBER OF
THE INTEGRATED COMMITTEE
COLLABORATIVE I'M AND IF
THEY'RE GONNA KALRA AND FIRST
OF ALL I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT I
SUPPORT EVERYTHING THAT A LIST
OF THIS BODY OFCOMMERCE TALKED
ABOUT BECAUSE WE ARE. IN WITH
THE FAMILIES AND WE KNOW ALL OF
THE NEEDS AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
A LOT OF FAMILIES WITH COLD OR
NOT REPORTING TO THEIR REGIONAL
CENTER BECAUSE OF DESTRUCTION.
AND THOSE THAT ARE SOME OF THEM
ARE NOT GETTING SERVICES. I
HAVE A GRANDSON WHO IS TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS OLD AND I TOOK HIM
OUT OF A CARE FACILITY A CARE
HOME IN MARCH WHEN I HEARD
ABOUT OF THE COLD IT DIDN'T AND
EVERYTHING AND THEY IS DOWN IN
THAT STATE. BY TALKING ABOUT TO
PROTECT HIM AND I BROUGHT HIM
HOME AND OF COURSE THAT
ENTAILED HE NEEDS TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN CARE AND THAT ENTAILED
ABOUT FIVE INDIVIDUALS COMING
IN AND OUT OF MY HOME. AND WE
WERE ABLE TO BAKE IT FOR MARCH
TO JANUARY WHEN WE ONE OF OUR
CARE PROVIDERS GOT SICK AND
BROUGHT KOBE TO EVERYONE THAT
WORKED IN. OUR HOME- I GRANDMA
I MEAN I REYES MY GROUND TO HE
WAS A- IN. I'M SORRY THREE OLD.
AND WHEN HE TESTED POSITIVE IT
WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
I TOOK INTER MERCHANT SEE
BECAUSE HIS. OXYGEN LEVEL WENT
DOWN TO EIGHTY AND I GOT SCARED
SO ALL LOAN I TOOK HIM HE
TESTED POSITIVE. AND AT THAT
POINT I STARTED- EXHIBITING
SOME- SHOWING SOME SYMPTOMS AS
WELL AND I REMEMBER THE HORROR
THE HORROR THAT I FELT IN MY
HEART WHEN I KNEW THAT I HAD
TO. BUT NOT ONLY TAKE CARE OF
HIM BUT WHO IS GOING TO TAKE
CARE OF ME I'M A SENIOR
CITIZEN. SO AT THAT POINT RIGHT
I HAPPEN TO. BE ASSOCIATED WITH
ELIZABETH GOMEZ THANK GOODNESS
AND SHE HELPED ME FIGURE OUT
WHAT IT WHAT IT WAS THAT I
NEEDED TO DO- MY GRANDSON
DIDN'T END UP IN COURT AVAIL.
AND I'M VERY VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT AND ESPECIALLY OUR NANCY
MARCHMENT. WHO NOT ONLY HAS
LISTENED TO THE ICC BUT OTHER
COMMUNITY GROUPS. THAT HAVE
TALKED ALL ALONG ABOUT THE
NEEDS IN THE COMMUNITY AND SOME
OF THOSE DIRECTIVES THAT HAVE
COME FROM PDS HAVE COME AS A
RESULT OF **** PARCHMENT AT
FIRST OUT. LISTENING TO US AND
TELLING US WE NEED WE NEED
PEOPLE THAT CAN COME FROM OUR
FAMILY TO WORK IN OUR PALM
BEACH- THAT WE'RE FAMILIAR WITH
SO THAT WE DON'T EXPOSE
OURSELVES AND OUR LOVED. ONES
TO THE COLD IT. I AT THAT POINT
REALIZE I HAVE NO PLAN. WE BOTH
TACKLE BUT I NO. AND I'M- THESE
FAMILY. HOW WE HELP THEM
DEVELOP. IF THEY GET COALBED.
KERRY WE FIGURE OUT WHAT
RESOURCES THEY MAY NEED TEN
WEEK. CONTACT FOODS. AND WE
HAVE COME TO COMMUNICATION WITH
THE FAMILIES IT'S ALL IMPORTANT
I HAVE TO DRIVE MYSELF THE
THIRD DAY OF COLBERT I DROVE
MYSELF TO GET MY TEST BECAUSE
MY DOCTOR SAID I NEEDED TO I
DON'T KNOW HOW I GOT THERE BUT
THEN IN THINKING ABOUT ME AND
I'M THINKING ABOUT ALL THE
FAMILIES AND WORK THAT I WORK
WITH. HOW A DATE YET. THEIR
DOCTOR IF THEY WENT TO THEIR
DOCTOR HOW WOULD THEY GET THERE
I GUESS I COULD HAVE CALLED AN
AMBULANCE. BUT AT THAT POINT
YOU KNOW THAT WAY. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK NANCY FOR
IMMEDIATE THAT SHE'S HAD AN
ESPECIALLY THE MEETINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN TOTALLY IN SPANISH. I
WORKED AT A BILINGUAL SCHOOL
AND I KNOW THAT IF I WANTED TO
REACH MY SPANISH SPEAKING
FAMILIES I NEEDED TO CONDUCT A
WHOLE BEAT THE SPANISH BECAUSE
THEN I WOULD HAVE PAID BACK.
THEN I WOULD HAVE PEOPLE THAT
WOULD TELL WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE
AND ALSO PROVIDES. COOL SO DOES.
ARE SOME SENSE THEY NEED TO BE
A SPAN. WE CAN'T AND THEN IT
PICKS LONG TO TRANSLATE. IF YOU
WANT PAID BACK FROM THE
COMMUNITY. YOU NEED TO DO MORE.
BANISHED FOR EVERYONE. THE
CONGRESS THAT I'VE HAD HAVE
BEEN GROW ALL BOTH. UNITS FOCUS
ON OTHER COMMUNITY SEX. TRY TO
COME OUR THAT COMMUNITY AND NOT
ONLY CONNECT WITH THE COMMUNITY
LEADERSHIP LIKE THE ICC THERE
ARE A LOT OF OTHER COMMUNITY
GROUPS THAT YOU COULD IDENTIFY
IN THE COMMUNITY PEOPLE OF
COLOR THAT THE BETTER LEADERS
THAT YOU COULD THAT YOU COULD
TAP FOR INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
COMMUNITY. THEN ALSO WHITE I
REALIZED SOME OF OUR FAMILIES
THEY DON'T HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY
TO BE ABLE TO. BE PRESENT AS
LITTLE MEDIAN FOR OR OR TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR WITH
THEIR- ORDINATOR OR THEIR CASE
MANAGER WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT AS WE LOOK AT THE
PANDEMIC AND ALL THAT IS
BECAUSE- EDUCATION IS ANOTHER.
I CONSIDER MYSELF WELL READ AND
I KNEW A LOT ABOUT COLBERT BUT
WHEN IT HIT ME I WANTED TO ASK
QUESTIONS WHAT SHOULD I DO I
WAS A LONG NIGHT GRANDSON WAS
TAKEN OUT OF MY HOME I WAS
ALONE. I'M A SENIOR CITIZEN AND
I SAT THERE AND THANK GOD THAT
I HAVE SO MUCH LOVE AND SUPPORT
WITH NOT ONLY THE ICE YOU SEE
BUT THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE AT
BECAUSE I'M RETIRED AND I ALSO
HAVE FRIENDS THAT CAME TO MY-
RESCUE. BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
CATION WITH EDUCATE OUR
FAMILIES. ABOUT COLD. WHAT WHAT
DO YOU DO. WORKING TAX ALL OF
THE LOCATIONS AND NOW THE
THERE'S A OF YOUR PROGRESS THAT
MAY TO BE GIVEN UP TO COMMUNITY
REGARD THE FACT. THERE ARE A
LOT OF MISSING OUT THERE AND I
GOT HE ASKED WITH AND WITH THE
NEW ARE BEHIND OUR- WE. SHOULD
BE KEPT AT. YEAH. VERY
IMPORTANT TO THEM AND VERY
IMPORTANT CONCERNS WHAT
THEREFORE. THE OTHER DAY THAT I
WANT TO SAY BOB COULD DO WITH-
HOW ARE YOU WHAT ELSE YOU NEED
TO HAVE FOOD- ALL OF THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT. I THINK I'M DONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING TO ME AND I THINK I
GOT TO THE HEART OF THE MATTER
INTERSECTED ME AND ALL THE TIME
THAT I WAS ALONE I REFLECTED
AND I THOUGHT ABOUT ALL THE
FAMILY HOW. I WAS THE LONE BUT-
IT COULD BE FAMILIES OUT THERE
THAT ALL OF THEM COULD BE A LOT
OF MULTI GENERATIONAL FAMILIES
AT ALL OF THEM HAVE COLBERT.
PLEASE LET'S HELP LET'S HELP IN
SOME WAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM AND FOR BRINGING.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE. WILL YOU DO ONE MORE
SWEEP FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS
OPERATOR I SURE WELL AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ASK- SHARE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND ONE THEN ZERO SHARE
AND WE DO HAVE SOMEONE CLEAN UP
WELL. IT WE GO ONE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE TWENTY NINE. HI GOOD
EVENING. I'M THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR HAVING TO- HEARING AND FOR
TAKING OUR PUBLIC COMMENT. I'M
I WANTED TO ADDRESS MY COMMENTS
TO- DIRECTOR PARCHMENT MY NAME
IS PATRICIA ALBANIA AND I'M
HEARING MYSELF OF ANY SIXTEEN
YEAR OLD ON THE AUTISM SPECTRUM
I AM ALSO A STRONG ADVOCATE
FOR- A SPANISH SPEAKING
COMMUNITY CHURCH I'M IN MY
FIRST CONCERN- WHICH REGARDING
THE LETTER THAT CAME OUT DID IT
JANUARY THIRTEENTH HALF OF
WHERE IT WAS- YOU KNOW OUR-
FAMILIES WHERE FAMILY MEMBERS
WERE TOLD THAT. IF WE HAVE ANY-
CLIENT THAT'S PART OF THE
REGIONAL CENTER- WE COULD
QUALIFY FOR THE VACCINE AND IT
WAS VERY SPECIFIC- IN REGARDS
TO THE DIAGNOSIS THAT I AM
QUALIFIED. AND SO MY FIRST
CONCERN REGARDING THIS LETTER
WAS THAT THE LETTER I WILL
NEVER I NEVER SIDE IN SPANISH.
AND GOING BACK TO THE POINT
THAT JUDY MARC SNEYD- YEAR- A
LOT OF THE INFORMATION DID NOT
GET PASSED ON TO EVERYBODY SO A
LOT OF PEOPLE EITHER DID NOT
RECEIVE THE LETTER OR THE
LETTER WHICH NOT IN SPANISH SO
I FEEL THAT A LOT OF THE
SPANISH SPEAKING POPULATION.
BUT NOT AWARE JUSTICE THAT THIS
WAS HAPPENING- MY CONCERN
REGARDING THEIR IN FACT IT HAS
BEEN MADE CLEAR TO ME AT LEAST
WHEN I ASKED THE QUESTION THAT
AUTISM DOES NOT FALL UNDER. THE
CATEGORIES HERE- OUTLANDISH
LETTERS HOWEVER WE HAVE HEARD
THAT THERE ARE FAMILY MEMBERS
THAT HAVE BEEN AT LEAST EATING
THE VACCINE WHEN THERE ARE
CHILDREN ONLY HAVING ANY
DIAGNOSES AND FELL. I'M JUST I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE
THIS INTO ACCOUNT BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION THAT
IT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AND
IT'S VERY TYPICAL TO STUFF THAT
HAPPENS- WHEN WE REQUEST FOR
SERVICES EITHER FROM THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS WHERE SAM
FAMILIES GET THE SUPPORT AND
OTHER FAMILIES DO NOT IN THIS
CASE. SOME FAMILIES WE HAVE
BEEN TOLD THAT IF OUR CHILD
ONLY HAS AN AUTISM DIAGNOSIS
AND WE DON'T QUALIFY BASED ON
THE LETTER THAT CAME OUT FROM
AND PBS WHERE OTHER FAMILIES
HAVE ALREADY RECEIVED THE
VACCINE AND IN THE FUTURE
ALLEN- SUPPORT JUST HAVING. MY
CLARITY- BY STUFF LIKE THAT
THAT'S PUT OUT TO FAMILY.
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM MCCULLAR. AND
THAT COMES TO MIND SO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH SH. ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES MA'AM
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES DO YOU
HEAR ME YES MA'AM. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR ALLOWED
TO GIVE OUT OUR SYSTEM MONEY MY
ENGLISH IS NOT VERY WELL BOUNCE
THAT TIME A BIT I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ELIZABETH BOWMAN FOR
BEING HERE AND BE OUR BOYS MY
NAME IS REALLY SAD THAT NOT
MORE THAN UP TO KEEP WITHOUT
THE PHONE I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
TO THE PROMISE OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES FOR
THEIR AIRPORT TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFE AND HEALTHY
HOWEVER IT HAS NOT HE HAD NO
BEING NOT UNFORTUNATELY. THE
INTERPRETATION OF THOSE
DIRECTLY IT'S MORE OF WORRY AND
HELP ME GET THE
MISUNDERSTANDING OF THE SYSTEM
I FOR THE CALLS ALL THAT
STARTED THE SERVICE COORDINATOR
ARE MAKING SURE AND BEACHES OUR
CHECKBOOKS AND. THE QUESTION
ARE THE FOLLOWING. WHAT IS THE
PRODUCT. WHAT ARE THE LOS AND
RESTORE. THAT HAVE BEEN GIVEN
TO THE FIRE. WHAT HAD BEEN
SMALLER UP. TO IS THAT ARE
COMMUNITY IS NOT EVEN WITH ALL
OF THE COPY CASE. BECAUSE ON
MANY OCCASIONS BILL COURTED IT
HAPPENS AT THE BILL EVERYBODY
ARE IN MEDIA ANY WITHDRAWAL
NOBODY WANTS TO HELP THE
FAMILIES. IN MY OPINION THEIR
FAMILIES ARE BEING PENALIZED
FOR BEING SICK AND THE LAST
THING IS THEY- ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT THE QUALITY AND QUANTITY
BUT THE COMMUNITY WHAT I'LL DO
SOME ON ALL THE DISABILITIES
WHAT EXCLUDED FROM THE FIRST.
PHASE BACK THE NATION AS WELL
AS NOW IS BEING IS BEING
EXCLUDED FOR THE ELIGIBILITY.
FOR OUR WAR ELECT NOT FEEL
SPECIAL OUT OF TOWN I'M SORRY
BUT THIS TO ME MIGHT WALK OUT
TO SOME IT'S ALL DOES NOT. IS
NOT GOING AWAY. ON THE CONTRARY
IT GONNA GET WORSE IF I LAID
ELIGIBILITY IS GIVEN MOST OF
OUR KIDS. ARE- BOTH OUR BAY
LEGIBILITY OF GIVEN LATE AND
THEREFORE IN A JEWELERS THE-
RIGHT NOW. HELLO MANY OF THE
ARE YOU. AND MANY OF THEM AREAS
THAT YOU BROUGHT IS BROKEN.
THAT THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND THAT COMES TO MIND
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND FORTY FIVE WE CAN'T
HEAR YOU HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES MA'AM. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU KNOW I'M JUST I MEAN
IT'S NOT EVEN A WHO MIGHT I
SPOKE EARLIER BUT I'M JUST
WANTING STATE THANK YOU TO ALL
OF YOU FOR TAKING IT FOR
ALLOWING US TO- GIVE OUR
COMMENTS. YEAH COMMITTEE. AND
DO A FOLLOW UP. AND AND ANYWAY
COULD OUT OF THE D. S. CAN. TO
TO DO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. IN OUR
LIVES AND HOPEFULLY- RIKABI
ISSUES SAID THAT EVERY TIME
THEY HAD SHARED. TO NIGHT. AND
ALSO- YOU CHAIR ADDING BY
SENATOR ADEMOLA. TO JOE NETWORK
OF THE STATE THE WITH THE
INTERNET OR AT. ANY AGE YOU CAN
ASK HE HAS A COMMON OKAY THIS
IS SCHEDULED. MAYBE HE CAN- GET
IN CONTACT WITH A LIST OF THE
GOVERNMENT. AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE HIM IN. AND JOIN US OUT
TO HEAR FROM MY COMMUNITY. SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ALL YOU DO
A PILOT ACT TO. KEEP OUR
PROMISE TONIGHT THANK YOU SIX.
GROSSNESS IN YOUR MIND GET ON-
THIS YEAR THE FOCUS ON
IMPORTANT TO PRESS CHINA. IS.
STANDING IN. BENNINGTON THANK
YOU AND I DID GO TO SIGN THANK
YOU MUCH FOR IN MY WHICH UP. IT
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE
NO ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS. LET'S
TO ONE MORE CHECK WE- WHICH- IT
IS JAMMING AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SHARE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
THEN ZERO. WHEN YOU HAVE
SOMEONE CLEAN UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. YOU JUST QUEUED UP YOUR
LINE IS OPEN LINE ONE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE JUST
QUEUED UP- ONE MOMENT.
A LINE
ONE THIRTY NINE YOU JUST PICK
YOURSELF I. Q. PLEASE RE QUEUE
UP WITH. ONE ZERO NINE ONE
THIRTY NINE. HOW TO LINE ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO GET A PUBLIC
COMMENT MY NAME IS A LEASE THAT
BLOCK THEM I HAVE TWO CHILDREN-
ACTUALLY YOUNG ADULTS THAT ARE-
REGIONAL CENTER CLIENTS BUT I
HAVE ELEVEN FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
ARE IN DIFFERENT REGIONAL
CENTERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND I HAVE. MY CONCERN AT THIS
MOMENT IS- TWO THINGS ONE I
KNOW THAT WE ARE PREPARING TO
OPEN UP SELF DETERMINATION TO-
ALL CLIENTS ARE. IN JUNE OR
JULY I BELIEVE AND I AT THIS
MOMENT- ACTUALLY BOTH OF MY
CHILDREN ARE IN SELF
DETERMINATION AND WE'VE HAD
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES WITH-
GETTING- EVERYTHING IN PLACE
AND- TRANSPLANTATION FROM THE
TRADITIONAL SYSTEM. INTO FAULT
DETERMINATION AND IT. IN MY
EXPERIENCE OF. NOT ONLY
NAVIGATING SYSTEMS OF CARE WITH
MY OWN CHILDREN BUT SUPPORTING
COMMUNITY AND FAMILY MEMBERS. I
THINK ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THOSE ARE OUR
SERVICE COORDINATORS ARE
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE NOT
ADEQUATELY PREPARED. AND THAT
IS REALLY IMPACTING THE WAY BOB
FOR PROGRAMMING- BEING
IMPLEMENTOR LOT BEING
IMPLEMENTED. OUT PROPERLY-
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT I SEE THAT I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO BE
ATTRACTIVE I KNOW FOR YEARS
I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN PARTICIPATED
IN ADVOCACY DAY IN GOING UP
WITH MY PARTICULAR REGIONAL
CENTER TO ADVOCATE. FOR MORE
SERVICE COORDINATORS. IT REALLY
IMPACT THE DELIVERY SERVICE AND
IT REALLY IMPACTED AGREES
COMMUNITIES LIKE AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO COMMUNITIES
WHO ARE REALLY AT. A
DISADVANTAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
GETTING THE ADEQUATE SUPPORT
AND SERVICES. NOW HAVING
SIGNIFICANT CASELOAD IT HAS
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE
FOR A LOT OF SERVICE
COORDINATORS AND NOW THAT WE
ARE TRANSITIONING FROM FAMILIES
INTO PUBLIC TERMINATION AND
THEN OPENING IT UP AND MORE AND
MORE WIDE SCALE. I DON'T SEE
THEM BEING ABLE TO MANAGE IT
WITH THE CARE AND- YOU KNOW HOW
THINGS NEED TO BE IMPLEMENTED
AND IT'S JUST IT'S I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE. THAT BE ADDRESSED WHERE
WE HAVE YOU KNOW THE RECORD
READERS AND THEIR CASE LOCAL
REDUCE BUT ALSO. BETTER
TRAINING FOR THEM ABOUT THE
DIRECTIVE THAT ARE COMING OUT I
HEAR A LOT. FROM THE COMMUNITY
THAT THE DIRECTORS ARE NOT
BEING FOLLOWED UP TRICKLE DOWN.
TO THE COMMUNITY AND I. VOTED
BE- OPEN TO HAVING COME. WITH
ANYBODY THAT CAN HELP OF COURSE.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL ONE OR TWO.
ESPECIALLY WITH OUR- OF. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NOT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AND THAT
COMES FROM LIVE ONE FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M DEBORAH
MARSTELLER WITH PROJECT
INDEPENDENCE WORRY IN THE
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND
I'M WANT TO GIVE A FULL
ENDORSEMENT OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL
RATE INCREASE- THE ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR FUNDING
GAP. FOUND BY THE STATE'S OWN
RATE STUDY PRECLUDES ANY
MENTION OF THIS RATE INCREASE
AFTER WE'RE TRYING SO
DESPERATELY TO SURVIVE. THIS
PANDEMIC AND ALONG WITH THAT IS
RATE INCREASES THAT ALLOW US TO
GIVE A LIVABLE WAGE TO OUR
STAFF. WORKING AT MINIMUM WAGE.
EVEN WITH THE DOLLAR INCREASE
SINCE LAST JANUARY JUST KEEPS
OUR STAFF BARELY SURVIVING IN
THE HIGH- EXTEND AREAS LIKE
ORANGE COUNTY IS YOU JUST CAN'T
SURVIVE ON THAT IN THE END THE
FOR THE PRIMARY CARE GIVERS.
FOR THE PEOPLE WITH THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION IN THE
STATE AND TO THINK THAT WE'RE
JUST MISSING THAT- WORK FOR
THAT PRIMARILY WOMEN PRIMARILY
PEOPLE OF COLOR IS JUST.
DISGRACEFUL AND I HOPE WE CAN
KEEP THEM IN MIND WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT WHAT A LIVABLE WAGE
REALLY SHOULD BE. FOR OUR STAFF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
THAT COMES FROM LINE ONE FORTY
FOUR LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOW I AM
TIM CLARK- CREATIVE ARTS
DIRECTOR MARIN VENTURES IN
MARIN COUNTY. AND I JUST WONDER.
FREE WEBSITE- SOME OF THE
IMPACTS WE'VE NOTICED FROM
ECONOMIC DISPARITY WITH SOME OF
OUR- INDEPENDENT CLIENTS CRIMES
NOT IN GROUP HOMES COMPLETELY
CLIENTS WITH FAMILIES AND EVEN
AMONG THE BIRTH CONTROL IT-
WITH GETTING ONLINE HAVING
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY THAT- WITH
GETTING INFORMATION. HOUSEHOLDS
DO ONLY SPEAK. SPANISH SHORTAGE
BECAUSE THERE'S SOMETHING- BUT
THE REAL REASON AYE AYE THE
THING I WANT THE MOST
IMPORTANT- TO REITERATE THAT WE
REALLY DO NEED TO PAY OUR GST
BETTER THIS- HE CRISIS HAS.
QUIET OUT NOT ONLY THEIR- THERE
NEED TO BE WORKING ONE ON ONE
PLACE THAT- YOUR FINDINGS AS WE
JUGGLE- WHO'S WHO'S WORKING
WHERE WHO'S SERVING WHO ARE
FINDING OUT HOW HOW DEPENDENT
THESE GUYS ARE AMONG MORE THAN
ONE CHILD LET IT SHOULD BE A
CASE THERE. YEAH I'LL TAKE CARE
OF FAMILIES TO. AND IT'S ALSO
PUTTING THE CLIENTS NOT JUST IN
OUR OUR COUPONS IT'S NOT JUST
OUR PROGRAMS. BUT THAT OTHER
FACILITIES ARE CFE- ELDER CARE
AT RISK- YEAH I THANK YOU FOR
ADDRESSING ALL THESE ISSUES
AND- THANKS TO ALL THOSE WHO
WILL BE CALLING IN TO SHARE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER. AND I COME FROM LIVE
ONE FORTY FIVE ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ONE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO I
DON'T KNOW IF I'M A ONE TWENTY
FIVE YEAH. YES- MY NAME IS
MARTHA OKAY THANK YOU- MY NAME
IS NOT THAT BAD BUT I DON'T I'M
A MOTHER OF LAST ONE YEAR OLD
AND A FEW CAN CUDDLE. AND
DINING AND- SOME LOCAL INTERNET
ORDER I WORK. WITH THEM AND IN
SEVEN COMMENTS THANK YOU SEE
INTEGRATED COMMITTEE CANNELLA.
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT TO
SEE- ONE THING- AT. THE MOTHER
OF ONE OF THOSE WITH- I.
OUTSIDE I WANT TO TRY ABOUT
PAPER TO PROVIDE IT- ONE OF THE-
I HAVE TO PAY FOR MY- AND- THEY
GET THEY THIRTEEN LACK WHICH I
THINK IS. LOW THEY'RE WORKING
TO IT'S REALLY HARD AND I KEEP
THEY HAVE LOT OF A LOT OF
BEHAVIORS. AND I THINK THAT-
ONE THING I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU. ANOTHER KINK I THINK AND I
LAURA WHO. HELPED FUNDING
NEEDS. THAT ARE NOT. GETTING
AND IT'S THEIR DEFENSE- IT'S
NOT FOR ME TO SEE THAT ARE.
HERE AFTER WE START WITH COLBY
AND THEIR FAMILIES WOULD FEEL.
YOU'LL HAVE FEEL BILL IN- I
THANK THE NINETEEN HAVE A
FUNDING. FROM DAY ORANGE COUNTY
WHO HAS DONE. THAT IN. THE WITH
THE VERY SEVERE INCIDENT AND
SHE'S. AT AND LIKE HER. A LOT
OF FUN HERE BECAUSE THAT'S IN
KNOW THAT SERVICE AND
EXPERIENCE FROM BRING IN THE
ABSENT PARENT. AND RIGHT NOW
WITH THE FUNDS THEY MAKE THEY
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE GETTING BOTH.
SERVICES TO. GET A LITTLE BIT
OF TELL IN THIS PLAN THAT ARE
SO I JUST WANTED TO CHECK LINK
WOULD YOU GOALS TO. THANK YOU
FROM. THANK YOU MA'AM. PLEASE
THANK YOU NECKLACE LIVE ONE
FORTY ONE FORTY NINE. OKAY YES.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES HELLO-
YES THANK YOU SO MUCH- MY NAME
A GROWTH OF ALLAH I HAVE TO ON
THE- SPECTRUM- ONE THE MY
OLDEST SON IS- MORE EFFECTIVE
THE OTHER ANY A LOT OF THE AND
HAS SHOULD BE ABLE TO- ONE OF
THE THINGS. THAT WE EXPERIENCED
DURING THE POST COLD IT IS THAT
MYSELF MY FAMILY DID CONTRACT-
COLD IT- MY HUSBAND IS AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS SO HE THE ONE
THAT BROUGHT IT. HOME
UNFORTUNATELY THROUGH US WE
BELIEVE. AND- IN THE PROCESS OF
GETTING MY ELDEST SON TESTED TO
SEE IF HE HAD SOLD IT- WE HAD
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES- EVEN
THOUGH THE NURSES THEIR WORK
TRYING TO BE COOPERATIVE AND
FLEXIBLE AND EVEN HAD ME.
ADMINISTER THE TESTS HE WAS
VERY FRIGHTENED HE SAW THE
WHOLE PEOPLE GET UP FOR THE
NURSES AND EQUALITY FOR
DEMOCRACY WAS MEANT BAYERN
MENTAL EVEN TRY DOING IT IN MY
CAR IT JUST WOULD NOT BE
WORKING. THERE NEEDS TO BE A
PLAN. FOR ADULT OR EVEN
CHILDREN THAT HAVE SENSORY
ISSUES THAT ARE FIGHT THEM
BECAUSE IT'S NOT WHATEVER IS
HAPPENING NOW NOT WORKING AND
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER MAYBE
EVEN GOING TO WANT HOME. OR
MAYBE THEIR PROGRAM THAT WHAT
HAPPENING NOW IS NOT WORKING SO
IF YOU WANT TO EXCLUDE A
POPULATION THIS IS THE PERFECT
WAY OF DOING IT IS NOT DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT- I THOUGHT IF
I AM HAVING TROUBLE. THEIR
GETTING HIM TESTED. WOULD BE IF
YOU HAVE HOPE IT. I DON'T KNOW
HOW IN THE WORLD I'M GOING TO
GET A VACCINATED- STUDIES ARE
SHOWING THAT- OUR POPULATION IS
VERY VULNERABLE WHEN IT COMES
TO GETTING ILL AND GETTING
HOSPITALIZED- I THINK GETTING
WORSE BECAUSE MY SON IS- YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO USE IT FOR IF YOU
DO A MACHINE. TO COMMUNICATE.
SO HE'S NOT ABLE TO TELL ME
WHAT HURT WHAT AILED HIM- SO
IT'S VERY CHALLENGING TO GET
HIM INTO EMERGENCY ARGUMENT. DR
ON. A GOOD DAY- SO THAT IS
ANOTHER CHALLENGE- IN OVER ONE
FAMILY GET. WELL THAT. ON THE
PORCH THE FOUNDING FOR. MORE
THAN PVP BECAUSE BY THAT TIME
IT LATE. HE V. THANK YOU FOR
THE TV SAID REALLY THEY REALLY
BE A NET OF LIKE WILL TAKE THAT
WOULD NEED FOR FOOD WHY WOULD
YOU NEED FOR CARE LIKE I WOULD
THINK THAT I. HAPPY TAKE CARE
OF MY HEALTH I WOULD ABLE TO
STAND UP MORE THAN SECONDS-
WHAT AT ONE POINT AND MY OTHER
SON WAS KILLED THANK GOODNESS
MY YOUNGEST ONE CAN ONLY GET
AFFECTED SO HE TESTED POSITIVE.
BUT I WOULD I WOULD BRING TO
MATH BUT I STILL WASN'T SURE IF
MY ELDEST SON HAD CONTRACTED
THE CORONA AND I WOULD CHANGE
MATHIS TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY
ON THE BACK OF MY EARS WERE
BLEEDING- SO EVEN THOUGH I WAS
SICK I STILL HAD TO TAKE CARE
OF EVERYONE ELSE AND I DIDN'T
HAVE ANY SUPPORT. IT WAS I LOOK
AT THE COURT THANK GOODNESS I
HAD SOME- FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES THAT WERE DROPPING
OFF FOOD- AND I WOULD AND I HAD
THE MEANS TO ORDER ONLINE ORDER
SUPPLIES AS WELL. OTHER THAT
EVERYBODY HAS THAT LUXURY AND
EVEN WITH THAT THE COURT IT WAS
STILL VERY. VERY DIFFICULT- I
KNOW THINK ALLOW- THE OTHER
THING IS THE INFORMATION NOT
BEING DONE- IN FANNISH AND WE
SHOULD BE TO IN A MORE
LANGUAGES. BUT FOUND SPEAKING
FAMILY ARE A LOW PARKING. OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE
IS NO EXCUSE. THAT'S NEAT IT
JUST SHOWS BLATANT RACISM IT'S
NOT A PRIORITY IT SEEMS TO ME.
IS BEING DEMONSTRATED BY NOT.
TRANSLATING THIS INFORMATION IN
SPANISH THERE'S NO EXCUSE. YOU
CAN THROW A ROCK AND HIT
SOMEBODY THAT CAN SPEAK SPANISH
THE QUALITY TRANSLATE. INTO
MAKING IT- SO- AND THAT'S KINDA
FOR I HOPE CHANGE SOON- AND
ALSO THE RATE HAS A VERY. THESE
ARE NOT MINIMUM WAGE JOBS FOR
CHRISTMAS THAT WORK WITH OUR
POPULATION. THEY CARE ABOUT OUR
FOLKS AND THEY WANT TO WORK
WITH OUR FOLKS. BUT IF THEY
DON'T HAVE A LEADING WAIT. HOW
IN THE WORLD EVEN IF THEY WANT
TO THEY CAN'T WORK WHAT WITH
OUR FAMILIES I NEED I WONDER IF
LEGISLATORS AND STAFF MEMBERS
WERE BEING PAID THE MINIMUM
WAGE IF THEY WOULD CONTINUE TO
DO THE JOB THEY HAVE. GET THE
QUESTION TO BE PUT OUT THERE WE
LIVE IN THE BAY AREA. AND IT'S
NOT. ON MINIMUM WAGE. IT'S NOT
HAPPENING IT CANNOT HAPPEN IT'S
NOT POSSIBLE SO. THERE IS NO I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A PLAN. I
DON'T SEE ONE THE ONLY PLAN
THAT IT IS TO INCREASE IT TO
MAKE A LIVING WAGE- THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND THANK
YOU I KNOW THIS IS GONE FOR A
VERY LONG TIME. AND I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HAVE A NICE EVENING.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND THAT COMES FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
LINE WILL BE ME THIS IS AGAIN
IF IT'S GONNA- I JUST WANTED TO
LET YOU KNOW ONE THING THAT I
FEEL THIS IS HOW I GET TO
REGIONAL CENTER HAVE YOU EVER
GONE TO A RESTAURANT. AND DON'T
HAVE THE MANY. BETTER EXACTLY
WHAT WE GENERAL FUND OUR FIELD
WHAT. BECAUSE THEY TELL YOU
THAT EVERYTHING IS
INDIVIDUALIZED. THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE ACCORDING TO THE SERVICES
THAT THEY FEEL IS RIGHT BY THE
PROFESSIONAL BY THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR I FOUND THAT EVERY
TIME I'VE COME ACROSS.
QUESTIONS THEY DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER THEY DON'T KNOW. I'VE
ASKED HEY YOU KNOW I ONLY GET.
A HUNDRED DOLLARS FROM AT THE
SIDE BECAUSE I ACTUALLY WORK.
AND I'M AFRAID THAT IF I COULD
MAKE MORE MONEY I WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO HAVE MY TONGUE OVERED
BY THE INSURANCE ON THE STATE
INSURANCE. CAN YOU FIGURE OUT
THE INFORMATION CAN YOU GUIDE
ME THROUGH THE PROCESS I CAME
TO FIND OUT THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING CALLED- A WAIVER.
THAT WAS NEVER BROUGHT UP. I
WAS ON A JOB THAT I COULDN'T
LEAVE BECAUSE I HAVE TO PROVIDE
FOR MY FAMILY. AND I WAS NEVER
INFORMED TO ME I'VE ASKED THEM
I WANT TO TAKE A JOB CAN YOU
FIGURE OUT. HOW WILL THIS
AFFECT ME AND HE WILL BE
ELIGIBLE NOBODY GETS TO ME.
LIKE GET BACK TO ME I ASKED HEY
I'VE NEVER RECEIVED A FOR- ANY
PUBLIC PURCHASES FROM. FROM
REGIONAL FINALLY BEING CAUGHT
MY FAMILY HELPING A CLIENT
BECAUSE EVERYTHING THAT IS DONE
FOR MY CHILD. MY FAMILY SO IT
HAPPENS TO US. I NEVER RECEIVED
ANY PROOF OF PURCHASE THEIR FOR
ANNUAL BUDGET OR ANYTHING I
SIGNED UP TO BE A INDEPENDENT
FACILITATOR OVER A YEAR AGO. I
WASN'T REALLY LOOKING INTO THAT
NOW THAT I HAVE TO TRY MY ONE
AND I ASKED THEM IT HAS BEEN
ALMOST FORTY DAYS I SENT AN
EMAIL. TO THE PERSON WHO'S IN
CHARGE OF THAT. YOU NEVER GOT
BACK TO ME. SO RICHARD WHAT I'M
HAPPENING WE HAVE THE RESOURCES
WE HAVE A MENU. BUT IT'S FINE
IF ANTI BECAUSE SOMEBODY'S
KEEPING IT HIDDEN. SO WE ARE
COMING ACROSS EVERY SINGLE AREA
OF POSSIBLE BY REGIONAL CENTER
BECAUSE THEY DON T. BIGELOW
UNDER THE UMBRELLA THAT.
EVERYTHING IS INDIVIDUALIZED
YES. EVERY TIME I ASK FOR HELP.
SO CAN SOMEBODY MAKE THAT
PUBLIC INFORMATION CAN WE HAVE
THE OPTION IT ONLY HAD LITTLE
KNOWLEDGE AND INFORMATION ON
WHAT IT IS SAID THE REGIONAL
CENTER WILL DO FOR FAMILIES
BECAUSE I'M TERRIFIED OF EVER
GRANTED ANY TYPE OF. WHAT OUR
OVER MY TELL WHEN I'M GONE WHY
BECAUSE THEY ARE FAILING ME AND
I'M NOT LOOKING FOR MY CHILD
WHAT IS IT GONNA HAPPEN WHEN
I'M NOT HERE AND I DON'T HAVE
AND THAT IS THAT IT'S REALLY
CHILLY. EIGHT HELPING MY CHILD
SUCCEED IN LIFE. THAT IS WHAT
REGIONAL CENTER KILLED BY AND-
HONESTLY IF YOU'RE GOING TO
GIVE THEM ALL OPEN ALL THAT
MANY OF THE FUNDING. MAKE THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.BECAUSE IT'S NOT
FAIR FOR FAMILIES. I'M SORRY
COMING ACROSS TOO STRONG. BUT
THE FUTURE OF MY CHILD. THIS IS
THE HUMAN BEING THAT I LOVE. I
LOVE ALL. I NEED NEEDS TO BE
KNOWN BECAUSE YOU CAN BE GIVEN
ALL THAT MONEY AND HAVE THE
OPTION OF ALREADY. ARE IN THE
PROCESS BECAUSE YOUR SCHOOL BY.
AND SEVEN OTHER FOCAL AND
PRESSURED HAVE YOU DONE THIS.
DO YOU DO THAT. THEY SEND YOU A
FIRE I MEAN. HELPING OTHER
PARENTS THAT WERE TOLD. YOU
COULD MAKE THE APPOINTMENT FOR
THE SIXTEENTH. SO FOR MODERNIST.
WHO HAVE A CHILD SPECIAL NEEDS.
VERY FEW MEN ANY COLDER THE
MARGIN HOURS. AND THEY DON'T
SPEAK ENGLISH DURING COMPUTER
SAID THERE NOT LONG INTO SOME
MEETINGS- OR MAKING PHONE CALLS.
WE THE USER FONG YOUR PHONE I
COULD BASIC. HOW COULD YOU ASK
THEM TO SIGN UP FOR THEM TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
TO SET UP AN APPOINTMENT NO.
THERE ARE NO NO WAY WILL SET UP
AND AT THE BEGINNING IT WAS
VERY COMPLICATED YOU WANT TO AT
LEAST. SEVEN STEPS TO GET TO
THE END AND THEN YOU TOLD THAT
THERE WAS NO APPOINTMENT. IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT AND ONE OF THE
MOMS THAT I'M HELPING SHE TOLD
ME LIKE THEY TOLD ME. THAT THEY
WERE NOT MY BABYSITTERS THAT
THEY COULDN'T HELP. THEY KNOW
THAT SHE'S NOT COMPUTER
LITERATE BUT SHE ONLY SPEAKS
SPANISH AND THE SHE STRUGGLING
WITH HER TO. HER CHILD. YET
WHEN SHE ARMED HERSELF AND
GREAT IN THE CULTURE VERY ARE
ASKING FOR HELP. THEY'RE BEING
TOLD I AM NOT YOUR BABYSITTER.
SO THAT HAS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY ST DEMOCRAT THEY
SHOULDN'T SPEAK LIKE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE DEMEANED. AND IT
ALSO GO TO INCOME SUPPORTER
SERVICES WHEN THEY TELL US THAT
THERE. THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE THE
PARENTS PROVIDERS ARE THAT
THERE WE ASK FOR SERVICES OR
CAP IF YOU WANNA LET OUT OF OUR
CHILD THAT'S NOT THE CASE THE
CASE IF WE WANT TO BE THE BEST
ADVOCATE. AND WE KNOW THAT AS
PARENTS WE ARE THE ONE PERSON
THAT WILL NOT HURT THE- BILL.
THREE LAKE THE IDEA THAT WE'RE
BOXING FOR MORE CHILD. IF IT
ALREADY TO ASK FOR SERVICES TO
BENEFIT OUR FAMILY THAT IS NOT
IT OKAY SO MANY UNIQUE. THAT
THE BEST PERSON THAT CAN DO IT
IS A FAMILY MEMBER BUT EMPOWER
THE FAMILY MEMBER TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED SO THEY CAN
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES SO THEY
COULD LIVE IN ORANGE COUNTY
BECAUSE THE ONLY THING THAT
THEY'RE DOING IS PUSHING US
INTO RURAL AREAS BECAUSE
FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER HOUR ONE
NOT BEING ENOUGH. I KNOW KIDS
NEED SO MANY THINGS THAT WE
BECOME DESPERATE WE DON'T ST
OKAY PEOPLE GO TO SLEEP AT THE
SAME TIME. THEY ALWAYS HAVE
DIFFERENT BEARS THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT STRUGGLE AND THE
NEED. FOR THAT KIND OF IT'S A.
TWELVE EIGHTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO HOURS BILL. CASSIDY WE ARE
PROVIDING. THE SERVICES THAT
ARE NEEDED FOR CHILD. FOR JILL.
BECAUSE THIS ALL THE PARENTS
WERE WORKING. AS A KEY. BUT
WE'RE BEING SINGLED OUT AS
GREEDY SO WE NEED TO HELP
PEOPLE TO. TELLING THEM NO WHEN
WE ACTUALLY SUBJECT IS VERY
DIFFICULT IT REALLY BREAKS DOWN.
OUR DIGNITY OR HAVING TO ASK
AND ASK AND ASK AND THEN BEING
TOLD NO. AND THEN HAVING
LAWYERS AND ATTORNEYS AND
PEOPLE COME TO US LIKE WE'RE
CRIMINALS WE'RE NOT WE ARE AT
IT WE ARE TRYING TO GET THE
RESEARCH THE SUBJECT NEEDS.
WHEN WE'RE NOT HERE. THEY WON'T
KNOW ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
A DECENT LIFE THANK YOU AND
AGAIN I'LL GET FOR TAKING MUCH
OF YUR TIME BUT I REALLY NEED
TO THAT CHANNEL. WHAT IS THE
OTHER SIDE OF THAT PICTURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEMBERS
SPEAKING YOUR TRUTH. OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER. AND THAT COMES
FROM LIVE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE LINE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT'S ALL- HELLO
THIS IS CHOICE CAR I AM THE
PARENT OF A THIRTY TWO YEAR OLD
SON WHO CIRCLED SAN DIEGO
REGIONAL SYSTEM CENTER SYSTEM I
AM ALSO A CO DIRECTOR OF THE
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER AND-
CHAIR OF THE LOCAL SELF
DETERMINATION ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. I WAS NOT PLANNING
ON PROVIDING PUBLIC TESTIMONY
THIS EVENING THAT WAS MOVED BY
THE PASSION CONCERN AND
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT FROM
FAMILIES AND ADVOCATES DDS
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND AGENCIES I WANT
TO TAKE THE COMMITTEE I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR TAKING
TIME TO LISTEN TODAY TO THESE
COMPELLING STORIES ANECDOTES
AND CHALLENGES AND BERRIES THAT
COMMUNITY IS EXPERIENCING ON
MULTIPLE. LEVELS IT IS ALL
WHEEL. IT IS EQUALLY RAIL
CLEARLY EVIDENT THAT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS UNDERFUNDED
IN FAILING INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
IN EQUALLY FEELING THE AGENCIES
AND INDIVIDUALS PROVIDE
SERVICES. TO ACCOUNTABLE
POPULATION. IN ORDER TO
EFFECTIVELY SUPPORT A
POPULATION WHO IS ALL TOO OFTEN
A LAST CONSIDERATION WHEN
PUBLIC POLICY IS DEVELOPED WE
MUST INVEST INVESTED THAT YOU
WAIT AND WE MUST ENSURE ALL
PEOPLE GET THE SAME
INFORMATION. AND THE SAME
ACCESS TO SERVICES. AND THE
SYSTEM MUST HAVE THE MEANS TO
ADEQUATELY ADEQUATELY MEASURE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
INVESTMENT. I SINCERELY HOPE
THE COMMITTEE WILL TAKE ACTION
AND ADEQUATELY FUND OUR SYSTEM
PUT INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
FIRST SUPPORT AND PROFESSIONAL
LIVES I DIRECT SUPPORT STAFF
AND AGENCIES. HOW FUND
COMMUNITY NAVIGATOR PROGRAMS TO
HELP FAMILIES NAVIGATE THESE
COMPLEX SYSTEMS I KNOW THAT
PERSONALLY I CAN TELL YOU AFTER
THE EARLY START PROGRAM HANDS
AND YOU'RE IN THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM. EXTRA SOCIAL
SUPPORT THE FAMILY AND- THANK
YOU AND BY BETWEEN. ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY AT ALL LEVELS
WHERE OUR ACCOUNTABLE ANYONE
WHO RECEIVES OUR GOVERNMENT
BONDS MUST. DEMONSTRATE THAT
THEY ARE MEETING THE NEEDS TO
STAY IN THOSE RAIDS WE CANNOT
PROFESSIONAL I THOUGHT
COMMUNITY IN LIFE PEOPLE
ADEQUATELY A PAID. ENSURE MEDIA
ACCESS TO VACCINATIONS FOLLOW
CONSUMERS WHO ARE SERVED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS I
CAN SAY THAT FAMILIES HAVE
CONTACTED US WHEN. THEY WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR THERE'S I THINK
THE SAME METHODS OF GETTING
INFORMATION OUT CAN IT WILL BE
CAN BE EQUALLY APPLIED IF WE
DON'T MAKE THE SYSTEM TOO
COMPLEX TOO COMPLICATED. FOCUS
IN SUPPORT SELF DETERMINATION
AND DEVELOP A STREAMLINED
PROCESS TO FACILITATE
IMPLEMENTATION WERE LITTLE BODY
DOWN. YOU KNOW WE HEARD BUILD
BACK BETTER AND BIGGER I WOULD
SAY BILL BACK WAY BIGGER WAY
BETTER OUR SYSTEM IS FRACTURED
PRE COATED IN IS IN DIRE NEED.
WE NEED OPTIONS FLEXIBILITY
INNOVATION AND ACCOUNTABILITY I
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO CONCERN IN PUTTING.
ATTENTION TO THESE URGENT NEEDS.
THANK YOU. HAVE A LOT THANK YOU
MA'AM YEAH NEXT CALL PLEASE.
HEY WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
SEEING AS THAT'S THE THIRD TIME
WE'VE CLEARED THE QUEUE I AM
GOING TO TAKE THAT AS OUR FINAL
PUBLIC COMMENT I DO WANNA THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL AS-
EVERYONE WHO'S HELPED TO PUT ON
THIS HEARING HERE TODAY WITH
THAT WE WILL ADJOURN FOR. TODAY
SOMEONE HERE.